[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my gosh
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter and
you're just forced one he wants ticket
into the championship the Snowballs
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
[Music]
oh my gosh entering its Fifth Season 16
teams will reboot the PCL Legacy with a
new format and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion plays phenomenal chess
today and it is coming home
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
happy February 14th everybody some of
you celebrate Valentine's Day we
celebrate the start of the 2023 Pro
chess League season I'm Grand Master
Robert Hess alongside me my good friend
feed a master James Cannon III James how
pumped are you for the PCL to begin well
first off you can't spell chess without
Hess so I'm here with the big Hess
himself the big Flex s everybody know
what it is chat and I'm here with myself
I'm too hyped right now protest league
is awesome and we're gonna have a lot of
fun lots of big teams lots of energy and
we're here with you Chad how you feel as
I'm feeling great and that was an
energetic start there and it's going to
be a fantastic season there are some
important dates for everybody watching
to take note of bring out your calendars
you know today is Valentine's Day go get
those flowers and chocolates but also
note that this is a five-week regular
season March 24th pencil that in your
calendar that's the arena Royale James
that's where the All-Stars of the
protesting they took it out absolutely
all stars as you like the they we call
it the All-Star All-Star team basically
they're also kind of like basketball and
like you see the pro All-Stars type
stuff football too as well but here
you're gonna see everybody clashing out
every team because of course every team
can't play each other but now you get to
see everybody in one little Arena Royale
swinging at each other it's gonna be fun
I'm planning that too you planning that
or what
I'm becompetent so I'll be covering your
games and I hope to recover your games
in the playoffs those are March 30th to
31st and only eight teams make it and of
course the PCL finals May 11th the 14th
only four teams are going the distance
so James it's just the start of the
Season we don't know who is going to be
taking it but let's remind everybody of
the format because it's been a while
since the protest league has been a
thing about 17 months since that Arena
Royale in 2021 the time Patrol 10
minutes plus two second increment and
you get four boards that's the fun part
James why don't you talk a little about
that with board one playing versus Board
four to start well you know board one
board four of course that's a huge
matchup because the underdog I'm always
a big fan of the underdog so the
underdog can swing and strike there oh
first of all that's confidence for the
team the teams are fired up we're
feeling good and if they can strike even
make a draw there sometimes against that
very strong board one I mean you're
gonna be feeling good and a little bit
more confident going in getting some
points on the on the board for the team
there and you never know what can happen
to them later rounds but every nothing's
gonna be easier nothing
nothing because even board fours are
super strong and you play everybody on
their team unless their team gets eight
and a half points early you are gonna
get to see board four for one team
playing board one for another and then
eventually the board numbers will play
each other so uh let's uh you know break
this down because today we start off
with two great teams the Indian yogis
and the Brazil capifaras but every team
in this league is great like if we go
just look down uh The rosters the
captains the managers we're gonna see
some familiar names James Magnus Carlsen
obviously the standout on this one
absolutely of course you got big Magnus
here we see uh we see a mod look at the
chess bras is here you got Nemo is not
just a movie right you know got the real
Nemo here AKA nimstone got Blitz three
mvl the man with three names Fabiano
Carolina you got Magnus there Sam shank
land right come to shankland with
Shanklin it's nice and then you got
David uh Pruis and the chess Dojo chat I
mean this is everything that you're
looking for not only do you have the
streamers but you also have the big time
names we got the big time chips
and today we got the Brazil Capybaras
they're starting the actions the Indian
yogis krikor mechatarian the Portuguese
streaming sensation I should say
Brazilian he speaks in Portuguese but
either way he's got just from on his
Squad look down here Arjun eragisi for
team mgd1 and then prognananda is on the
Indian yogis those Indian teenagers
James we know how dangerous they are I
mean of course look there's something in
the water as I always say man you go
over to India you drink the water you
just feel different okay the chests
you're gonna play different every week
is another GM coming out of India it's
pretty scary in fact I might get some
residency over on our side of India
because whatever they're doing we need
to follow
yeah they are absolute monsters there
and look at these lineups as well the
Gotham Knights I see Hikaru Nakamura I
see Gotham chest leading the way but the
number one name on this graphic for me
is James Canty the third the Jedi is a
Jedi oh watch out oh my goodness man I'm
getting too high I'm sweating I'm not
even playing but of course I do see my
name up there as uh the captain of the
team as we play tomorrow it's gonna be
very very hype a name we're missing
though is a big Hess of flex right big
Flex test right we didn't see it there
so of course we'll get you out I know
your salary cap was too high they
couldn't get you on the team so it's all
good but we'll get you next time I just
love seeing Anna Rudolph The Big Greek
these are the captains for the remaining
squads here the Norway gnomes and the
Berlin bears with some great players I
see Garden State pastures sevian we got
Salem Salem for Norway we got Anton
corba of the Ukrainian legend or the
Berlin bear so every single team in this
league has some of the best talent in
the world and as soon as I say it this
graphic comes up I see chakra starring
for the levitov chess wizard wow you got
Shaq then you got Alexandria Kushner
fresh off her grand uh Grand Prix
women's like just Fresh Off The Win
winning uh I think what's an extra point
or two just snapping literally playing
some excellent chess here I could
monitor Paulina shuvalova right oh she's
super strong she's like 2500 feet right
it's a lot so she's uh she's pushing
type 2 as well as an international
Master lots of strong cars lots of
strong matchups guys anything can happen
for sure the Spanish Maniac shrimps they
deserve a special shout because they
qualified their way into this field but
that's neither here nor there nobody
cares who the qualifier is who the
envity is every team starts out as
equals week one is beginning right now
the matchup that we are going to see
first today is the India yogis taking on
the Brazil Capybaras following that will
be the Charlotte cobras against the
Canada chess bras and I think we you
know everyone is excited for that second
match of today because a certain person
I don't know if you know him Magnus
Carlson will be taking on the likes of
down your neraditski on the Charlotte
cobra that's gonna be Magnus versus
narodisky on the cobras that's gonna be
amazing guys there's lots of energy then
you got the Indian young I mean this is
scary when like an Indian team oh yeah
I'm team two India well what's your
radio like we all like 2600 that's your
second team what do you mean right so
it's very scary to see what they're
going to do with those copy Bears there
is very strong
um as they uh they have a very good team
too as well so it's a lot of Chess man a
lot of fun I'm excited to see the strong
chest today and of course tomorrow you
will not be commentating your team is
playing you got the Garden State passer
taking on the levitov chest Wizards
that's going to be a fun one and then we
got The Maniacs rooms taking on the
Gnomes uh some familiar faces the Gnomes
we've seen them approaches League
Seasons past but the Maniacs trims
that's an awesome team name absolutely
of course and in fact when he uh talked
about um how did you get the name he was
like yeah we just kind of threw it out
there and it like it just happened like
it was like a random name generator and
we liked it and it just was there and
now we're uh you know they maybe Maniac
shrimps but their game is nowhere near a
shrimp okay
and then the rest of the week we'll see
matches on Thursday and Friday it's
always going to be a double header you
should be excited for that uh it's just
really a fun start to the pro chess
League season and you can always go
online look up the rules look up the
teams but the rules that's important
because it's a little bit different than
what you may be used to you need to have
an average team rating that does not
cross the uh 2550 margin and you see
that you need two female players one
Junior one 2003 or later and once you're
on the team you stay there unless James
you boot them out you are you know a
captive for a team what do you think
you're gonna be booting out any players
from your squad no hey look if you're
not performing up to par hey look I love
you you know we we paid you to get here
um and we're gonna take some of that a
little bit of that back maybe kidding
maybe not but also at the same time we
will uh we got to do what we got to do
so we can make it because we gotta win
three Hales and you're out of there
all right well we we heard it from James
himself that if you're not performing up
to the task for the Garden State passers
you may be passed over and someone else
may be filling up the roster uh but we
do have some Stars some amazing lineups
for the teams that are about to kick off
2023 protest League season the India
yogis we see Vida Gujarati he is the top
of the rating leaderboard for the squad
but look right under him you got
prognanda Neo and Robert what is this
hey they cheat bro hey get the yeah we
need to get them checked my guy look at
this you got V you got pragy you know
your knee-hole and then when you thought
it was oh okay I got past the scary ones
no you didn't you got runx advani you
gotta add wraith here he's a superstar
all the way down to Elizabeth Bates who
just played in the fide Grand Prix
women's right you got parnesh here this
is strong this is only one Indian team
it's very scary over in it
and there is going to be a you know one
playing every single match so as you
mentioned Elizabeth Pates and vaishali
that's just dangerous territory for the
other teams and well they have a tough
matchup ahead of them today against the
Brazil copy bars but we may see the
likes of Elizabeth page that's where
they may shine some of these boards I
mean board four plays board one and so
on look at this lineup right this team
represents South America and of course
we got a capybara it's a cuddly rodent
but this team is anything but cuddly we
know Jose Martinez number three there
Josh boom Beast oh yeah absolutely
Jasmine is super strong as we know him
he beats he's beating everyone on
chess.com in fact so of course we have a
very strong player there's soupy yeah
Mauricio here Alexander fear all these
guys are extremely strong you got Cree
core two Creek or the Kraken right very
strong players so they have all these
GMS here that are ready to take down or
at least challenge this Indian team that
is maybe a slight favor but at the same
time okay it's PCL lots of Vibes here
lots of energy lots of strong chats I'm
fighting for my team so hey you know
it's gonna be anything but easy today
brilliant and I mean all the way down to
the bottom of this rust right uh Julia
Alvarado she's very strong she's
actually gaining rating points uh
they're using the November supplement so
if you're having good tournaments since
then you're underrated for this league
and some players are even better at the
rapid tide controls than classical chess
relatively speaking and Irina bomaga
Romanian International Master She's
Dangerous right if she's going to be
playing all four players in the opposing
team but she can take down the grand
Masters oh absolutely I'm sure she can
and especially when they have these
underrated teams I've seen some like
Irina crush is uh is like on a board
four or something I was like four four
that's just insane like that's that's
the lowest like what are you in a crush
right this is very tough of course
especially when you have these very
strong underrated women on the team here
to to uh let's be heavy and big points
on the board
yeah and James I mean while we have you
for a moment the games are going to
begin shortly how did you come up with
your roster like what was the that
process like of building a team of
course the better team part a little bit
of a salary cap so I can see who we can
reach out to of course we all did a
little bit of our um our due diligence
there but we just kind of reached out to
see what we could do make it a little
bit interesting from there and ask
people a few questions like uh hey what
do you feel like uh what do you like
about this about uh what can you bring
to our team basically what do you think
expectations are in ETC and we I think
we have a very nice lineup especially
starting with big Sam I Am Sabian
well I think a team with high
expectations will be the India Yogi's I
mean that team as we saw they've got all
those teenagers in Prague to Nanda
they've got Roundup they've got nihal
sarin they are super strong and well
they have some great matchups today some
of their best players right the
country's best
starring on board one for them and he is
in fact playing today and here we see
board one versus Board four that is how
you start every single match in the
protest League arena bomaga she'll have
her work cut out for her but she gets
the white pieces James and we know
upsets happen in the PCO yeah white
piece is too having those white pieces
is definitely an advantage there now we
are able to
um strike quickly but uh any any sense
guys it's really just about who can get
off and running in this first round
maybe the first two rounds here but I
see a video going up to board four we
got board two playing board three and
this is like this every round here so
I'm excited to see what they do in this
first round what's your prediction what
do you think is gonna happen next
it's huge to get off to a good start
right because if you are like three to
one after this first uh round of action
then your team is clawing back it's
tough I think that Brazil capybara is
right on paper you look at their lineup
and it's kind of The Underdogs and I
heard you say earlier you're rooting for
the underdogs and you look at this line
of soupy he had that famous win with the
fishing pole against Magnus Carlson we
have Jasper who is a monster and a
streamer but in classical chess his
rating isn't as high as some of the
others and Alexander fear he's they
strikes the fear into the hearts of his
opponents when he's had his best but I
gotta be honest James after saying all
that I still like the Indian yogis in
this one I mean look at this lineup top
to bottom it's like you know the super
teams in the NBA right when you're like
you have a super team that's exactly
what you feel like with India every team
they have it's just something different
over there so everybody wants to beat
the Indian teams here so I think even
being underdogs with Brazil uh they are
they have a lot to prove they're like
yeah cool India's strong and all I know
your water's all magical but we about to
show you you know uh Brazil can fight
just as hard if not harder today we have
actually even seen upsets even though
Spanish Maniac shrimps in fact we
thought the Ferocious tacticians were
going to be able to make it into the
qualifier but in fact it was actually
the Spanish Maniac shrimps who we really
didn't think we're gonna make
right and I think that we should call
for chat to get involved let us know who
you think will win between India and
Brazil because this matchup I believe on
paper we have the highest rated player
for the India yogis but Brazil tends to
be stacked with those 2600 rated players
no quick work today that's a bit sad for
me he's a good buddy of ours and he's a
superstar streamer from Brazil uh if you
speak Portuguese and he also streams in
English as well but if you can you
should give quick course Channel a
follow so James I'm super pumped for the
season to get underway the teams are
getting set up just making sure that
everything is under control that their
Tech is all good that the fair play
calls they're doing those cameras I'm
pumped I'm pumped too cameras look you
know make sure the cameras are right the
money's on the line make sure you got
your right music of course that you
usually don't have any music while
you're playing this stuff but also just
being pumped getting in the right
mindset because you're about to play for
the team here every Point counts play
every game out 10 minutes two seconds
increment lots of emotions here and you
gotta play and put those to the side and
remember look I gotta play this for the
team just play my best chess and we'll
see what happens that's what the great
say
for sure it's hard sometimes to remember
that you're in a team event because
chess is usually an individual game you
just focus on your pieces your board but
if your team is down maybe you have to
have a conversation like I gotta play
for a win all of a sudden and I feel
like that's difficult for chess players
James you have experience in the
protestly you know what it's like but
kind of how do you switch that mindset
from just playing your own game just
kind of looking out for your team
teammates and score overall well a lot
of times actually believe it or not it's
actually saying it you know hey I this
is for the team so when you just say
that you just it feels different this
for the team now you know it's bigger
than myself now I'm not going to resign
this game I'm going to play this out and
you magically you know things happen of
course especially when you do things for
uh bigger than yourself right so I think
you do have to really put yourself in
that team mindset and understand that
look this is a grind set for the team we
have to do this we got to get it done oh
I didn't miss that I heard that grind
set I like that you always come up with
the the clever names for things and
you're right though I mean I do think
team chemistry is important in chess
despite the fact that it's not
basketball you're not passing the ball
to other people but I do think that if
you can compare it together if you like
your teammates that works out well and
we see actually the players I mean
they're really getting set right now
they're locking in I saw some people we
have them off in a separate monitor the
players kind of like almost praying you
know getting ready for the chest to
begin now get your Mantra right you know
what I'm saying do some stretches do
some pull-ups however hats I heard you
can do 50 pull-ups in a row look at him
from the camera he doesn't pull ups
today chat my goodness but of course
yeah it's uh it's about that man it's
about getting getting pumped getting in
the right mindset getting ready whatever
you have to do to to be ready to play
this very very strong and this exciting
intense chess
for sure and the action will get
underway very shortly as some of the
players are getting set we see that
viticusrati is taking on Irina bumaga in
the first matchup Ward one plays against
board four you see them on the screens
in front of you and well that's going to
be a tall task for balmaga but she is
capable she's an international master
from Romania she has played some of the
very best players in the world so let's
see how she does today E4 on the board
here we go E4 for the score okay and D6
wow
you don't see that one very often
no you don't and we got a modern and I
it might be did it feeling like he needs
to win so he's planning to sort of fill
a door position where the queen trade
can happen immediately if this Pawn on
D4 right if we see the swap of pieces
here oh and she doesn't do it well you
can often see a queen trade as early as
the first or moves the game absolutely
not a big fan
uh trade them queens and I'm just like
well we can go to sleep bro you know
like it's immediately uh usually better
for black enough positions too as well
uh black can just kind of grind it out
all the way so I like the decision to
keep the pieces
okay I like the energy I like it
I feel like this is a moment where
you're like Rook G1 we're having some
fun so let's see ghosts he's gonna throw
that part off the board oh big heads
y'all hear him has yeah it has to be
rubbing off on them chat you hear that I
have G4 for the score there it is and it
takes on D4 I'm taking white all day now
obviously there is uh of course on the
E4 Pawn you can deal with and I mean
there's some weaknesses like E4 and G4 a
little bit they might be a little
overextended a little bit sometimes but
it can be weaker and it can be targeted
for like a nice c527 type stuff but I do
like white for the aspect of uh this
reminds me of some type of um freak
attack Knight or Sicilian or you also
have just G4 lines in jobava London's
that I'm familiar with even G4 and
terminals very very nice uh to have this
G Pawn up H4 is coming G5 Bishop D2 E2
Queen D2 Castle Queen side and just
literally go for me this is a very very
uh attractive position for it
yeah so white can't throw the pawn
forward but we see that Arena she's
taking her time here because she's not
sure do I push the pawn up to G5
immediately and then the Knight has to
vacate the F6 square or should she keep
that the threat sometimes is stronger
than the execution uh James I like your
plan man just throw the pawn throw the
bishop out let's get a castle Queen side
going I feel like white has everything
you could ask for in the early going and
she shows more strength than I could
have right exactly absolutely Bishop E3
played here this looks great this should
be three Castle quickly I mean do we go
Queen D2 Castle's F3 there's a D5 coming
in there interesting it's different it's
like there's some stuff there's some
stuff you got to watch out for here
especially when they Castle quickly like
that so we use Castle whoa he went back
to E8 was on the move huh wow yeah it
should be two yikes right that that
Knight would have just been captured off
that square snapped off so I'm expecting
some H4 H5 but you mentioned the move D5
and I think some point that is going to
come into the equation the Blackstone
plays C6 and maybe D5 they tell you if
you're getting a attacked on a flag you
got to strike back in the center that's
a great way of doing so for vivid
absolutely strike uh yeah playing on the
wings should be countered with play in
the center so D5 definitely should be
coming Black's pieces aren't quite
cramped in fact we do need to figure out
where to put our pieces at we got to get
everything out here and this is the
problem that you can face in the Phila
door specif you don't know what to do or
how to get the pieces out and the next
few moves here I mean this could be plus
everything right
um if if black does not get the pieces
out white has pretty easy play just gets
exactly Queen to D2 develop the bishop
Castle move the H Pawn very easy easy uh
moves to make for white here I think
Vita is going to have to come up with
something spectacular it can be very
accurate at this point before we fall
into a worse position
the best thing that bit is doing is he's
playing quickly but he is going to have
to really consider it not just H4 maybe
there's an F4 F5 at some moment as well
I I feel you James I know why you love
this position for white it just feels
like the moves are easier the plans are
more straightforward what is Black's
plan did it trying to figure that out
right now does he play C6 open up this
diagonal for the queen
um it's night this night this bishop
they're not really playing James that's
the big problem that video is trying to
figure out absolutely you see right
there he's in he's in the zone just
thinking you see him hands on the head
here what do I do I need to make some
moves see fine I am a big fan of this I
like uh the fan of I'm a fan of the
tempo is what they say so a lot of times
the tempo gives you time so when we have
the time here C5 now allows me to get my
queen out next move if you make the
maybe Knight F3 I may have a queen F5
Knight B3 stopping any type of unit 5. I
made the tempo so now I'm gonna I need
to uh do something else maybe
it's the next move here ask what you're
thinking I the thing about this is it's
it's nice in terms of getting the tempo
as you're saying but strategically it's
terrible because white gets his D5
Square forever there's no Pawn back to
C6 you'd love to be able to kick a
knight that lands here D6 is an eyesore
we're gonna go after that so we would if
the pawn were on the A6 we're playing B5
we know A6 we met by A4 is taking away
that option from black I like everyone's
position I actually think she has a
sizable advantage and her position
remains easier to play James what do you
think about black maybe pushing this F
Pawn at some point I actually did think
of that yeah I didn't think that because
you have to have some type of activity
you have to have active pieces as uh
Gary says you have um what is it uh
peace activity trumps material most
times so if you have uh okay material
deficit right but how active is my piece
is so I mean this could be very bad I
think F5 definitely has to be played at
some point just to get the pieces active
I can't move the Knight on EA because D6
hangs the Knight on B7 where do I
actually put it maybe E5 that's a good
Square to start with but that is a
voluntarily Bishop E2 followed by an F4
now so Queen side D6 has pressure
there's problems even with Knight to C5
or Bishop C5 because the queen is loose
loose meaning undefended on d8 there's
lots of problems here for black and also
with this time you know with the time
here is not not the greatest so there's
all kind of uh tactics that you have to
look out for for video here
let's see what happens showing I'm just
showing you a great point that the queen
is left undefined on d8 so a careless
move like Knight V6 would just drop that
pawn on C5 right away so you have to
keep that under lock and key for viticus
wrathi and he is now down on time he had
nine and a half minutes we were just
saying that okay his time Advantage is
what could be useful for him now he's
down to the clock and has a tough
position Arena off to a great start for
Brazil and there is a staggered start
for the games so uh the first board for
India the fourth board for Brazil they
started in a minute later uh the board
two versus Board three matchup began so
we can of course get around as much as
we'd like uh but I'm curious what bit it
will do here I am actually trying to
find a good move too as well a good plan
at least like sometimes well if you
don't have a plan you have to try to
find a good few moves and then you you
can make plan later obviously so I mean
maybe 95 Bishop E2 maybe just get the
pieces out 95 it's just it's a Tempo
make you move something and then play
Bishop out next Bishop somewhere at
least it's better than having my pieces
where they are right now at four I might
get pushed back though like sheesh F4
f5's there my goodness what how is this
not plus five right the engine's like uh
oh yeah it's a equal this is why it's
it's um very very important to take the
engine with a grain of saw here
understand it this is a practical game
human versus human so it's difficult as
a human but the engine's like oh it's
like equal yeah we don't care what the
engine has to say did it doesn't know
that it should be equal and he's
spending a lot of time while he does
let's go to the bird's eye view we have
all four games of this match underway uh
we see that in the top left that's the
game we've been looking at between vidit
and Arena and did it plays A5 he's
throwing his pawns up the board he says
I need to strike now I'm a fan of that
but look at the bottom left game there
Jose Martinez that's Jasper Brazil
taking on board three Abdullah get him
Billy from Azerbaijan but he's playing
for the India team what in the world
that is spicy James I think we should go
right into that one absolutely I don't
even know what opening that was that was
like son what is this double ponzie I
have no idea just open it kind of a
bishop out early very spicy Queen on H5
with the H6 Pawn hanging some F4
possibilities two Bishops versus Bishop
Knight very scary stuff big fan of it I
do like a fan of Mike's position looks
like we're attacking black does have
some defensive possibilities Queen F6
looking good
um at some point for black but gotta see
what happens after you even get here
yeah it's also White's turn and look at
Jocelyn's clock that's Jose Martinez
with the black pieces he is nine minutes
44 seconds so they start at 10. he's
barely spent any time his King is wide
open there's this bishop you know trying
to slice across here the queen is uh
gonna pick off the spawn H6 but I guess
we have to do a material count James
Black currently actually has extra
material black is up a pawn white spawn
structure is shattered and it's clear to
me that if the queen takes H6 this queen
is coming to F6 let's offer Queen trade
get those ladies off the board and once
that's done it feels like the attack has
run out of steam and then Black's
position is better the pawn structure is
better absolutely Pawn structure being
better Pawn structure being the skeleton
of the game in fact anything else gives
you your plans and ideas here and blacks
is very simple here even with the bishop
pair of course having an open position
you do want to get rid of one of these
Bishops ASAP so Queen F6 definitely
going to allow us to uh bring some
safety to our King and try to trade one
of these Bishops off Knight takes G3 on
tap and also Bishop takes E4 we are able
to trade the light Square Bishop which
is usually looks like is a Little Bit
Stronger here in this position here
honestly I mean an engine likes white
but looking at practically okay what
we've mentioned here black definitely
has some great chances I mean after
taking upon Queen F6 I guess we have to
trade Queen H5 runs into what happens on
H5 maybe just more development right
we'll bring our Bishop out
attack with your queen at the moment for
white that's not enough material but I'm
feeling you I think we got to keep our
Queens on the board if we're Abdullah I
don't think you want a queenless
position
absolutely yeah absolutely not here with
Bishops are sharp swipe the board
this way to move though so we got to
come up with something and we're down to
pawn we are playing Joss Stone too all
that comes into place you look how hot
the time is that five minutes there
buddy yeah
that's a five and for Jose he's got nine
minutes and 44 seconds so he is in his
preparation that's scary news for
Abdullah again and Bailey who is trying
to make a great start for the India team
he is from Azerbaijan they picked him up
he's kind of a ringer out there he's
really talented he's a youngster uh he
is Got The Grandmaster title in recent
uh years but uh you know he has his work
cut out for him because Jocelyn what are
you doing Johnson he's a youngster how
old is he
he's like 21 maybe oh man he looked
gladly older than that Master beard it's
uh and the well I guess that's just how
it is bearded a mustache I was I thought
he was at least the mid-20s
very adult there Queen it's what we tell
ourselves to make us ourselves feel
better when they beat us right like no I
bet that's uh
yeah bro I'm 37 bro
oh well look at Jose he just brings his
Bishop out protecting night here
stopping anything on the diagonal Knight
takes G3 now may Force more pieces off
the board I can just rook and slide up
to E6 to kick that Queen out of here and
whoa he took your idea you were
mentioning Bishop takes Knight and he
says let's go for it obstacle the
Bishops it's not just to draw we got an
attack going let's open up that game I
actually am a big fan of that move
that's a very strong move here now we
have to figure out what to do afterwards
with the obstacle the Bishops of course
you cannot defend with the opposite
color Bishop so if we get a bishop to F6
then the light Square Bishop is doing
literally nothing at all you cannot help
or defend the squares on the dot squares
obviously so we have to try to take
advantage of this after Bishop E4 we
might see something like an F4 strange
move and F4 but after the ideas after GF
we played Bishop H4 and then Bishop F6
and bring the pieces into the play here
it looks very strong of course all kinds
of things are happening and mice should
be winning those type of situations so I
really like actually why it was a great
practical Choice especially before it
was a nice spot
yeah actually in this line after it
takes F4 I'm not sure what you're
supposed to do because now the Pawn's
under attack twice we just said you
can't take because the bishop doesn't
take back it slides to the rim or hits
the queen and then plants itself on the
F6 square with Checkmate to follow so
that means you might have to give up a
pawn and this is where opposite colored
Bishops play a part but Jocelyn says
whoa whoa whoa were you guys talking
about Bishop takes E4 it comes my rook
and look at Adam Bailey he switches
ideas F4 would have been the choice now
he plays rookie one he wants that Rook
trade James because wait a sec I have
the only open file over here yeah you
could slide your Rook to ba that's not
doing much and the queen look at that
queen that is just an annoying piece in
Black's Camp love this queen here on H6
absolutely of course uh yeah the queen
is definitely hindering King the the
king movement the G5 Pawn is like why is
your oppon on G5 right like if you just
got to the position you're like how did
you get your Pawn in G5 what's going on
here it's a very strange situation right
so you can definitely see the king
safety is uh not there for black as much
and after work take CB1 we have stuff
like F4 once again Bishop H4 I mean that
four move is really going to be strong
there there are some challenges here for
for Jose
there certainly are so after Rook 81
finally Jose he's burning some clocks so
while he does that he's gonna have to be
thinking hopefully my teammates can
strike because he's in some danger here
let's look at how the teammates are
doing we have all four boards underway
in the top left look at Arena's position
unfortunately it's falling apart did it
Gujarati too strong uh just such a
powerful player and then the top right
James look at that game where black is
on the attack both those Rooks that is
aravind chidambaram or India versus
interfere those Rooks are barreling down
at the white king wow these Rooks as a
car will say these nice those Rooks look
very nice on
um on the G and H files there we need a
light Square Bishop maybe we don't need
it but of course as you see we do know
that black is the one on the attack here
Bishop to G5 it's a nice rule unless you
want to trade it off E4 e5's hanging a
little light yeah definitely back for
favorite for Choice pushing for sure why
don't we dive into that game because the
last movie played Bishop G5 an
interesting one usually when you're
attacking you want more pieces he says
let's trade Bishops because once this
bishop takes an F5 The Rook slides up
the board and it's both here and there
you don't know if we're gonna double in
the G file or if I'm going to bring my
Rook over the H file and try to
Checkmate you down here not to mention
the E5 Pawn is under attack this queen
the bishop was on E7 the queen can slide
down James I see the eval bar to my eyes
this is completely over but the
evaluation bar is saying yeah only a bit
better for black oh of course absolutely
right the evil bar the evaluation about
this bar sometimes you have no idea why
it says the things that it says here
practically guys you know you would
choose black here in this position the
Rooks are there my Rook is still on A1
right development is huge develop your
pieces get them off the back ring is
that the move
that's not a move I've heard somebody
before that is not a movie fella oh my
goodness then the stretcher to his
address we got it on file or cage five
uh BG start a new one yeah yeah you can
just hit the button my guy hit the
button hit the button Rook H5 hit the
button
you see the EVAP bar is just taken right
that's going all the way down and if we
can bring analysis board up we could
show you the reason why is the only way
to deal with the threat of Rook takes
Knight would be either to move the
Knight out the way but then you get
checked back here you lose your queen or
you have to bring your Rook after Rook
H5 to H3 but after this trade I mean the
attack rages on this Pawn is under
attack this queen slides over black
won't even be down any material with the
attack against the enemy King so maybe
there's another idea after F4 because
yeah because you see the engine went
down after work H5 oh maybe it's a clean
engine like that maybe it's queenish
sick yeah I think it's just give up The
Rook for this night down here going
after the king uh that's a hard move to
play so if arvind finds it and you see
that he hasn't moved yet because in
bullet chess James we're all playing
Rook H5 Rick H5 and we live easy yeah
easy but now that he's thinking I feel
like he's gonna play Queen H7 I need
seven so what's the combo here Coe
calculate check calculate chat by the
way shout out to chat thanks for the 10
gifted Subs here we see you 10 gifted
Subs so a night a work H5 was played he
played Rick H5 the Knight F1 now
okay so he's just saying you know what
let's just uh get into a turtle shell
right Knight goes to F1 you check me
here you're not winning my queen because
the king slides out the 90's in the way
and James look at the clock situation
black is down on the clock by a bit and
they get that increment so that's
important but King is snaked out maybe
you can just bring your queen out to G4
Rook to F3 things like that I do love
black how could you not referendum
for you give me all that give me that
appreciate the generosity there my guy
Queen F3 Rook H for now anyway oh wow
he's running away at 53 and then check
how do you run away from it he's like
trying to get over there somewhere oh
twice in the same game that's a classy
move though 97 we're looking at forcing
lines he says let's improve my knight
let's get to F5 over here and we're
hitting this Rook maybe the Knight will
continue its Journey over to age four of
Rook E1 good defensive move James I like
the way that Alex fear is defending
himself oh absolutely one thing about
being a strong player is you have to
have the defense part right defense win
championships now of course that's not
all the time but here I mean you have to
have some offense too it was very nice
to see the 97 Knight F5 move but I think
you have to say you gotta love the
tenacity and the defense here from
Amazon in fear here and you don't see
the Breakthrough yet it's not all the
way over yet and of course if I'm able
to get a few moves here you know slide
my a work into the game actually run my
king to B1 and I mean okay we're here
this is a long shot but it's very
possible and if I can get upon the G3 H2
check I mean you you're gonna have to
sign the exchange I'm up in exchange at
that point it is possible but I think uh
White is actually doing a nice job
holding right now especially look at the
time bro you about to go under a minute
you gotta move yeah you got to move
because if you make one slip all of a
sudden White's extra Pawn will make its
presence felt especially if this King
can start sprinting put on those Nikes
run over to C2 and get on out of there
so I feel like this is dangerous
territory for Arvin he brings his Rook
back I think G3 looks automatic to me
you need a protection
does that there it is Rook H3 he wants
he wants all the action
all the action that's a lot of action on
the G3 Square bro oh my goodness how do
you even hold that you're right like
that might be a wrap for that part
um sheesh rookie 395 Rook D3 Rook gate
yeah I mean maybe you get away but then
Queenie two C4 E3 I somehow know you're
losing that pawn bro yeah
I feel like you gotta do something sad
like this you know like rookie two run
away with your king bring your Rook to a
passive Square uh but give it give him
the clock situation there is a chance
and by the way vinegars are out there he
won his game pretty convincingly against
Irina bumaga it was a nice start for her
she had uh aggressive intentions but it
never came to fruition and then it was
able to just crash through on the queen
side and win that game for the yogis
other three games still are in session
including this one here between
Alexander fear with the white pieces for
the Brazil caviaras and Arvin
chidambaram you know the black pieces or
India yogis but look at this rookie two
he Slide the king
the problem is you can't go Rook G2
because Rook cheese has always been by
Knight H4 thanks to the pin on the third
ring oh my goodness right it's a Family
Channel come on Robert
that's gonna hurt Knight H4 and get him
out of here wait wait wait wait wait he
might have allowed Rook did you we can
announcement
no longer works
I'm just gonna take it and look at you
all crazy yeah you know
just working on my tactics today I'm
looking out for him a knight H4 looks
like it's winning the queen is loose
here but you see the eval bar go Sky
High because once you take this Knight
it unleashes The Rook to the enemy queen
as well you take mine I take yours thank
you very much I'm up a good night on F1
oh my gosh and look at the clock James
under a minute for black under a minute
whoa that's very scary play D4 I'm a big
fan of it open it up try to get some
pieces in there but he needs to move
fast obviously it's a two second
increment I mean a huge time edge here
for Alexander
and look at Arvin by the way you know
he's diving into the computer he's
working so hard at the board he just you
can barely see his head on the screen
but D4 do not take that don't allow that
Knight it's the D4 Square I think you
have to allow this capture at some point
and say your knight for now can't get
any further into the position
maybe okay well if you want I was like
maybe we'll see one but Rick D1 he went
to the D1 route
Rook C1 with it well okay we've got some
moves he has to move quick so you got me
with that King right King F2 oh yeah he
says let me just keep everything nice
and compact here uh Knight H4 ideas of
course no longer work the whole point is
The Rook was on H3 uh Knight E3 is taken
care of by this Knight on F1 or is it
can we get away with this move oh a
spicy take I just take with the king I
like them I was hoping you'd you know
fall for a trap but no you're sure
you're like I have no fear I'm James
candy the third you're not gonna scare
me you're right yeah I'm a Jedi out here
so 93. yeah 936 King takes and I'm just
chilling yeah I look good as long as
long as you can't get to the king but I
mean there is it's definitely risky oh
engine it did not like that move very
much but of course what is the move is
it no G4 doesn't work
he's setting up 93 now though now we
know what his intentions are that's what
you want somebody Queen E4 then yeah
just uh put it in the center of the
board centralize and threaten G4
actually
is like the move that I never would have
thought of but not that you've mentioned
it it kind of stops all of Black's plans
although there isn't quite Rook takes
everyone I'm looking for tactics on this
square but with the uh we ain't pinning
this Knight you're not going to get away
with things so wow we need four what a
cold blooded move it's a very strong
move but I mean what else do we have is
there anything else anybody's cleaning
for very strong okay and now 15 seconds
none whatsoever but look at the clock
I'd be scared if I were Arvin yeah right
but a fear to fear my guy 12 is that 12
seconds is that 12 yeah your eyes do not
deceive you and G4 is a fork but Queen
slides up to H4 with check so you can't
get away with G4 I mean it's not
necessarily a bad move but does not win
material the queen goes up to H4
yeah this is uh okay what do I do about
this now it's not over 12 seconds and I
still need to finish
and he runs away where's the Knight
going
I don't know he got out the way oh man
no fear they put in his last name to
trick you boy three seconds here boy
Whoa
oh yeah he's in the back that was kind
of always there so now he just gets to
oh we just go Rook G1 I think take take
and this whole thing James I know you're
the Jedi I know you're really good at
bullet you try to sort of flag arvind
this you got 5.8 seconds there is a two
second increment but you kind of play
for the clock at this moment for fear
you know I remember playing uh the I am
not a GM speed test championships with
these one second increments I mean it
was one second then and you know I was
it was tough it was not the same so the
two seconds oh no I'm not trying to flag
you I gotta finish this boy out I have
to finish him like finish him right you
know like I have to finish this out or
you know they can come back because of
that two second increment oh look at
that Queen speaking of coming back the
queen says let me get around here oh my
goodness
with just seconds on his clock James
that was brilliant a comeback he says
don't call the comeback I've been here
for years and that Queen snakes into A3
and it's going to attack this King and
this Pawn is the hero on on D3 is just
doing the work all you had to do was
take a little bit of extra time chat now
of course it is hard to do that when the
opponent has less time this is why you
don't play their time I mean how many
games have we lost OTB where you just
wanted to move oh I'm trying to flag my
opponent he got three minutes left and
then you lose the game in that last
crucial moment right this whole game he
was holding so much more time and now as
you see this is the moment when they
start to use most of their time right
you use your time when you start losing
that's the hard part so it's really
tough about Chess right I feel like and
you see I see a head shake there he's
trying to figure it out and now he's
starting to use his time here when he
had like two minutes left and it's
already over yeah Black's play is
automatic the queen is either gonna take
the pawn or slide into this B2 square
with check the king will have to step to
the first rank oh my gosh he's running
up but this queen being out of the
street Queen E2 D2 everything two it's
all right yeah this is no fun for Alex
fear and you're right though he did so
well to survive but when does Queen went
to fa it's like he wasn't even thinking
about the queen where's the queen going
yeah immediately he moved too quickly
there pretty tough
pretty tough oh my goodness right and
then you see the clock and you like come
on bro he had no time and then you start
kicking himself and then you start
asking yourself should I knock
everything over in front of me right now
um at the table nope don't do that
because it's just expensive stuff
he won King of the Hill he lost his Rook
now on e4 that's a resignation huge win
for the India yogis there and they got
off to a great start in this match
because Vida Gujarati he won with the
black pieces we see on board two the top
right of our screen that was a win for
our event and we still have one game
still in play and it's soupy against
vaishali but Charlie is board four for
the India yogis but look at that eval
bar it says uh sorry what am I I'm the
best and she is winning this position
that's practice sir right yeah yeah I
mean of course you can see uh that
family is just real strong right
probably the dog probably 1400 ELO at
least the dog crazy you know that whole
family strong boy so very strong stuff
here soupy is going to have to pull a a
rabbit out of the Hat here or some type
of animal out to hat here because this
is a capybara about that because it's
not working right now I mean what does
she have four pawns and a bishop for one
row I don't think that's enough
wow look at that very strong
it's a big game she's having a great
tournament success too as well if you
guys been following and playing very
strong chess
she got great experience recently
because she played in the tops of Steel
Challengers tournament where every
single opponent was like 200 rating
points above her uh so that's great
experience like Grand Master after
Grandmaster and she's showing that while
that result well you know of course it
was a tough event for her she still did
pretty well she can beat very strong GMS
like soupy in in a game and we see just
a domination of the pawns here that's
connect three but that does win new
games of Chess yeah connect three right
yes nice shot and connect three here and
then you win the game very easy maybe
you just go D6 don't even think about it
C7 whatever you want yeah it looks like
everything should be good but she's now
done under seven seconds She's Gotta Go
she's thinking yeah okay you gotta move
whoa hey hello you there all right there
it is it was getting low getting a
little scared there at D6 played if the
Rook takes a knight you can throw in a
check and then push the Deep on not
going to be able to stop that pawn
getting to the other side but I feel
like soupy has some outside chances here
if he could give up his Rook for a pawn
and somehow win the others he needs to
win all three of these pawns for a rook
that's just easier said than done yeah
CEO okay okay look at him wait he wants
the eight there oh my goodness Rook b87
oh but he plays 97 anyway
but that would have been nasty that's
such a nasty idea when you like give up
a piece to fill the squares right he's a
physical right right no I think yeah
this is beautiful we're CA coming next
yikes
great controlled by her right she had no
time on the clock things were looking a
bit shaky and she says I've got it under
control look at these pawns here very
impressive yeah give me that you can't
stop Rook C8 definitely in the blood
definitely uh prags blood there as you
can see you know he's the same way
composed all the time keep your
composure play the position and you know
even Under Pressure right you try to
keep your composure and that's what
she's doing as you can see doesn't look
phased with four seconds on the clock
not shaking you don't see anything she's
not you know when you really in the zone
when you're like losing or like uh not
losing like you're in time trouble here
and it's very crucial critical moment
you lean in right oh that's a move okay
get the root back but you lean in and
she's like not even like you know you
can tell she's just neutral you can
she's also composer there three pawns
and this is terrible news for Brazil
because they already lost uh this first
round of action it's you play uh to the
first tennis scores eight and a half
points they're down two and a half half
right now it starts to be three and a
half they're getting bullied oh my
goodness I told y'all look at some of
that Indian water it is scary but of
course the Brazil capabiras do have a
they have a chance but we can't start
fast we have to strike back now this is
like almost a Muslim situation first a
half wins this happens again I mean that
could be GG that's it that's seven
points right real quick and be done and
be out of there and then uh with eight
and a half being the match that's a
funny move let's stop the check you know
but here comes the bishop and then the
pawn by the way Suki's playing on a
track pad you see that a touch pad yeah
yeah that the trackpad game is uh I'm
not with that that's hard to do
that's hard to do
yeah if I showed it with a big dub there
for the India yogis they dominated round
one James three and a half half is the
score in favor India yogis but Brazil
does have a chance to bounce back wow
yeah they have a chance to bounce back
and it needs to be right now you got to
use everything that you can't make only
thing that was the only point you got
was a drop with Jose Martinez Johnson
movie they all know but of course it was
just not enough it's not enough three
and a half to a half India is off to a
higher hot stuff and it could have maybe
been forced here we loved the position
for Gavin Bailey with the attack against
the black king but Jocelyn he held
steady he gets the draw for them and
that's the nature of the protest League
some weeks one team just gets out to a
blistering hot start goes up to by Squad
three and a half a Brazil can't bounce
back James as a captain what do they
gotta do
well of course you get uh first thing I
remember is Hikaru has this quote a long
time ago maybe two and a half some years
ago I remember him saying every loss
every time you have a loss you have to
have a short-term memory loss that's
easier said than done but you just have
to keep rolling you got to keep moving
if you think about the last loss it's
not going to work you have to go in
there with no emotion right leave your
emotions at the door at the board and
actually play the game play the board in
front of you and hopefully hope for the
best so that's all we can do all right
well they're gonna keep rolling we're
gonna keep rolling as well I'm gonna
head to a short break and win return it
is round two of this match between the
India yogis and the Brazil Capybaras
capping off the starting capping off
that means the end beginning the 2023
approaches League season
foreign
so I loved puzzles I loved solving any
puzzle you put in front of me so chess
was unnatural for my brain it was the
unsolvable puzzle it wasn't one of those
things you just looked at here is the
puzzle what's the solution it it was a
puzzle inside of an enigma inside of a
mystery like what is this game and there
was so much to it the more you learned
the more there was to learn so that
puzzle solving uh gift that I had or
desire wish you know I was crossword
puzzles back in the day as well as a
little as a high school kid fell in love
with New York Times crossword puzzles
had to do one of those every every day
that the puzzle came out in the paper so
I always was a puzzle solver and I think
that that made it easy for me to to
transfer over that skill set to chess
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the protest league has just started we
saw the India yogis jump out to a three
and a half half lead over the Brazil
copy bars James that was an exciting
start if you're an India fan if you're
Brazil that probably wasn't so much fun
absolutely it just wasn't that fun here
uh Jose was the only one to strike
anything to be and put some points on
the board it was and it was half a point
it wasn't a win there so of course that
definitely hurts as the uh Brazil
Brazilian team we just got to bounce
back like yo get our head in the game we
can play this game too we just gotta
bounce back a little warm up little
Jitters here also very strong chest of
course there are some chances for both
sides um and for in every game again
against India for Brazil so they just
gotta you know hone into it and maybe
this is a second round this is a
different round we have time we can do
this so let's try to strike back
for sure I mean it is early and they
need around like the one and you just
had you just get three and a half a half
in your favor and we see Vida Gujarati
he is getting set with the white pieces
in this game and he takes on Alexander
fear and fear he fought back valiantly
he almost really came back and not just
held the game but won it against arvind
but he did lose at the end he played a
little bit too quickly now with black
James what do you think with the start
of this one you know it's so far so good
I like he has the Knight of 66 more of a
maybe this could definitely transposed
to many different openings maybe some
type of semi-slav
um or some type of Carol con-esque type
position it could be anything even some
type of groomfield somehow so we just
have to see my transposition what we're
going to get here um but of course
Alexander like really has no fear there
but vid it doesn't either I mean as
you've seen in that last game that was
like you can be scared for your life
against what that that position that he
had and then he was able to figure out
some things on the queen side with the
A5 and was able to break through
especially now we're having the white
pieces here I'm sure if I'm vidding I'm
feeling a lot better this is more even
like almost yeah this is a pan-off Nick
now you can play D5 yeah take take and
now we've transposed to a pen off a
badvinic yeah you said that this could
uh turn into a caracon he says no let's
play E5 going after this Knight on F6
and oftentimes when someone plays E5
black strikes back with a move d4 I
don't know this position very well you
could also probably just move your
knight away but then white will likely
reinforce the palm of D4 and gain some
space yeah the D4 was uh I remember this
being some Theory like you played D4 and
they both take the knights and this is
like strange territory here definitely
not a fan of this if I'm black here I
want to be comfortable in the game here
it's just not that comfortable out of
out of the gate here with Ponte tonight
on takes tonight yeah this is like some
strange Theory
you take this one the bishop does not
take back instead you throw in a check
against the white king and only after
that do you take back on Jim maybe
that's what we'll see uh because yeah oh
he takes back on C3 did it wants the
queens and everything on the board
yeah somebody plays D4 he wants Knight
F3 and Bishop D3 first yep
I guess 92 or Knight F3 Knight F3 is
Bishop G4 you come back around class and
Bishop G4 Bishop H5 Bishop G6
very easy plan
yeah Queen C2 I'm very under uh thank
you very nice very nice just sidestep it
the whole thing
many people would automatically go
Knight F3 but I like the queen C2 here
which was very like he understood you're
gonna play this with G4 so let me stop
it and just make it a little interesting
here you might is who crazy as this is
even Castle Queen side this is Bonkers
but I am in that and that I love that
kind of Chess obviously it's very crazy
I know you're thinking like if black
plays G6 I'm gonna play H4 H5 and go for
the attack and maybe the kid will even
sit on F1 or as you say castle Queen
side you have options you do not simply
have to Castle and this is so thematic
in the caricons H5 idea it looks very
strange to people who are unfamiliar
with it but the point is that it's hard
actually to get to the spawn and
meanwhile White's King is in the center
black strikes with C5 the Knight will
venture out to C6 and James it's kind of
like a caracon mixed with like a nimzo
Indian with these pawns doubled here
it's such an odd Dynamic periodic
correct because that H5 Carroll Khan
usually comes from the classical
variation and this is C seems like it's
a classical variation but it's also
seeming nimzo-esque of course with the c
Pawn there Knight C6 Knight A5 B6 Bishop
A6 you attack the C4 Pawn like you
usually get and all these Nims those
with the double pawns there lots of
plans and ideas I think for both sides
here you Castle King side and this one
though okay yeah this is gonna be a game
it's gonna be a a game game it's gonna
take a while you'll develop your pieces
there's nothing sharp about this one for
sure any pawn structure too in the
center for white this will go on for a
bit let's go to our bird's eye view
while video Gujarati thinks because all
four games are getting underway they are
staggered starts and we see in the top
right Arena bomaga now is the black
pieces against our event and that one is
just a symmetrical position so you see
every single piece is on the same square
and that's annoying copycat chest but it
can be effective it can be in fact it
can be effective in the in the right
moment I'm like I remember looking at
some uh what is this like some ready it
was ready but it was like awesome metric
already but how white does it is you
trade in the center one time after like
C takes D5 and you're able to bring
pieces to the C1 A3 B4 really enough the
Symmetry you're not able to do the same
thing obviously every move so whenever
you deviate sometimes there are huge
advantages there that you can't come
back from in fact so those move is it
here it is move I'll be honest James
whatever I have games like this when I'm
playing Blitz online and someone does
this I get super frustrated I'm like I'm
like come on like you're just messing
with me right now and it's a good
strategy objectively these have been
good moves just to show you how we got
here it didn't start with all copycat we
just ended up in that way after white
decided at this point defianchetta right
this was White's decision to do this and
so it's not like it was copy cat chess
from the start but now that we're here
every single piece is on the same square
as the opponent Square yeah the burdens
unair of it he needs to find something
new uh whether that's taking the night
out with F3 or even taking this Knight
on e4 that's not out of the question
because if we just analyze for a second
after Bishop takes Knight on e4 there's
no way that black can copy because
Bishop takes E5 you throw in a check and
you see the evaluation goes so high
because the King has to react and now
give me an extra Pawn thank you very
much for everything you've done so you
have to take back on e4 and then maybe
we trade Knights and then we determine
who's better here is this Knight better
than this bishop is this Pawn a weakness
or a strength because black has some
open space and attacking chances these
are the big questions that need answers
yeah this is uh definitely tough as you
say as you see yeah with that Bishop
before we played A4 so grabbing some
space you see this more than London
that's a nice move now this gives me
London S5 so you can see here in these
type of positions you do play A5 you
grab the space but you also look for
Queen E2 Bishop A6 uh Queen E2 are
playing C4 trading C takes D5 putting a
rook on the C file and actually playing
Bishop A6 so it's a very strong plant
which you can do as well uh which which
works for white it definitely is about
what Black's gonna do F6 though F6 blade
okay well now the knights are going to
be traded we'll see how this one
continues we'll Jet right back out to
the scene with all of our games because
they are underway I mean I look at the
top left and did it through his Bishop
all the way down in front of the black
king and give a check and then he
dropped his Queen back so that game
Still Remains exciting uh that's a
French in the bottom left between Luis
supi and Abdullah get him Bailey except
it's a French where the dark light
Square Bishops excuse me are off the
board that's good news uh for black and
in the bottom right we just have a very
calm set up a sort of like steiness
against the Aurora Lopez that's all just
fine I think we you know we got to go
back to the first game between vidit and
as interfere because that board is wide
open
yeah the board's wide open got the
bishop 187 there the H5 pawn and
definitely steel uh weak we love it we
love to have you know weaknesses in your
opponent's position here I mean I do
like white I want to play A3 and then
move the bishop back and reroute the
queen
it's difficult to do that we have the
hanging Pawn structure though hanging
pawns meaning obviously we have some
dynamicism there
playing D5 C5 stuff like that maybe even
that's too much but I was thinking A4
and Rook lifting but we need to like you
see the bishop like The Bishop's over
here whoa G6 hold on bro you think I'm
not gonna take this
come on the question is if you take it
again or you throw in C5 because that
cuts off the bishop and the knight from
each other and then maybe Queen takes G6
is next he goes for us 6 C5 but it's
surprising from Alexander fear you and I
we never were considering G6 that looked
very risky because of something just
like this not only could white have
captured on G6 and got out for the king
now C5 hits two pieces at once The
Bishop's under attack the Knight is
under attack they've lost connection
with one another James this just feels
kind of just bad for black absolutely of
course I mean it just felt like it just
really felt like I think we've seen this
in the last game too as well with him
what's his timing situation yeah he has
time he's not low he has G6 it's kind of
maybe quickly there just maybe a little
little bit too fast but I mean this is
obviously much better for wires as you
feel is a practical sense even engine
agrees to as well C5 is very strong the
G6 Pawn is weak what's tonight doing
your development is not there for black
you're actually three Tempe away from
completely development looping the Queen
Bishop and the a rook us we got two I'm
about to move the queen you know where
I'm going and then the work can come to
any one of the files probably C and D
when the c one the D push the pawns I
mean very clear easy plans for white
yeah this is not good a really really
tough position now for Alexander fear he
probably just has to move like Bishop F5
give up this Knight be down a pawn maybe
two pawns too right because you take B7
b7's loose after though this is just
really bad so unfortunately for Brazil
it looks like another a tough go of it
against Vida guzrathi see that's why you
play vidit on your team it's like you
can count on him to score points he is
27 24 very highly rated and anyone over
2700 in this league counts as 2 700 flat
so you really want the highest rated
players that's right Tony sometimes the
flat there of course and uh some very
nice rules there I know uh any woman
player is like under what is it
yeah if you're above uh let's say you're
a GM right or your arena bomaga for uh
or vaishali you count only as 23.50 so
it's just encouraging teams to get the
best talent and then the problem would
be is if you have magnets on your team
yeah and if he doesn't count as 2700
then you really are sacrificing the rest
of your boards in a way that just
doesn't feel like in the spirit of
competition so it's great to see these
teams putting forth their best lineups
and it's working really well for India
most definitely of course India has like
you know three teams and they bring to
the protest League like they are always
striking and it's getting very scarier
just playing these guys all the time
here but okay 95 on the board right so
do I take G6 or do I not let me think
about why we got to calculate right
because Coe they call it G6 they gotta
be that
you're taking everything on this flank
the king is in grave danger you could
take on D6 but I think the reason why
James and I don't love that so much is
then black will defend this Pawn on G6
and you have these ugly double pawns
here you likely won't remain up a pod
for example if you take and even if this
King just goes up G7 or H7 something
like that uh you protected your Pawn D6
is in trouble this Knight is a great
piece on D5 and yeah white is better but
I feel like there are chances for black
absolutely yeah I mean black is I mean I
mean it's not the greatest for black but
you know you feel like you have better
taking on G6 here H5 is hanging don't
have the Rook lift yet but eventually it
may be there it may be some Rook lifts
in the in the air I mean we still have
that Knight on D5 is extremely strong so
you you won't be able to dislodge that
it might be keep the bishop on the bah2
diagonal so that might be difficult for
me I want ideas of like Queen G6 in a
perfect world queen G6 Queen H5 right
take both the pawns maybe get the queen
back to G6 or uh or it eventually A4
Rook A3 is what I want and Knight F4
with the bishop on B8 so that I can sack
and swing the rip over eventually but
these are plans obviously but in a
perfect world but it's it's difficult we
have to try to figure out how you can do
it he goes for it yeah oh does it help
The Rook lift that you're talking about
right I mean what is that oh I see what
he wants if you take on H5 this actually
would be a mistake because the King goes
to G7 and now when you take here this
queen has no checks not here not here
not anywhere and Rook h8 happens and all
of a sudden there's counter play against
the white king who is attacking who bro
who's the crusher attacking Google
that's why he took back on E3 first the
bishop now has to move there's no Rook
move here because you get checkmated so
the bishop goes and then he gives a
check he repeats look at that that is
classy you're gained two seconds per
move so before you figure out what
what's next you repeat once this Knight
come up to F4 James you could grab this
one as well yeah yeah it's got a pretty
probably I mean you bring another piece
in the game okay four Bishops man
those are some really good Bishops
I don't mess with those
staring across the next the next one was
probably Queen E8 I guess but even
though that loses track of this pod so I
feel like Lex moves aren't actually that
simple here
tough how do you how do you progress
what is almost time you got three
minutes okay three minutes
how do you finish here eval likes white
too you understand that I mean Knight F4
and queen H6
by repeating again
I'm playing nine and four I gotta I
gotta be honestly James
just throw it in there right just do it
bro Knight F4
ring an extra piece in the game
yeah I want I want to be captured
because then my Rook will get up and he
gives his check he can make a draw if he
wants that's the good news and if we're
looking at the match overall it might
not be the worst idea to make a draw and
he
he does it yeah he says repeats it yeah
he says why risk anything why risk
losing when every single Half Point gets
us closer to eight and a half so let's
go away from this one I mean did it was
better had he just continued the attack
but that would have risked losing
chances so James which of the other
games uh catches your eye and which one
should we go to all right let's take a
look let's take a look that game is it
draw on that one let's see
oh my God and Jose Martinez look at that
Jose game
all right so we're gonna go definitely
heating up Jose Martinez and vaishali by
Charlie board four of the India yogis
but she took down the board one for
Brazil she beat Super in the first game
and what is happening here
what was this it's like a ID or it was a
it was a Spanish that turned into King's
Indian it looks like Spanish King's
Indian new Lynch hat that's a new one
wow Spanish kingsmania okay that's
that's new yeah the question
the question is like does black just
crash through and deliver a checkmating
attack or is white just strategically
winning those are the questions the
trade-offs because this on an F4 it's
good if you get to attack but it's not
so good if uh the attack Fizzles out so
a queen trade would benefit white that's
very far away and you see vaishali down
a couple minutes on the clock but
holding her own on the board very strong
very strong is she does have a nice plan
of G5 G4 going the king's Indian route
this is what the setup says of course
you do have a Pawn on F4 the G6 Pawn is
quite weak and the pawn on e4 hinders
the white uh the white Bishop on C2 so
playing G5 doesn't really weaken the
diagonal as much as it may seem Knight
X2 I like from jobs from here
understanding that you might want to go
G4 so let me just put some pieces over
here to be ready for the G4 push so we
might see something like maybe King h8
root G8 and moving the bishop eventually
A4 grabbing space I like it slow maybe
maybe there's a future James you keep
talking about Rook lifts um I'm waiting
for it real quick bro Rook A5 oh my
goodness that's a move foreign yes
aggressive regular you know I I like the
move though because it does
cement this Pawn in place you push that
I'm taking it I'm shattering your Pawn
structure uh maybe there is a future
where black goes against this Pawn on B2
and White's plans don't seem that
straightforward if you take on E5 uh the
pawn can simply capture back uh this
bishop is behind the E4 Pawn as you said
White's best move is throwing this off
the board like if I could just figure
this one away like there it is yeah
but right now oh man it's close and of
course close positions usually favor the
knights and we all we both have Knights
but whose Knights are better I think I
would say black here of course tonight
white has the uh Superfluous nice that
they have a rescue talks about so these
Knights are the same and they don't
really do much of course one does one
and the other defends the other like you
know and when one can go to G4 so not
the greatest pieces here but uh the
white uh the engine prefers white
slightly that's actually interesting I
wonder why
I'm guessing the central control plays A
Part here uh and by the way we do have
another result it looks like Arvin
ChatOn Brum beat uh Irina bulmaga so
it's a top star for her it's the board
for Brazil but India keeps stacking a
little going crazy man India like
somebody used to stop the cow hell
no
they need it right now India is trying
to take off with this one wow yeah but
uh Jose Martinez he's trying to help
Brazil fight back in this I think he
wants queen D5 check and he's going to
be greedy James he is going to play
Queen D5 Queen takes B7 try to get all
of these little pawns over here because
Black's attack is far away for the time
being 100 especially with the Knight on
H2 I mean when are you ever getting G4
and you're gonna need a lot of moves to
play G4 so Queen D5 check maybe there's
a bishop E6 Queen takes Rook B8 you take
whoa you take on B2 yeah I guess he
didn't want to go for complications of
that
though
yeah like he could have just grabbed and
grab and go you know what I mean like
grab and go back boy like what were
those called Gogurt you know
[Laughter]
grabbing goes yeah
they can move he plays Queenie too so I
feel like black now should have some
time to press forward but as you keep
saying there's no attack here the Knight
on H2 is doing the big job of covering
the G4 Square so maybe that's what he's
counting on the black has no attack
whatsoever you know King h8 Rook G8 all
this stuff it's too slow all right very
very slow and at the right moment too I
mean I could always stick the Knight on
G4 play the other Knight to H2 and play
F3 right and really just cement the
thing in there if I absolutely need to
that's gonna be passive but you know I
don't want to play Passive here but I
have that if I need it so it gives me
confidence in the position to you know
play A Move Like Queenie two maybe even
work a to D1 now just because uh you
don't have it
yeah and queen C4 check looks like it
wins a pawn but the bishop slides up and
protects the Knight G4 your move James a
good call out by you that looks strong
692 yeah that Bishop's gross huh that's
the king's Indian Bishop I see I talked
about to dania about this a lot where he
loves the king's Indian I'm like
strategically the Dark Sword bishop and
the King's Indian is terrible so if you
just play it positionally black is in
trouble and this is showcasing just that
that's right that's right I'm a king's
Indian fan myself I had to actually
switch up I had my first win OTB against
uh paragua in the king's Indian but it
is also um you got to be careful with
that you gotta be careful with that kid
because this I mean it was an open
position right those close ones the
positional ones are the ones that are
the hardest to face as a Kings Inn
player too so it's tough very tough King
H7 on the board
uh while we have a second here let's uh
just bring up the view of our other
games we know the two have finished uh
but we still have the game between soupy
and Gavin Bailey that one has been very
interesting so if we take a look at it
that is in the bottom left so there was
so much happening
there was so much happening like I
caught up the court of my eye and then
the queen suddenly got traded so if we
just bring it up here this move was
played James you're gonna be happy oh
Big Fellas swinging okay
Lexus you know have some fun I'll take
it I think the reason why this was so
unlike was Rook takes D4 was possible
here if the queen comes up this Knight
can help join the party for the defense
and maybe some of this was working but
looks very scary against this King so I
would not have gone it's that especially
with his Rook sliding over I don't even
know how this works it was black just
here takes
I'm a cheat I'm putting the engine oh my
F1 Queen F1 oh no no it's it's Rook D1
and somehow black is winning yeah
it's like this you're okay
you have no checks because the Knight
stops everything over here oh that's
that's why the eval bar is brutal like
it says you're completely winning like
what I miss what I miss oh you miss
engine stuff so we started oh okay all
this happened the Queens came off here
and now we get an end game where black
is just mopping up Pawn so yeah okay
that is one of the most ridiculous
tactics I've seen right you think he's
like we'd have one or something but no
not even close just Rook D1 simple one
how come you didn't see that man what's
wrong bro all right that's too funny
that is hilarious but hey guys this is
my chest is so hard when they give you
that type of stuff for sure and we see
that Jose Martinez he had a pretty
decent position against vaishali soupy
needs to get this game he's got the
white pieces he's down upon a black down
to 24 seconds and the king is a bit open
so I could see an argument James for
instead of taking the pawn giving a
check and then bringing this Rook over
here just because you're getting closer
and closer to the black king oh that is
nice he's actually thinking about that
he's actually thinking of that and I'm
down a pawn and this week
check check I mean check Rook G8 I mean
yeah
maybe this best you get is some kind of
checks and a draw so that's probably you
know what he's struggling to figure out
but when my opponent is 24 seconds and I
have three minutes and 25 seconds I'm
like how do I make this complicated even
if I'm down a pawn oh my goodness you're
right yeah check and that's the way to
keep it complicated because he's
expecting you to do work B7 which is
played Ruby seven now play this should
Teeter out to a draw here unless he gets
drastically alone time which he is but
not too bad like you know once you get
under 10 seconds it's really rough two
seconds I I think at some point White's
gonna throw a move H6 yeah yeah distract
the rope and get this F7 Pawn Yeah
but H6 you don't have to take it that's
the problem for for white yeah it's not
made over there like I don't have to
take it throws in the check oh
oh what's going on here that's serious
yeah that's me oh he said no not today
ain't about to do this to me on National
Kingdom
is the king running this way like is it
hiding behind the pawn somehow right
that's what I'm saying is King G5
actually work King videos
I'm looking at like these checks over
here just trying to get that King out
and then trying to push my ass spawn oh
that's sharp oh
he saw it yeah
one of those disappointing things for a
soupy it's like come on fall for my trap
all right come on bro come on just this
one time bro yeah be a Friend Lucy three
is tempting I definitely want to put the
king up there just put them in the
maintenance well the idea here is to
play check check F4
and then Rook G5 that King's going right
there you gotta go there it is
tuck and roll I'm out the way
is there this check over here
oh my goodness
runs back oh boy he be doing that in
Game Boy
you mentioned you mentioned deboretsky I
gotta you know make him proud oh yeah I
always call him Uncle Debbie that's my
uncle
Debbie in the Chevy yeah we sit out
every day on the stream when we do our
end games from G3 yeah yeah I figured
because Richie five is so strong bro
yeah
was a nasty nasty move
down right maybe just yeah rookie A8 I
guess
Basics give up H5 for A5 I think you got
to do something like that and bail out
take that
and then bring the king back yeah the
king just chases the pawn down yeah yeah
it's gonna be a draw ski well yeah
something to draw push King G6 Rook a
takes and then takes on A5 y'all can
shake hands
I wonder just because the clock if you
can try to play this out for soupy we
have seven seconds for Gad and Bailey
here let's play Rook B5 Rook B7 push
your B Pawn and of course
draw right objectively drone right you
could just I mean push it right you know
push the limit why not you know I do
have a pass B Pawn
I do have a past people
right you have King G6 if you own King
G7 I'm trading off those
um
oh he is in the Square isn't he and yeah
you can't take F7 without the other one
Queen you have to like play G4 G5 right
moment and take it type thing but Adam
Bailey has this I mean this is one of
those end games where if you're black
you're like okay no longer do I have
problems maybe I can even win this game
like I push this push this get my king
up try to give a check at some point but
yeah no this is just a hold or get a
bill important holes because Brazil
needs these points absolutely in fact uh
the scoreboard as we see there are two
draws okay fighting back but that is not
enough against two wins oh yeah no one
drop sorry that's the match score up
there so a round score so this is a draw
and a win okay yep yeah on the board
that's good all right here five and a
half one half in favor of India so
that's a big hold for India not what
Brazil wanted we only have one game left
it oh my goodness let's get right into
that one by Charlie and Josh from Jose
Martinez James we might finally see G4
happen in the near future get out of
here with the King on H6 King out in the
middle of the street don't care about
nothing you got to stay away from her
that's the scary scary woman G4 and just
don't care about anything Queen D1 wins
a pawn oh yeah good oh yep great Point
by you you saw it the bishop is hang on
did so wrong move order why everybody
should take it back with the bishop
rather than the Rooks you need to keep
the Rooks on the board this tactic would
not have worked out and now you do not
want to take your check give me that
yeah I know she would take on e4 so we
back it up Bishop F3 take it with the
pawn yes oh my goodness yeah you take
with the pawn oh sick it's brilliant the
Night Comes In the Night comes in G4 it
defends the only weak part of the
position and this queen is infiltrated
that was we're gonna show that again
when this game is done that is super
instructive bye
good work King G2 Knight G4 stuff like
that I mean just a beautiful night where
it's bad business that you pointed out
King's Indian Bishop in a way the bishop
terrible bro like
it is terrible
you can maybe even like put it on a good
Square where would that be right wait
um exactly bro yeah I got I got one see
one you can see one okay this one she
won perfect right yeah gonna take a long
time big fella
pick up everything
they're going to be five there very
strong you can check and take this one
as well
everything is offered you know just
nothing that black can do
what is that too oh okay you're trying
to play but I have Queen for one
whoa it should be two oh snaps you
tricky check and take all right you can
just trade off all the pieces now Queen
six F6 is oh that's winning yeah man but
he'd be doing them in games boy let's be
hitting them take take
that yeah yeah that's the one because
you're gonna get this one all right but
this is instructive by Jose by the way
like he's spending time he's saying I
can just take this Pawn be winning this
way maybe I can just win the game by
trading off everything he's calculating
he's not taking it for granted
yeah that's strong that's strong Queen
takes takes
takes King takes King H2 E5 G3 E4 G4 and
then he zucked out and you take the pawn
that's nasty that's an easy clean way to
do it simplify but he's still calculated
from there you know he's going five yeah
fire out I understand
oh snap E6 with almost under everything
he said check
oh he's just clinical check here yep E6
no E6 is something not H6 there we go
oh
whoa hey big fella man you got kids
watching this man
yeah yeah
hey man hey man they say Checkmate in
one look for better but we're gonna go
back just because I think G takes F3
this moment here everybody would be
playing Knight takes F3 the problem with
this is you allow black some play the
pawn goes up the bishop gets out he says
no nothing for you my Pawn structure may
look bad over here isolated pawns double
A say pawns but your Bishop is locked in
and the Knight comes in G4 protected
can't be kicked out of that square
wonderful play from Joseline just that's
a winning decision absolutely beautiful
winning descent I love that I put the 90
G4 there you can't really get in it's
also like a shelter around the king
there it's very very strong definitely
needed that Jose is performing in fact
out of two games one and a half he's
performing for the team right now he's
everything that the capy Bears need but
they also need to step it up themselves
because he can't do it by himself
that's right tutu it's not gonna be good
enough when India won the first round
three and a half to half so it was a
great win for Jasper but he's the one
leading the charge for them and he needs
more from his teammates that's the
struggle when you're playing against the
India yogis and right now uh Josh from
he's the kind of Lone big scorer for
Brazil
yeah absolutely in fact there's only
three points and Three Points first to
eight and a half that's it the Cowboys
need six points
I don't know if that's gonna happen
there guys just being a 100 practical
that's very hard to do against this very
strong Indian team in good form right
now it's very very tough but anything is
possible but it's very very difficult to
say the least for sure in India with
three points in the next round they can
clinch this first match eight and a half
points wins you the match so we'll see
if the India yogis can do it but first
we take this break when return it's
round three of this matchup between the
India yogis and the Brazil capybaras
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from this stakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my gosh
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter and
you're just 4-1 he wants ticket into the
championship the Snowballs welcome back
PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
[Music]
face
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion play phenomenal chess today
and it is coming home
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
we are back here in the matchup between
the Indian yogis and the Brazil
Capybaras it has been all India thus far
in the matchup they have left out to a
huge lead but when this match is over
and it could be finished in the next
round of action we still have one more
to go and it's a huge one we have the
Canada chess bras taking on the
Charlotte cobras So Daniel neraditsky
will in fact be playing and so will a
guy named Magnus Carlson or the candle
chess bras yeah they talk about that
Magnus guy a lot but he's on the chance
of our team of course as you see right
there look at that lineup boy that's
stagged we got Magnus sitting up there
with the beefy raid and then you got
Anish giri come on now Jordan Yvonne
sarik aryantari e Hanson
um priyotsu there you got Sean lemoy
who's now a GM while newly minted shout
out to him Jennifer you and uh Molly
Jade there so stupid strong Team bro wow
yeah that is a stacked lineup from top
to bottom Jennifer you the US Women's
Champion Magnus Carlson the world
champion Still In classical and of
course in rapping and Blitz as well so
just a monster lineup from the chess
Bras don't count out the cobras because
we've all seen dodgeball we know what
the cobras can do and uh well they have
a great line of themselves Gregory apart
may be the top rated but the most
popular is undoubtedly Daniel near
Disney will be playing today Dania is
playing today Chad did you hear it uh
calling all chat members Danya is
playing today against the Canadian
Canada chess bras Charlotte Cobra is
newly new team here right you see Greg
o' pairing there super strong a Wonder
Liang he's definitely a wonder and then
Daniel nerdinski you got Brandon
Jacobson Brando El shamore body I mean
Crush right Nazis there is so strong
chat I mean this is going to be a huge
match episode hey now the match right
after this right for sure but this
matchup is a huge one between the copy
bars and the yogis be because Jasper he
has been playing well for the cabin bars
thus far the only player for them for
the scoring points he gets white against
vidy Gujarati and he plays this H3 move
a very quiet move in a position where
both sides have moved out their Knights
and then A3 so James what is he doing
yeah first off okay Chad don't copy this
secondly you know we gotta figure out
what happens after Bishop C3 Pawn takes
and the Knight takes E4 is the whole
question of this whole thing maybe Queen
D5 there and it's happening Knight takes
E4 looks like a pawn but it's definitely
something we're probably missing in
Queen E2 but then D5 so like I'm trying
to figure out what happens when you take
this one Queen D5 Knight F6 so what is
this I think Knight takes E4 this is
just a quick little thing is that their
office is Knight takes E5 move where you
take and the queen size up to D5 and
says give me one of them Knights you
can't protect both so it's a fun little
trick that's available in a variety of
openings but that that is what Jocelyn
is relying on and you can see vidit he's
like uh is this for real can I get away
with taking he says Nah not so fast
but you know what's good is a bishop
here James I'm a huge fan of a good old
Bishop pair I am two actually in fact I
will only usually I like to go to
in-games usually only when I know I have
the two Bishops if I don't then I'm like
I don't want to play this in game I mean
if you have to you have to play what's
on the board what's given to you
obviously there's many ways you can go
but two Bishops yeah for sure I like
that because positions open up you got
the Bishops and it definitely favors and
it shows here but this game is going to
be definitely a test of strength and a
test of ability and just everything that
you asked from uh Jose Martinez can
actually
um take right now because this is we did
his very strong 2700 top board in India
right now
um going crazy and playing very good
chess today so it's definitely gonna
test Jose hopefully he's able to do
something with him and I think we're
gonna have a James Canty style of game
here I'm I'm suspecting we need to fish
about okay now especially if you castle
Yeah
easy work come on you're right there it
is we need to right he's for sure going
that way and they're gonna throw his
pawns at the board James you sure you
know you have been coaching Jose it
feels like a very Canty like opening I
mean hey look sometimes we talk you know
it's the big homie he actually raised
the stream by the way he's a streamer so
make sure you're following him he is he
goes by uh GM yaspoon I think that's
what it is on uh on Twitch guys make
sure he finally streams quite active
he's an active streamer so shout out to
him and he raids me I've rated his
stream a few times too as well so you
know we got some symbiosis in the air
there you can just feel the waves you
know we got on glass you see us both
wearing glasses today wearing glasses
too you got the memo today didn't you
look at that so I have to wear them I
can't see you've got Vision you know
across you're the Jedi man you don't
need those glasses I know I know they
don't actually have prescription lenses
in there
don't give away all the secrets come on
all right my bad my bad well well this
game after Queen E7 Josh was thinking
here that's Jose Martinez those of you
unfamiliar with the stream we'll zoom
out just because the second game has
also started and that one is between
soupy the board won for Brazil he
famously beat Magnus Carlson uh when
Magnus was playing uh Blitz game of
chess.com was a fishing pole line and
then he is taking on arvind chidambaram
who has had a good showing thus far for
the Indian yogis that position
it's a pretty quiet game honestly the
top two games very solid thus far
absolutely of course I actually do like
White's position here with the double
[__] I mean with the um the double fin
Kettle there it's pretty solid I mean
you have lots of flexibility I've
experimented with these lines myself and
you just notice that black it's very
easy for black to go wrong and for you
to get good positions because white just
has so much flexibility and options that
black has to really be on on a a good
you know a sense of the position every
single move here yeah that Knight D5 is
looking really strong with E4 yeah he
closes down his Bishop but he makes the
D5 Square available to his Knight I
think Super is trying to sit on the
position he may even play D4 in the near
future if you're not looking out for it
and it's kind of like a maroxy bind
Style with the pawns very Advanced but
that's why aravens is not so fast it's
not going to be a one-sided game here we
come we're gonna get maybe King's Indian
style counter play over on the king side
with F5 to follow oh Knight G5 yeah
that's that's correct Terry with the
king's Indian style usually when you see
a bishop on G7 especially for anyone
that plays King's Indian shout out to
you I understand like if you just want
to just oh this king's Indian anytime
you have a visual G7 and it's not a
position that is from Theory or a dragon
or something it's some type of King's
idiot so you just put the original G7
play F5 and you should have a good time
here at least try to but this position
does say that pawn breaks in fact I
actually learned this from you has a
long time ago and it was like whoever
controls the Palm brace controls the
game and years later I'm actually still
using that same way of how you've said
it before so you can't spell chess
without hash chat but you also learned
something too as well with the pawn
break so Pawn break F5 does control the
game there F5 is a nice Palm break D4 is
a pawn break two but F5 is really strong
yeah I appreciate that and also Knight
G5 trying to swap these Knights takes
away White's control over D4 and you
know you're talking about spelling Coe
that's all you got to know calculation
over everything and that's why you see
it's not just even calculating
individual moves about the series of
moves coming up with a plan and I think
that Knight takes G5 that's not what he
wanted if we just actually bring up an
analysis board quickly now the knights
are getting exchanged on F3 had he taken
on G5 let's say he went for that we see
that pawns are just storming up the
board the open H file can be very
valuable for black if the king moves out
the way and The Rook slides over but
that's why he says no no let me just go
King H2 trade this way but what do you
think James there's been a bishop giving
up for a knight we see White's likely
going to play F4 White's Pawn structure
healthier for the time being which side
do you prefer I'm actually going to
prefer white now we have the dead Bishop
on G7 I mean it could come out to life
if it does get to D4 but uh or E5 but he
went to Knight F4 route which I guess is
the same but I was actually gonna go
Knight B4 of course it is to take a long
time but I want to get F4 F5 in as quick
as possible but now I can't and like
what do I do next I'm actually kind of
have a loss of a plan here in fact I
don't even know what to do now maybe
just try to better my position but I did
one night before Knight C2 F4 and then
maybe try to swing the Knight back
around maybe the F3 but G4 is coming at
five maybe try to push myself but now we
have to kind of sit and wait because
this is uh my knight doesn't have any
good squares yeah both sides could have
said wait no more F5 the G6 Pawn is
always loose so for black no active
plans for the time being for white
you're just trying to orient your pieces
towards the king side and then break
free and press forward when you have the
right moments let's zoom out of this
game just because I think our event will
be really pondering his options for a
while James the bottom left game between
get him Bailey and Irina bumaga it's an
end game that does not mean it's just
going to be a draw both sides will have
their chances and in the bottom right by
Charlie against Alexander fear vaishali
took down soupy that is board one from
Brazil she is not afraid of fear uh but
that position is early stages of Carl's
bod structure so uh honestly the uh
games are pretty quiet so far in the
third round of action definitely yes I
see yeah everything's pretty quiet wow
yeah I mean maybe it's not a lot of
I mean you still play the game but it
may not be as motivated I mean because
there were only like two points away
two and a half something like that from
clinching it
um and they're a clean six you have to
win you know what I mean so it could be
a little bit of disappointment
um you know in the positions or whatever
in some of the games but you still just
play and hope for the best that's all we
can do and that's all they can do so
for sure and you know we're gonna look
at the game I guess between them by
Charlie and Alexander fear because uh
Brazil really needs that game they need
fear to win with the black pieces and
the good news for him is he's shut down
the queen side so in this Carlsbad
structure where white typically puts
this Pawn up on B5 that's not happening
here look at the queen and the pawn
taking care of business on the B4 Square
thank you very much you're not pushing a
Pawn on that side uh so James I feel
like the clock is in Black's favor the
position is closed and that means white
doesn't have the free hand that you
usually see on the queen side flank
especially actually after trading Queens
too I think that kind of favors black a
little bit I mean we also want to put
the 906 usual Carlsbad structure stuff
Knight F6 Knight C8 Knight D6 and like
you just literally you know doing
everything that you do in these Carlsbad
structures here put the knights on the
great squares and we stopped a minority
attack that's how you can really you
know that's what you want to do it's not
for minority attack wow trading Queens
Queen H5
unexpected that one
I feel like Queen D6 is likely I like
your rerouting of knights up to a D6 as
well uh these types of positions like
let's just get into an end game just
force the Queens off and make some quick
move like Rook E1 the Knight comes up to
D6 no E4 push for you at least not very
easily and then black can even think
about expanding on the queen side at the
right moment put a rook on B8 and say
I've got an extra Pawn on the a through
C files that's three that's two last
time I did math three is better and so
we can see potential Pawn storms up that
flank but the Earth says no Queen trade
I want to win this game I want to keep
the Queens on the board and make it
messy okay real fast Queen D6 I'm gone
and white needs to figure out something
quickly here I mean this is super equal
here you know this is fine for black
black lives these type of positions used
to grinding these positions tied down
especially if you look at the old
classics and be kind of blanca playing
in a queen's Indian I mean uh Queen's
game decline here with a great success
team petrogen doing this well like just
very strong players all the way up to
World Championship matches with Gary so
you know he's gonna be the client's very
strong here and black has exactly what
they want we set up the minority attack
three versus two on the queen side black
is for choice I think and white needs to
figure out what to do if we want to have
some type of attack here E4 is going to
make D4 very isolated and weak maybe a
route though it may be a way to go but I
mean that's going to change the
structure that's not a fan of that
it's a big choice for if I shot that's
why she's spending her time and while
she considers E4 amongst other options
like even trying to get B4 and
eventually I will leave her to it she is
down three minutes this could be a big
result for Brazil they need to win this
round by a big margin to feel like
they're in it and as we look across the
four boards I feel like in the top right
still a closed position a soupy will
throw his pawns forward in the top left
the game between Jose Martinez that's
Jocelyn and did it Gujarati that to me
looks very close it's kind of a neutral
position chances for both I think Brazil
is doing everything you could ask for
them James at least in the start of the
third round yeah they're doing
everything that they can um with what
they're given they're trying I mean this
is probably I think they probably needed
a little bit of a warm-up if this was
like the first round we had these type
of games here like nothing looks like
anyone's getting rushed there's no
decisiveness everything's sort of equal
in every game in fact which is it
hopefully you know sometimes it just
doesn't go that way and you've got
Jitters and first game type stuff so
first game of the protest League here
just first match it didn't work out well
there what happened I think we
commentators Kirsten can we just bring
up the game between soupy and chidambram
arvind just snagged the pawn like I was
looking at that position and I was like
okay White's gonna press forward
um James can you explain this move H4 to
me yeah
what are you doing what is he doing
he just blundered upon in one move hey
call him up yeah yeah yeah make sure he
good yeah we need to make sure he's all
right well hold on my guy take him to
the locker room real quick what happened
I mean he could play F4
just throw your pawns up the board he
blundered in one turn and after Queen
takes he brought his King back the queen
just drops and black is up a pawn so all
of a sudden it went from a great way
actually how does that what no this game
is crazy this game is wacky bro this
game is very wacky guys wait what why
did Black let that pawn survive just
take that thing off the board
I'm so confused man yeah that is very
confusing it is it's very confusing I
mean just give him a pawn here on the
seven of the rank and I mean yeah I lost
the pawn but hey I feel better now [__]
thank you bro you know I feel a lot
better about the blender I made because
this is uh what James if you if I asked
you hey would you give up your H Pawn to
get a pawn to A7 I'm pretty sure you
would say yes so it all worked out for
soupy but this is completely unnecessary
from both sides give up the pawn and
they're like all right bro you gave it
up I'll let you get to Seven the right
thing I get it I got you you know you
help me I help you man you know what I
mean that is I guess he thought he would
like play B6 to go after the pawn
immediately and then bring his Rook over
but it's just kind of slow it's very
slow in fact uh I think uh if you played
it though V6 V6 but he's hitting uh a7l
okay so if we go Queen A2 here
C7 and take X
wow
this Rook B1 immediately nope I don't
work either maybe the other route to be
one but in Queen B7 Queen before maybe
we just go over with the B font just go
after the B yeah he's going out for the
B Pawn but now I think for black I'm uh
just taking this Pawn okay so maybe our
event deserves more credit he didn't
just allow a pawn to A7 it looked very
strange at least uh from our first
perspective but now that we're here he
wins the pawn back and he's still up a
pawn because soupy blundered with this
H4 move that is really tragic for the
happy bars because James his position
was excellent before he blunder that
pawn you're right it was very
uncharacteristic here but it is uh it
happens I mean these blunders do happen
lots of pressure you're playing for the
team you're also playing a very strong
player right you have to play the board
here you have to really just focus on
the board it's really tough to do
sometimes with all the things on the
line you're thinking about the game
you're thinking about the team how's the
team doing like are you actually really
focused on the game or 100 so here H4
was just a huge blunder here but of
course I mean he's back in the game here
but it's causing that blunder to
definitely change some of the trajectory
of the game yeah just show that one more
time the King on H2 there was a pin here
he played H4 allowing the queen to take
this Pawn for free Pawn takes Queen you
see not allowed because the king is in
line with this bishop a one moot blunder
happens to even the best in the game we
know super beat Magnus Carlsen in that
famous fishing pole game so while he is
trying to save this game Let's zoom out
let's look at his teammates because they
will need to win their games just to
give them a chance in the top left it
looks like Vida Gujarati is a man
possessed just playing good chess stable
chest you can't crack his shell as
position just too solid and then in the
bottom left we have Abdullah Gad and
Bailey that's for three for the Indian
yogis he's in a fight against Irina
bumaga that's just an ending and then
the bottom right by Charlie and
Alexander fear it looks like Alex
interfere he's active he just sacrificed
a piece but it's a temporary sacrifice
he gives up a knight to get one back so
just good chess all around absolutely
good chest all around look at the EVAP
bar pretty stable around all boards
except the super game here where they
prefer black slightly here at night
versus Bishops
nine Bishop versus two Bishops yeah I
mean a lot of play like what's the time
looking like anybody really long time
yeah probably around the pretty pretty
average I think looking govish all these
low
and
oh yeah come Bailey is uh low as well
okay
we got some people chat rooting for
Brazil let's look at the game come on
Brazil yeah yeah gotta root that into
his existence and the game between
vaishali and fear is interesting because
his last move was a trade of knights and
F5 just to show he gave up a knight on
F5 please take my knight because I'll
take yours and then B3 and E3 are both
loose the Knight slides back to A2 the
queen jumps into A3 needs to keep
contact Queen takes Knight is force
otherwise you're just gonna Crush in E3
and then after this James the queen
survives and E4 played from vaishali she
understands that's a long-term weakness
let's turn into a strength if we trade
pawns thank you here comes my Rook
attacking you the d-pawn may be a passer
I still like Black's position even after
all that yeah that's definitely very
active look at the Rooks and the queen
in into White's position on A3 it's very
annoying to say the least here we're
gonna have three is very playable you
also have D5 so follow I mean and we got
this weak Pawn here Black's gonna
pressure this forever and wiping long
time
definitely have to move faster and play
a little bit better right obviously
Queen C4 looks good hitting F7 or E7 out
of G7 I like that because the rook's
already controlling the f file so it
really encourages the move D5 but now
Queen takes E4 would be possible if D5
the F7 uh on his loose or maybe not
actually maybe not just blunder because
I'm gonna show that really quickly
because I'm just showing everybody that
I blunder all the time it's okay after d
takes C6 there's a back rank Checkmate
against thinking how is this equal I
thought I blundered wait Rook tell you I
don't know that's crazy this is equal
what the heck is that it will equal what
maybe it's just like some random move
like this before and you just oh my
goodness I finally blundered I finally
blundered so it's Rook E7 just get the
pawn that's why
that's crazy and then you get the eight
ball you get the B I get the a yeah okay
well I
overlooked it she has not she plays D5
she takes E4 is a viable option for
Alexander fear but he wants to win this
game so he wants to keep pieces on the
board
yeah so if we keep pieces on the board
then I guess we take on deep right
um
yeah it's winning from black standpoint
it's gonna take a long time you just
gotta wait for a mistake obviously it
was Queen H4 moving nope yikes all right
maybe just take the prawn say whatever
it's going to be as you said a long
journey for black maybe C5 and try to
use the dark Square something like that
but I was interfere does have the time
let's go away from this game because
he's gonna spend it uh all four games in
this round still in play we see that in
the top right uh so be he blundered that
pawn but he's trying to go after the
black king I see the eval bar I'm kind
of ignoring it just because I feel like
there are chances for both in that one
even if black is objectively better in
the bottom left we have an ending where
night Bishop rook and six pawns per side
looking very level there and the top
left it looks like vidit he is finally
opening the board up for his pieces
that's good news for the Indian yogis
that one's in a bit of a time crunch so
when we head to one for the Indian yogis
in Port two for Brazil just because
Jocelyn we know he can make people pay
and down to the wiring the bullet
scramble
oh wow yeah okay here we go some time
yeah look at the time before he under a
minute I mean you know he's very fast in
this time though we all know that he's
very fast in this time he plays very
fast chess 3K online right bullet and
Blitz very quick he is playing fitted he
was very very strong I think Vivid
actually gets in time trouble often uh
from from past commentary and looking at
his uh his games before he gets in time
trouble and was blundering hopefully
he's been working on that lately but
time trouble has not been his friend
no it has not and he just is facing H4
kind of a random move doesn't have a
moves that that scare me the most when
I'm like what is my opponent doing what
am I missing is there a threat yeah
there's no actual Threat by H4 it's kind
of a move an A6 played by vid also it's
just a move no threats they're trying to
keep the status quo because if black
ever takes then white could take back
and even isolate a pawn and if whatever
takes black takes back and both sides
have an isolated Pawn but D3 will be the
target so neither side wants to capture
over there we see that Jose down to 35
seconds plays G4 is he gonna play H5
next perhaps Bishop to H2 slide to a new
diagonal it's getting messy absolutely
of course this looks good for white but
I mean they do like black and black is
black is actually the engine likes black
black is a fully developed two Rooks
from the fire we got the Knight the
visual G8 there's pressure and wise King
is very weak so it's weaker than Black's
King here I actually like white for you
know the the Tactical aspects here
um but black definitely has some very
good squares as well like E5 could be
hanging you do have the hanging Pawn
structure in the center besides the C
Pawn being uh on C7 you can move it to
C6 to make the pawns very strong in the
center
but right now I think that it's a weaker
shot by the way I can bully it oh yeah
you've talked you've talked about this
you were just highlighting it did it and
when you get some time travel sometimes
he makes those critical mistakes and now
he is even on the clock we're about to
get a full bullet melee yep we're about
to get a full bullet melee that's that's
correct and I mean I can feel the
mistakes a video does not play as much
bullet I think as uh Jasper does Joe's
uh I keep calling him because that's
what he goes by all the time right oh I
see his name on he's playing every night
every day yasum is playing bullet and
Blitz on online so we know this we see
this
queen E5 25. Checkmate it's a back ring
mate exactly
I mean you're the prophet now dania's
got to give you that title because
well then then maybe he can you know
hand it over here
I never thought I'd hear you doing
Russian accents but Queen E5 is winning
for white look at Vida he is just upset
he's got a hand in his head he can't
believe it it's a woman Gotta Move what
I'm out what I'm out fan the draw offer
no way they drew by agreement vidic
can't believe it what just happened
Queen takes E5 is just devastating
because after the queen trade you can't
take on F3 it is a fork a pieces you're
gonna have to Rook takes Rook Rook takes
Rook this isn't just check it's mate
I have no idea bro I have no idea you
know but you know what think about
yaspoon in the game where he miss Maiden
one right well he missed that made one
game I mean he just maybe maybe it's
just he's not
his mental right now it's just mental
maybe psych something like that
oh my gosh ban the draw for he draws in
a winning position Vita Gujarati now I'm
moving two and a half into three for his
team but look at the three boards still
remaining uh we see that in the top
right soupy trying to go up to that
black king but the white king is
probably even more exposed and then the
bottom left end game looking like an end
game win or Abdullah Gavin Bailey he's
just up a pawn suddenly against Irina
balmaga so uh looking really good maybe
India is about to clinch uh in this one
yeah that's looking it's looking rough
man maybe clenchable right now of course
uh what's the uh match it might be
yeah it might be maybe two and a half
points two and a half now
and it looks like soupy he's going down
right now he made the move F3 and feigal
says never played that move and here
it's simple bring the Rook over to the
party go after this King the black king
is safe and sound over here there's no
checks against it oh it goes this way
instead of King up Queen G5 is mate who
wins wow came over
yikes black winds yeah he played good
he's playing great shots here
it was tough like this definitely was
looking good there but well
that might be it one and a half there
anyway one more I think they need one
nap points if we look in the bottom left
Adam Bailey that's board three for the
Indian yogis he is winning he is up upon
the end game and the bottom right by
Charlie in no trouble whatsoever with
the white pieces against Alexander fear
if you're board four beats the other
team's board one and holds their board
three you know you're in good shape so I
feel like the Indian yogis I mean
honestly they might be a team to beat
they could go a little bit under the
radar until they put in prognanda and
nihal sarama Vida Gujarati is showing
I'm going to lead this team as well as
two and a half to three against a strong
Brazilian squad I forgot you actually
mentioned it and I'm like oh shoot I
forgot they was playing like this what
do you mean like what I forgot they was
playing oh man it's tough out here India
is just a power house look at this game
bro
whoa
he's playing out of her mind
yeah this is the game uh we see that
Michelle and I was going to fear on
screen this is the game between Abdullah
get and bayley and Irina bulmaga uh this
is an end game where uh White is just a
pawn ahead centralization if you ever
trade pieces you don't want to liquidate
when you're down material in the end
game so I feel like for getting Bailey
the clock may be a factor uh but it
should be a factor in his favor he can
just push these pawns yeah b4ing for him
B44 looks good up a pawn here clean very
clean again this is some of the best
stuff you like to see it's very clean
easy risk-free
some blunder obviously
he does have 20 seconds oh they're both
here they broke a long time
Knight D5 check would have been good but
now the King has squares that's the
problem is any pawn push gives away
squares to your opponent and now the
white king is just going to snake in
there
between five king of six and we're good
take yeah G4 very nice H5 okay King he
finds nice
quiet little move now the King has a
Target to pick off easy
by the way God and Bailey's one of the
best Bliss players on the site so you
can now take it what's his user
I think it's just I think it's his name
yeah
but 94 liquidation you're hitting the G5
Pawn okay cool
this is just simple beautiful Easy Clean
clean clean
where's this King going yeah H5 right
and take the other one too
King comes back four is dropping
can you see through sc5 was two it was
very good too as well
all right well this game is
easy easily winning for white uh the
pawn race is gonna be one by White's two
pawns black only has one just throw them
forward and win the game the white king
is also well in the Box to stop the pawn
gotta take it
yeah he played to the finish and that is
it
yes that's it and that means that if
vaishali can draw her game against
Alexander fear uh that game is still
going if I shot down in her final few
seconds oh Alexander fear might be
keeping Brazil alive if he wins this
game Brazil gets to play the fourth and
final match but if this game is a draw
and we see the Evo saying it should be a
draw with proper play then
will secure the win
gotta hold and this is something that
the rookie Championship go back to F1
every time we also have checks yeah
horizontally laterally agreement you see
his face he's really upset because even
if this game ultimately should be a draw
with best play you need to put pressure
and she had six seconds remaining but
vaishali she held the balance even
though it looks scary that is a match
win this is over the Indian yogis take
down the Brazil Capybaras eight and a
half to three and a half that's a
demolition James
I mean look hey we came in here I
already knew when I saw the Indian team
in the stack in the lineup we already
know how strong India is they pop out
GM's every single month or week at this
point India is just beefy man they're
doing very well you see it so they're
forced to be working with now of course
they definitely have a strong team over
in Brazil here India was just a little
bit stronger today and it was able to
show that and it got off to a hot start
and uh Brazil was not able to recover
just the Indian yogis from top to bottom
such a strong lineup of vaishali she
scored one and a half points out of her
three games if your board four is doing
that kind of damage good luck to your
opponents and of course Vida Gujarati he
got a bit lucky there James he offered a
draw that was accepted that's a I saw a
featured chat that's a draw by
reputation in that one because that was
a losing position for him yeah it's all
my reputation that was a nice day of
course we have to ask him about that uh
later on but yeah Queen takes E5 which
is CG there I'm sure he saw you can see
it in the zoom camera there too as well
just like the emotions there I'm not
sure if they can see each other because
a lot of times if you're able to see the
zoom camera and you see the emotion from
that where you can actually oh you did
sound like what happened right you know
the reaction definitely tells all there
so tough game but at the end of the day
the India Indian yogis was able to make
it through and uh and win this match it
was awesome yeah I think people are
wondering what we're talking about
because that game that you know was very
important for Brazil to take in this
position approximately level you see the
clocks in Jose Martinez's favorite bit
again down to time trouble he made a
really bad blunder with Knight D4 the
evaluation Bar says that is not going to
get it done
the biggest thing for me James is maybe
it was because Jose missed Mateen won
his tactics weren't completely there
even though he played well Queen takes
E5 is very straightforward there's like
not much to calculate for it right when
he takes E5 you also have the bishop on
G1 so you spot it instantly you also see
with the back rank trouble Rook takes D7
rookie eight I mean you can see the
overall picture this is how we like to
do tactics so see the overall of all the
pieces were their place and the patterns
let you see the Checkmate is on the back
rank due to the bishop on G1 very strong
he's able he just missed it and it's
definitely possible especially if you're
not feeling the sharpest and he missed
making one and remember he thought about
that too like it was second you know
many moves on the board but he thought
about it and missed the maiden one right
so of course it's definitely uh possible
for this draw to happen and if it was
able to get away and of course score and
it's very nice for India to move on but
vidit saw it right he wasn't hiding his
emotions he like grabbed his hair like
what's wrong with me
yeah because if look at this position
James right it seems like a position
both sides have chances I don't like the
eval barsing it's even no it's Dynamic
both sides will have their chances but
let's say black had said let's just
trade off pieces why not get into an end
game I don't think this is something
that you'd be very scared about if
you're a bit of gujaratus he did blunder
in one turn it should have cost him but
it wasn't meant to be for Brazil today
eight and a half three and a half final
score that is a blowout
yeah and exactly it's a blowout here it
means and it doesn't show how strong
basically I mean the score doesn't say
you know the real story right eight and
a half three and a half they definitely
fall they played there they had their
chances and of course even that win one
win could have been another match which
could actually even switch things in the
other in the other direction but very
tough I mean we knew this going in like
India the yogis are monsters they got
like you know a b the B Team 2700 right
like it's very scary chest from these
guys here so they are forced to be
reckoned with here and we have to uh
somebody got to put them out but it
won't be attacked yeah you see if I sell
it one half points for board four that
was the low score and putting that in
air quotes because she had even score
against Grand Master opposition she
approved her might today Alexander fear
and Louis soupy you know she has the
points she took off of Brazil and yes
more countries are showing up these
attorneys we'd love to see Brazil back
in Action Cricket mekhitaryan the
Beloved streamer from Brazil he streams
of Portuguese and he's a big part of a
comp Community they'll be playing for
them in future weeks but for now it's
all about the Indian yogis we are going
to take a quick break because when we
return we'll have a special interview
we'll tell you who with who but we'll be
back with that in just a few
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
going to ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
I am
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
joined by super Grandmaster super
content creator Superstar vitikujrathi
vidit congratulations on leading the
Indian yogis to team Victory but my
first question has to be about your last
game there what happened
um first of all thanks for that intro I
think every time I go to a show this
should be the script
um
look at James you're looking cool over
there what'd you do James what happened
to Mike yeah
I guess we'll stay here so
a lot of times nice okay
what were you saying did it
should I wait
please go ahead yeah keep going man keep
making fun of him all right we'll fix
you later
so now I'm very distracted with this
green screen usually green screen is
behind you know James the only one who
was Green Screen in front of him you
know all green this is a new one yeah
I'll get you one better I got you
yeah by the day I last thing I think I
saw James they did some like push-ups
challenge or something so okay
look come on Robert
you heard him yeah
regarding the last game you know uh I
don't think we can pull up the board but
you know all five moves before I played
Knight D4 I was calculating the sequence
of taking on C4 takes on C4 and Knight
D4
and it Queen if I never worked because
there was Quincy to check my queen was
in G6 that's sick right and it was made
so I thought okay uh like I I'm
preparing it you know playing A6 all
this cool moves Bishop G8 like preparing
it but then I realized I put my queen on
F6 after I played 94. but you know
you should have all your resources so I
realized it's getting low on time
probably he has not seen queenified and
he has like 10 seconds let me throw in a
draw of her just to confuse him you know
so that he can't calculate
so it was legal and it worked yeah you
know that was that only thing I could do
to save that game and uh yeah it worked
oh my goodness
uh James and we enjoyed it James left
the room uh but you know come on James
you I know you got some questions here
from Vida oh absolutely absolutely I
like to say of it first off what are you
guys doing over there in India I know
you know I mean you ain't got to give us
the whole secret maybe I can email you
you know you can send me your PayPal
account whatever we got to figure this
out what is it why is India so strong
right now what are you doing is it the
water
that will be thousand dollars per hour
uh but sure
[Laughter]
I'm surprised that you guys asked me to
come because I think today arvind was on
fire like he was playing literally very
cool chess like after I finished the
games I go to see his board and it's
like meat uh also I think vaishali's
first game was very cool so they just
played awesome
um and I think uh one of the secret
sauce why there are so many people in
India were doing good of course there
are uh they are very ambitious they are
very driven
um but also I think there is a good
culture for sports let's say in America
or in Europe
um it's uh much harder uh because there
are other jobs other fields where you
can be equally good with the same like
let's say for the same effort you might
get same a different kind of reward but
in India Sports is very lucrative
um so that's why I guess the motivation
level is higher the drive is higher and
also we work uh like I mean the kids
I've seen they work very very hard so
yeah I think that could be one of the
reasons apart from the environment
for sure that makes sense fit it and you
know now you're back in a team event so
what are your thoughts generally on team
chess I know you played and you had
great success in the European Club cup
and you played around the globe in teams
but how do you feel when you play
amongst a team especially of other
Indian players
um I think in general I have a much
higher success rate in team events than
in uh
individual I don't know why is that the
case maybe there is less pressure uh
when I play in team events
[Music]
and like European Club cup as you
mentioned we won Gold this time and also
in um
world team and Olympiad we generally do
quite well uh for me I guess it could be
like my site my style also suits quite
well there because I can be solid
um and it really
requires somebody is needed in the team
who can you know hold the fort which
which comes naturally to me so maybe
that could be one of the reasons team
events work for me
very good how much are you aware of the
team matches that you're playing so when
you're playing you know are you like do
you got some some other tabs are you
watching the games while you're playing
or do you just play your game and then
check afterwards
I don't think
um it's possible to watch the other
games uh not only there is a delay but I
think it's disabled so only after the
games I can uh tune in
but it's very nice feeling after I let's
say even if I draw the game I see my
teammates are winning so at least today
that was the case so right yeah a very
strong very strong what's your favorite
part of the PCO
what's the
what's your favorite part of the PCO so
there's the playing is it the training
is it the camaraderie is it the energy
so the last thing I played was
um in the championship tour right and
that began at like 9 30 p.m and it
finished for me at 5am so I think the
best part about PCL for me is that it
finishes at 11 30 pm and I can get a
good night's sleep you know
sleep that's right important Chad get
your sleep see even monsters sleep too
I'm telling you yeah I know you're big
on your you know meditation and
preparation
um you know one question I think that
everyone wants to know when James was
hint to get it with all the success that
India is having I mean with the Olympiad
that was on your home turf in your home
country okay what has that been like of
course the event is now in the past but
what has been the aftermath like and
what is it like for you to see all these
teenagers rise and come to near your
rating
[Music]
um
I mean there is of course more
competition if I think about it on a
personal level
um there's definitely more competition
so we kind of it pushes you harder to
work
um because you know that you know you're
not in a safe spot there are always
people uh right there nudging behind and
you have to up your game constantly so
personally that is the case and
I think the aftermath of Olympiad it's
yet to be seen but I feel there is a
huge potential which is untapped is the
tournaments in India so if you see there
are no super tournaments happening in
India but let's say there was this Tata
steel rapid and Blitz in Calcutta and if
you would have seen some of the videos
or photos all the players were mobbed by
the fans there was so much of uh support
it's also the same was the case in
Olympiad so there's only one super
tournament in India where there is so
much potential so you know chess.com
that's that's an open space for you to
come and you know have more events
because it's completely untapped
opportunity I feel
okay well I mean we really appreciate
you taking the time with us here giving
us some great thoughts and
congratulations once more to you and the
Indian yogis will for sure be seeing you
next week but get some rest now I know
it's late may play title Tuesday if
you're available for it but uh it's
always good to see you buddy
yeah thanks thanks and all but thanks
James see ya good to see you
you heard it from the man himself that
was vidit gujarati's super Grand Master
he leads his team the Indian yogis to an
eight and a half three enough win over
the Brazil Capybaras and up next very
shortly will be the Charlotte cobras
versus the Canada chess bras the chess
bras will be featuring none other than
Magnus Carlson Daniel naroditski he's on
the Charlotte cobras he'll have his work
cut out for him so we're gonna take a
quick break when return it will be that
matchup and hopefully James camera will
turn from green to some other color uh
maybe you'll get the whole rainbow going
for today but we'll be right back for
more from the pro chess League
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
competitive Chase
[Music]
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my gosh
the protest league is back once again in
chess teammates matter
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
[Applause]
the PCL is the only place where the best
players
from different levels
[Music]
16 teams
[Applause]
[Music]
the pro chess league is back and it's
better than ever we just saw the Indian
yogis take down the Brazil copy boroughs
in our first match of the Season James I
know everyone is excited for the
upcoming match between the Charlotte
cobras and the Canada chess Bros it's
the heavyweight match you know like in
the uh in the boxing right when you have
the boxing you got the little undercars
and of course none of these is under
cards all of these is heavyweight
matches but of course when it comes to
publicity and what everybody knows and
who's playing on what team this is the
match this is what you came for people
took off work today Robert I remember it
was an Italian I'm taking off work to
watch this match against the Canadian or
Canada chess bras versus uh
um versus the other team which is uh
Charlotte right covers right that's a
brand new team too
and I know how familiar you are with the
Charlotte scene they already take on any
challenge in front of them they have a
great lineup and the protesting has a
great let up because today is just the
start of the regular season it will be a
five-week regular season throughout
February and March and of course we have
our All-Star Arena Royale on March 24th
followed by the playoffs starting March
30th through the 31st and of course in
May the PCL finals four teams will duke
it out for the grand prize Champions
will share 25 000 it's an awesome a good
payday 25 000 with the team oh yeah it's
awesome right of course we have so much
coming up there Arena Royale is really
really fun it's kind of just like a play
for all everybody can play everybody
it's nice to be able to do that counts
Shores I think your team too as well I
think you don't play people from your
team but it's very nice to be able to
play everyone else from the other teams
and stuff like that uh March 5th and we
got the regular season the playoffs is
coming right we've seen the PCO finals
how they play in person they're on this
this is the Esports field really I mean
so big now on PCL contributes to that so
it's huge
it is huge and a huge victory was scored
in our first matchup of the day by the
Indian yogis they would love to Jet Set
through to the uh playoffs they would
love to be one of the eight teams to
make it there but in our time Patrol of
10 minutes plus two second increment we
play four rounds maximum and it starts
with board one versus Board four or two
verse three three versus two and four
versus one and it's kind of an all play
all all four boards will get to play the
other four boards and enemy team and
first to eight and a half points wins
and we saw the Indian yogis score that
amount in just three of the four rounds
which is a shame if you think about it
James because if you're a board four and
you have the chance to play Magnus
Carlsen you want your team to give you
that opportunity right you want to play
everybody that's true yeah you want to
be able to play Magnus you're like yo
swing man come on y'all need to fight
because I want to be able to play him
right here no matter what happens so
um but at the day of course you just
want to play great chess for your team
it's a lot of I don't know I think
pressure not only for yourself but also
for your team here so a lot of times if
you can just let go of that pressure and
just be you know calm cool and collect
as much as you can only play the game
focus on the board in front of you then
of course it's easier said than done but
you can uh if you can channel that you
can actually do well no matter what part
of the team you're on well the yogi is
they use that concentration that Focus
they were not disturbed by anything
other than the moves on the board they
did secure match Victory they're the
first match of the season the first team
to win a match it was the Indian Yogi's
kind of crushing the Brazil Cafe bars
eight and a half three and a half led by
bit of Gujarati but he's called him out
he said bore two Arvin was a superstar
he won all three of his games Arvin
chitambra yeah he's very strong in fact
I checked a lot of his games in the
database I remember actually seeing him
a lot from uh actually looking at a very
strange line of the stressing across the
city in fact they called it the Dirty
Harry with the H5 instead of playing E5
he's actually one of the first players
to play it I've seen so many of his
games very strong player and he showed
out today in the protesting taking his
team to the next match of course eight
and a half they're swinging three uh
three he won three out of four there
which is nasty like three stuff three
three games is nice so it's pretty good
yeah he was a beast and well the lineup
we're about to see is full of kind of
these hidden beasts I'd like to call him
because everyone is talking about Magnus
Carlsen at the cobras right they hide
they're laying the weight and then they
strike at the right moment Gregory
o'parin is nearly 2700. he uh you know
he's from Russia but he now plays under
the U.S flag and you look at Players
like a Wonder Liang Daniel naradinski we
know Brando he is a monster he's only 25
51 classical b-day rating but in when
the time patrols get shorter he gets
better and better
absolutely of course as you know he's a
3K player 3K plus right hanging with
near Disney in fact goes to we've seen
hundred game bullet matches 30 second
matches on their diski's stream so those
two have a good camaraderie sometimes a
lot of times especially when you think
about you know different sports the team
come how do you know that person right
so if you know your buddy is duking it
out with you we're here at nerdinski and
Jacobson they are very close right they
are even in Charlotte as well so them
being around each other and just like
you know what God you know we have to do
this I wonder if they're even in the
same place right now I wonder cool like
yeah bro let's get them bro yeah get
them bro right so yeah let's uh that be
cool right we haven't seen that before
but uh it's it's definitely a nice team
camaraderie I think there and that's
going to play a part as well a wonder is
very cool with them also played a lot of
games when they're disc grego parents
now with Charlotte I think I'm not sure
he's in Charlotte native but he's in
Charlotte a lot every time I'm in
Charlotte I see Greg o' parents so not
sure if he's there uh or if he's in
Charlotte now but he's definitely
playing for the team here very strong
and I think as you said a hidden Beast
here yeah and they have two U.S women
Champions on the roster Arena crush and
Nazi pakizi so that'll be a strong team
but there is no team stronger than the
cannon chess bras and it's not just
because they're doing their pull-ups and
their Rook lifts it's because of that
man on screen in front of you Magnus
Carlson is the first board for the can
of chess for us and James if he doesn't
play they have a nice Geary to take the
top board for that Squad
that's scary boy big mag with the mag
okay then you got on this Geary right on
this Geary does that I mean not only is
he out here you know killing you on
Twitter but he kill you on the floor too
as well you all those draw means oh yeah
not today right recently those draw
memes have not been out right as you've
been playing some excellent chats you
don't have been favorite Forest very
strong very tricky as well Yvonne Starr
especially when he has E4 against the
Cecilia it's a very it's gonna be a
problem especially has a very nice
course on it strong as well worth with
Magnus ariantari works with Magnus Eric
Hansen work with Magnus chess bra right
pre-owned uh prior to there I'm not too
familiar with him uh Ros van but I do
know the rest Sean lemoy Lemieux from
Canada actually very strong newly minted
GM you got the wgm uh the World Champ or
uh sorry Women's U.S champ and Jennifer
you and then uh Jade they're not too
familiar but I mean it's just super
strong obviously as you see here their
team is stacked right they have money to
spend so they spend it on Magnus in the
top part up there and it looks good and
I think it's gonna be a problem for the
cobras but the cobras are again are
underrated right the hidden beasts there
on the team it's going to be a hard
matchup and it's an uphill battle for
Canada I mean for um for Charlotte but
you know it's gonna be a lot of good
shots today so that's all we want to see
it's uphill battle on the map you got to
look up to your uh Canadian fellows
there but it's going to be a good
matchup because we do have special rules
in the Pro chess League you're a team of
four players every single week the teams
must include one female player it has to
have a total rating cap of 25.50 and if
you're above 27 700 and we know Magnus
Carlsen the only player above 2800 in
the entire world he counts as 2700 So
you kind of want to Stack your lineup
with those Superstars because their high
ratings will only count as 2700 and if
you're a woman over 23.50 you count as
23.50 that encourages teams to get the
costen yolks the chess queens of the
universe who have them play for their
team so it's based on the November 1st
2022 feeder rating supplement and here
are our lineups here we go look at these
okay whoa energy there it is okay we got
a Magnus playing a wonderly aim there
right with the black pieces so pay
attention to every game here obviously
as you should already just to get a
lesson from it these are really free
lessons this is what you want to take
this every time you see chess.com live
it's free lesson so here we're going to
see some lessons here from the black
pieces of Magnus Carl and also A1 to
Liang playing white trying to beat him
down near this key playing all your
antari they're good friends that's gonna
be a heavy matchup Brandon Jacobson
playing Rossman there in Arena Crush
that's a that's a matchup remember they
played in the US uh the Women's U.S
chair
yeah that was crazy where Jennifer
blundered a bishop and it still won the
game so uh Irina Crush has won the U.S
Women's Championship I think almost as
many fingers as I have on my two hands
she's just always winning it but
Jennifer you now is a two-time U.S
women's champion and Jennifer gets to
play a Wonder in the first round of
action Irina gets to play Magnus because
board one plays board four and that's
going to be tough sledding for the
Women's Champions from the United States
those are some Superstars yeah this is
going to be fun to see of course right
the Superstar women
um they just play very strong chess
they're mostly very aggressive too that
I've seen like just women just always
want to just Crush you every game right
especially in the women's Zone when I
was doing commentary for defeated Grand
Prix every game was like decisive or
they were trying to be in fact so very
strong from there I like to see that a
Wonder Liang strong near ditski there's
Rosman Brandon Jackson versus Aryan and
Irina crust versus Magnus maggots with
the black pieces so see what we have
here of course it's gonna be fun to see
email you any predictions
well I was going to say no surprises
that I'm going to say this and it's not
even biased I just think it's true the
x-fast factor has to be Daniel
naroditski mopping up some points he
needs to take down razvant prior to the
black pieces that is way easier said
than done because prior to just won that
tournament in the Charlotte open uh he
tied for first olives under Bortnick
Bortnick being a popular streamer CO2
yeah you know he's one of those names
where you're like wait that that sounds
familiar where is he from oh wait a
second he wins this big open tournament
ahead of many strong Grandmasters so he
is capable he took down Lazaro of bruzon
in that event will he be able to take
down uh the likes of Brendan Jacobson
dating on their disc that's the big
question but I do think if you're the
Charlotte cobras you're looking Magnus
Carlson okay let's just try and make a
half Point against that guy orientari
he's also a Norwegian monster he's super
strong but I think that Dania with the
black pieces here and Brandon Jacobson
they need to uh score for the Charlotte
cobras not necessarily win both games
but win at least one yeah win at least
one right you know here but you never
know like again this time control here
is makes things very interesting it
really shows like if you're playing
online chess and a lot of it in fast
time controls you can succeed a lot here
Daniel nordinski Brandon Jacobson
remember in last match Joss Stone did
the best but he plays every day time
fast very soon when the time gets low
I'm able to adapt I'm able to I'm
already here I do this every day I'm
comfortable right so with the time
control being ten plus two whoever
really is playing a lot of this really
will show out here and if you're not
playing enough I mean it's just gonna
show it's definitely gonna show because
10 minutes is not a lot of time plus the
two second increment and a lot of strong
chance
right and with the sort of lopsided
early matchups when board one plays
board four if you're board four can get
even a half Point against the higher
boards that is an accomplishment we saw
vaishali do that for the Indian Yogi she
beat board one for Brazil that was a
little soupy right like if if Jennifer
you takes down a Wonder Liang that's
really bad news for the Cobra so uh the
cobras right they're gonna be hissing
they're ready they're just waiting in
the grass they're gonna just jump out at
you but Jennifer you she's playing for
the candle chess bras and James I wonder
uh she is a U.S women's champion she's
won that twice that was a nerve-wracking
Armageddon game but when your teammates
with Magnus Carlson do you feel like
that pressure like Magnus is watching
and I better you know score some points
you know when I think about it like this
as a
um they say in basketball terms like
LeBron just makes everyone around him a
better player right like I think Magnus
in that way is like I'm playing for
Magnus team you automatically get an
extra Hunter ELO right because he's on
the team it just feels like that because
you're around that type of greatness
your oh I'm with Magnus on the team I'm
not losing to nobody at least
confidence-wise going with a mentality
like this so I can play very good chess
of course don't be too aggressive play
the board but also you do feel better
you're playing with magnets so you have
something to show with or at least you
want to feel that way you know so I
think that's how I would take it
wow it sounds like I would bet all my
money on Irina
I mean I don't know which matchup you're
talking about but I I don't know where
she's getting free points from so that
is a dangerous bet uh yeah clearly let
me check the truth somebody's still
lingering from the Super Bowl will you
make this like crazy profit
oh man I saw the chess Center in the
chat says don't be so sure chest bras
have wrapped up they right behind their
team as they would try the chess Center
in the chat it's a lot of chalk out here
and games are starting yeah we see
Jennifer you with the white pieces
against the Wonder Liang and we get well
likely see maybe a Queen's Gambit
declined or a nimzo knight F3 now many
options here for black you can strike
four with D5 you can play Bishop B4
check early stages and I wonder I feel
like he's just trying to figure out what
Jennifer wants from him because he needs
to play for a win with the black pieces
right and you just play if I win so with
the E6 I mean you could go to D5 and go
over goes in here and D5 yeah Virgo's is
a good choice you can also go um you
know Bishop C Bishop D6 Bishop E7 I mean
you can go mini routes here even simi
simi Terrace it depends on what she
plays but D5 looks good if Knight C3
Bishop before we go into it goes in very
nice winning chances
for black
you just don't want that symmetry so he
has Knight D7 an early awkward night
move he made me think about taking this
pawn and bring his Knight to B6 so
Jennifer says none of that your knight
blocks in your Bishop let's just develop
naturally Jennifer is probably playing
from her dorm as is a Wonder they're
both college students a Wonder at the
University of Chicago Jennifer is a
student at Harvard and so you know they
probably are like waking up like you
have all this work to do I gotta go to
class and then pause I gotta go play
Magnus Carlson all right the likes of
these strong players all right I have to
play these very strong players here
today so that's going to have to pause
and then we'll get back to that wishing
him good luck in all the studies there
but today right now they have some very
important work to do for the teams for
their respective teams so as it is uh so
super common right now very easy
position so far I mean plans and ideas
very early can't really say anything yet
but we do know we need to get these
pieces off the back ring right and black
first just creates a pawn chain
defending our the pawns this bishop can
always slide out somewhere along this
diagonal and the key question is whether
or not black plays H6 sometimes you want
to include that move other times you're
like ah why did I why did I go with that
so this is early stages and while they
continue to think let's go to uh and
make sure we check out our second game
which is just getting underway we have
Daniel narodiski taking on razvan
priyoto so uh with Dania playing that
one maybe we can hop on over there
maybe sweet
all right
bring that one up we see that Daniel oh
this is and this is a sicilian Queen D4
It's gotta be
what's funny because I actually started
from the caracon yeah look at it you
know it's not you know all the time
where we see Dunya uh like you know as a
chess player these days he streams a ton
but he's often in in our seats James
we're compensating with him all the time
right right we are here as you see
Daniel near Disney chat we got big
narrow y'all ready who wants to see near
Disney right that's the big homie we
love him and as we know great
commentator great uh streamer great
chess player all around right so Big
Sean as he's playing for the Charlotte
cobras here a very uh strong player and
very strong game so let's see what's
happening in this game right here looks
like he's playing with blacks this was a
Carol con okay you've been playing a lot
of that lately actually online but yeah
here we go E5 only played the C5
variation these are Sharp
is ours you see that the queen gets out
for white very quickly and night before
just the bishop can't move because the
C2 Pawn will be threatened so resident
says take my Bishop please go ahead and
grab it and after the pawn takes back
white has quick development Bishop comes
out to E3 or Rook to C1 and you take
over the C file so uh as I say Brandon
because I know he's coming up next for
the Charlotte Cobra's but Dania decides
to take the bishop and he has a pair of
Bishops but James we know in the French
defense in the caracon the light Square
Bishop not the greatest piece pretty
gross this is why I'm not the biggest
fan of the C5 lines I like more of the
bishop at five lines I mean even looking
at the high level games farrugia all of
the you know 26 plus like to do Bishop
F5 all the time but uh over the C5 move
the C5 does give lots of chances and
lots of uh better
just excellent but this one seems like
it I mean exactly the bishop should be
out on the other side of the Fawn chain
so definitely look looks more
french-like than a Carroll Khan but what
I do like this about this from Donna's
perspective is he's playing a very
strong player Grandmaster and there's
not a clear plan for white it's not like
oh I just do these next five moves and I
have an advantage black does have the
bishop pair so if the game continues the
board opens up that's good news for the
Bishops now Knight G5 looks like it
leads to a quick Checkmate that of
course is not going to happen Knight G5
will be met by this Knight coming out to
F5 a square it wants to go to anyway so
this is instructive stuff from Donna you
first lead with the Knight the bishop is
blocked in but where's this bishop going
it's going to E7 so that they would be
fighting for the same square so let this
knight jump out to F5 or to G6 first
then put the bishop D7 and finally
Castle kingside this stuff gets very
very tactical in fact after Knight G5 I
looked at the line of Knight F5 right so
after Knight F5 you go G4 but after G4
the nurse Knight H6 and then there's a
knight on H6 but then you know we have
to get this Knight off of G5 so Bishop
B7 is coming and actually after I do
Knight G5 G4 Knight H6 uh and I I
develop there should be three or
something you go Bishop E7 and I
actually you're going to take on G5 at
some point but it's kind of strange like
maybe I even have in fact maybe not even
take on F5 maybe playing F6 which is
really strong you'll see this a lot but
H6 will be hanging in some cases so it's
very Dynamic you'll see this kind of
stuff all the time so it is white smooth
though we got them on the clock what's
the time here okay I feel like you've
been thinking a long time
okay he's been taking for a while
because while he's been thinking we can
uh look to see that all four games are
underway uh from the camera chest bras
and the Charlotte cobras all players are
at it and we see in the bottom right
Magnus Carlson with the black pieces
against Arena Crush that is of course
going to be a one to watch out for
Magnus Carlson plays the people want to
see so let's uh dive into that game not
exactly uh the furthest along but it
still is a big important moment in the
matchup between Arena and Magnus uh
because the last move played was Pawn to
E5 striking in the center
it's a kid people who are not familiar
with the kid you think oh wait I have
two attackers here let me go win the
pawn Irene is like no none of that
because had she decided to take twice is
Bishop stares at this night there's
often ways to play a movie like Knight
takes E4 and get this Knight on E5 but
James I feel like if I were on the
um the team right if I were a Charlotte
Cobra team member I'd be saying to Irina
if you can play a forced draw get to an
end game you go for that we need that
half Point against Magnus absolutely we
need at least a half Point here right
and this is a line that you can actually
get a good position from whites I mean
obviously everything's in there you can
if you know what you're doing here but
rookie eight okay so this is Siri I've
played from both sides in fact F3 but
there's D5 it takes this is a little bit
different F3 D5 takes takes I don't have
the bishop F2 here like you're doing the
glyceric or glycoric however you can say
that but it's different with the bishop
one F2 F3 D5 takes taste what
she allowed it it might be in trouble I
feel like Irina is spending a lot of
time here and I've had this position uh
from the white side before you take on
D5 and after Pawn takes you can even
make this with Queen B3 because your
Rook is going to open up positions and
the F7 Pawn is loose it's like you have
to see the forest through the trees as
Danny wrench likes to say and just to
show you what that looks like if we get
a position
and you think you're going to take
everything here here you drop the F7
Pawn you see the evaluation bar go Sky
High so a queen B3 is one of those moves
that you can play just to keep black at
Bay and then black plays was like Knight
C6 it gets very very complicated very
quickly and while Magnus says my knight
because the bishop is loose on E3 that's
actually Theory Knight D5
this is why it's annoying because this
is like Theory I remember from Black
Black is like fine
in every line take take could be three
yeah and then he actually plays around
the pawn I forgot what you do though
yeah you know what the biggest thing is
James I mean you're doing the right
thing you're the chess player thing
let's think about the position and the
nuances I'm looking at the clock
Magnuson spends no time at all and Irina
is not the best she's not a practice
bullet player and she's not going to
play that much Blitz either right what
Magnus is going to do is just build up a
lead on the clock and try to punish her
and use that as a weapon right yeah
that's tough I even just looked at a
recent game of magnets I remember it was
just like a YouTube video Magnus crushed
something I'm like oh let me check this
I'll just looked at it and it was not a
crush at all in fact it was an in-game
it was like a very he traded all the
pieces off and just ended up winning
against a very strong Grand Master and I
was like wow you know you can actually
learn something from the last game there
but also like as you see he's building
up the time is as you're saying I mean
it's getting bigger and bigger and in
this position it's tactical right now
but it also can lead you know obviously
to a lot of Trades where of course
Magnus is known for squeezing you know
water out of a stone right and figuring
these things out having very very dry
positions where he's able to get
positions that are winning getting
winning positions from them so we'll see
what happens Knight D5 was traded he
pre-moved that and he's literally used
no time I mean nine seconds off the
clock
right he's just playing instantly and
that's really bad news for Irina crush
seems like she's an unfamiliar territory
and Magnus he's doing the Magnus thing
where he's like am I even playing a game
with chess am I uh going to nap time
like right look at him right is he even
like here are you here bro wake up wake
up Magnus wake up bro
are you even here I'm actually in
Toronto this weekend so hopefully he's
there I'm gonna be cool y'all see
something yeah yeah I actually gotta go
Toronto frequently so I'll be uh I'll
usually go over to the chess bar pad
every time I'm there so it's uh it's
gonna be nice hopefully Magnus is there
you'll see me hanging out with Magnus if
he's there
we'll see and we'll get to pretty cool I
would love to see that collab you know
the candy Carlson collaboration
hey Magnus put this on bro put this just
put this on
yeah I think it could look good on him
and look at Irena by the way he spent a
bunch of time she plays King to H1
there's still this pinned down the
e-file and magnets can go upon grabbing
but there's often this like Knight B5
move in many positions that you go after
these vulnerable dark squares and you
can of course just take back on e4 The
Rook will get an open file if you have
pawns out the way the queen goes to be
three at the right moment and F7 is very
tender so look at white being ahead in
terms of development you have three
minor pieces developed black only is one
and so if you just go upon grabbing you
may pay the price but Magnus he's
finally thinking so we are going to zoom
back out to our four board scene just
because Magnus is taking time uh the
game we started with was the one between
Jennifer you and a Wonderland that's in
the top left Jennifer she has the white
pieces in that one and pieces are coming
off the board that is a good sign for
them but look at board two by the way
Daniel naroditski in big trouble against
razvan priyoto miyota's username is
attack to meet you and he is doing just
that again what look at the eval bar
look at the bar what's wrong with the
power hey get the engineers look at the
bar what's wrong with the bar bro why is
it all the way how did he how did we get
here how did we get here we were talking
about that bad Bishop in the caracon
yeah that became a friendship I mean
look at him he's off the screen there I
mean he's a good friend of both of ours
yeah what happened in this game is the
Knight went to F5 look at this Knight G3
get out of my way open up the f file
give me the attack and Dania move his
Bishop out but now we got the double
pawns the isolated Pawn oh what a Master
Class by priority you couldn't Castle
because Bishop H6 wins in exchange and
wins the game pretty much on the spot
the check mate and you have to move your
Pawn up you lose your rook and so he
goes G6 but then the Bishops are traded
dark Square domination James and the
queen lands on H6 my goodness yikes
that's crazy bro that's crazy it's a
tough game that's a tough game that
really is it's a really tough game which
lets you know I mean how strong both
sides are and they're Disney we know how
strong okay we watch him every night day
in and day out right so when you see him
losing you like what this ain't even
right like what's wrong with the no
something wrong right so it is a
definitely a very strong player he's
playing right here Rosman here who just
won the Charlotte open uh with uh
Bortnick here is in a losing position
now of course hey it's only one game
sometimes you need to warm up but this
one is not going uh in in Daniel's way
I just don't feel like the Cobras have
time to warm up when Magnus Carlson is
on the other team and you think that you
got to stop Magnus from winning all four
games but that means that your middle
boards tend to have to score some wins
so Dania for Brennan Jacobson that's
where the Charlotte cobras are kind of
relying on them for points I wonder
Liang he's a monster he fits so well in
the U.S Championship he can't score he
can even beat Magnus Carlsen in an
individual game but this is as rough of
a start as possible for Donna and the
cobras he'll try to fight I mean look at
this right like practically six six
pawns well he's on a pond so
yeah that's the problem yes
but I think if you get some trades in
and maybe trades one pair of Rooks there
might not be enough of an attack for
White against the enemy pawns but it
just looks really bad so we'll check
back in on this I think we'll leave
Dania to find a defensive test we'll
zoom out to our uh four board scene
because we haven't checked in on Brandon
Jacobson as he takes on orientari and
with Dania in big trouble that's an even
more important game for the cobras and I
love Brandon's position that's in the
bottom left there's an open D file and
white has both Rooks on it Brando both
the Rooks right I got two Rooks and they
both doing the same thing on the D file
with a smile right you put your Rooks on
the open files and got both of them
there on the D file controlling it 100
of course that might be the same amount
of material but definitely it's the way
the material looks the activity of the
pieces so it looks very nice for white
there's a knight on f8 the counterpart
is the nylon F3 looks very good I mean
you just have to use white here in this
type of position even though it means
objectively probably equal really no
nothing no targets really no weaknesses
but definitely white has the better
pieces I'm using the clock as a weapon
right Queen A4 using the initiative you
have these active pieces there is no
background Checkmate the Knight and the
Rook cover the square of that night
wherever to move Queenie one would land
with power so unit 4 is good if the
bishop has to retreat say to C5 maybe
even B4 right continue to kick that
Bishop around where do you actually go
actually that's correct Bishop c5b4 this
should you can't go Bishop D maybe go
Bishop E7 that's scary though rookie
what no you can't go rookie rookie
rookie right let's go stuff and A5 is A3
so you were getting hit everywhere yeah
actually I want to show that Bishop E7
Rook E5 there's huge problems down the
Elon here and you see the evaluation
going all the way up because it's
trouble The Rook is loose here the
bishop is loose there's actually no way
to defend this bishop with the queen
you're just giving up material at the
best you give up your queen or a rook
and a bishop that's not good enough so
Queen A4 Brandon is putting pressure on
Aryan tari uh yeah yeah this is bro
that's really good I mean what is the it
just like equal like equal waiter where
do you need what are you talking about
like what do you even do here actually
maybe you hang bro that's not well
either sheesh I don't know maybe
there'll be one make it out of here
Bishop E1 Bishops
so before there must be something for
black maybe it's like Queen e44 yeah you
got the paper um yeah you get the pin
yeah yeah okay that if you do not have
Queen E4 you're just in big trouble so
Queenie for it does allow black to
survive here uh so he plays it we'll see
how quickly RN plays Queen E4 because if
he doesn't play it now he's in big
trouble one of these moves with the
queen of the fourth rank pinning this
Pawn he plays it so what do you think
James now all of a sudden there are some
issues that white has to solve but white
is up a minute and nearly two minutes on
the clock that's actually really strong
the problem is the initiative can turn
very quickly with 96 Knight F4 right now
very strong 96 when you get the night
out then you move the bishop then I go
Knight F4 now who's attacking who right
so there's a lot of stuff and then I
have a knight H3 there also 92 or Knight
D3 right there's all kind of nasty
problems that you have maybe even
psyching on F2 at some point if you
aren't careful so it's it's actually
initiative can turn very quickly what's
the time situation oh it's about the
same be up a minute here
and you have to be very accurate right
now I want to play A3
but I'm definitely scared of 96 for sure
I am already scared of 96. there's 96 is
also A5 just trying to pile up pressure
on the pin piece over here
um I think Brandon did not see Queenie
for coming because he's thinking all of
a sudden and that's not a great sign for
him his lead on the clock is shrinking
his position remains about level but
it's a dynamically level position not
just an end game where you can easily
hold so uh Brandon you probably will
play A3 likely trying to figure out his
response to A5 not clear at all so why
don't we go back to our four board scene
I know we're jumping around a bit but I
just want to show that in the top left
here that Jennifer you against a Wonder
Liang that is perfectly level we're in a
rook end game Jennifer is playing this
very nicely it's two Rooks and six pawns
per side but Jennifer is down under a
minute on the clock that is the biggest
problem for her and she actually just
made a mistake commentator's curse
perhaps for the curse of time trouble
but her latest move came to E3 as we
pull up the board here that one was an
inaccuracy and look at this Wonder
quickly plays H5 is opening up this line
for his Rooks the black king is
perfectly situated in the center over
here and we just gotta shout out these
Rooks The Rook on B5 The Rook on h8
thank you very much very nice works here
uh watch your Rooks watch where you look
very good very good pieces here for
white and actually black too as well
though I mean the workers are very
active Rook B5 Rook on h8 there of
course the open file is going to happen
white needs to be careful we do want to
actually break in the center at some
point maybe rookie two and pawn E5 after
that opens up then we can play Rook D6
but a lovely move from a Wonder there
just getting behind the everything even
Rook to B1 is definitely a huge threat
here trying to bully the pawns and we
can use our Queen side majority to try
to win here she played E5 immediately oh
here we go here we go he said no none of
that stepped out of wow very nice big
move King E6 I think most of us would
have taken but he does not want to give
up those open files and if Pawn takes
the king can take back there is no G5
there Rook on B5 is just perfect over
here maybe black plays G5 Rook F1 check
available as well so honestly the way a
Wonder Liang is playing looks like the
way Magnus Carlson's playing not that
their games are similar but both of them
are playing for an advantage in a rook
end game uh the difference being that
Magnus Carlson he's up six minutes on
the clock I think he's about to take it
let's go back to our four board scene
because Irina crush is in huge time
trouble against Magnus Carlson so let's
catch the finish of this game where
Magnus is now up a pawn and his Rooks
are trying to deliver a Checkmate that's
Checkmate in one if she doesn't see it
oh yeah we actually knew this was coming
because of the time issue that she had
early on in the game we knew this was
coming here and Magnus uh used his time
to get an advantage oh yikes being on
the back rank
yeah yeah okay three quick smile and it
happens the game's over there made on
the back right Carlson and I read a
crush is so strong she's a grand master
I mean she's
um won some major events and here Magnus
made it look easy just to show you
quickly that the pieces came off and in
this end game it says slightly better
for black and he made her pay because
Black's uh Pawn structure is a bit
better The Rook is active some isolated
Pawn on T4 Target on A2 and Magnus
brought his rook in and then never let
her back in the game but pushing his
pawns and then finally trading off his
weakness look at this James C takes B3
please take my Rook back here
unfortunately for you you know I can
just take back and you can't take the
bishop for example uh so you can also
play B2 and after a rook B1 over here
you're going to give up this rook and
then the ensuing position is just bad
across the board so nice win there for
Magnus going after all these weaknesses
he wins an end game let's go back to our
four board scene because Magnus takes
care of business like we know he's
capable of and gen Jennifer you let's go
back to that game it's time trouble for
her but the position according to Eva
bar remains about balance as her King up
to E5
wow what a much better right now of
course honestly I'm still taking black
are you too far away I gotta give my
king to C7 and take the B Pawn that I
can't even take right out so you know I
can't get D5 in I mean I can but that's
just gonna trade the Pawns
level
anything can happen but I think her time
is really low seven seconds like it's
gonna be tough to make accurate moves in
this time that we're allotted yeah and
you see the the move rookie two is
played turns out it's a mistake you can
hardly blame her also not easy to punish
look Rook E1 check if you go back here
you're gonna lose the G4 Pawn at some
point ah D4 hanging buttons
looking around Rick D5
can can he just take apart like instead
of going right now exactly right he
looked around and said it's nothing now
I'm up two pawns clearly winning
position here time trouble
but they're bouncing back they're
bouncing back cobras would have went
after Canada was a win yeah big win for
a Wonder lianga not too surprising given
Jennifer's time trouble but she was
hanging in there throughout just she was
a little bit too slow on the clock so I
wonder is clearly winning now he's just
going to Usher his Pawn forward his Rook
protects and defends uh this is sorry
and helps lead the pawn forward he wins
the game so let's go back uh to the
other matches it is one to one now the
board ones for each side have defeated
the board four for the other so we need
to check in on the remaining games
Daniel nairditski he's been in trouble
since the start hey James I mean while
board three between Aryan and Brandon
looks about level at least according the
evaluation bar I feel like Donya has
more chances than earlier because his
Rook is active oh absolutely of course
and he's a tricky player what's the time
look like
um
it's rough for Daniel but I mean he
lives in the 30 second range anyway plus
you got two second increment and you
know we're not sure how much uh 30
second bullet Roz uh Roz actually plays
here so we'll see I mean there is some
pieces like we got some play right we'll
get the roof to uh the H file take the
pawn we can push the H Pawn ourselves
there is some place still for diet hope
is uh still alive
for sure and look at Rook F3 you take F5
I take F4 uh that still is every move
essentially is going to keep a winning
Advantage for resverat it's not really
uh I don't think he's a blunder at night
or anything like that but maybe Dania
can trade off enough pawns and he'll
sacrifice his Bishop for some remaining
pawns that is the key is that rook and
Knight versus Rook just pieces I'm gonna
put in red if those are the pieces with
the kings that is a theoretical draw
that's what dyna's hoping for right
that's what he's hoping for each other
theoretical one right and it's possible
I mean it's practical right you're
playing a human evil bar say you don't
have a chance get this guy off the board
but when you're playing a human and in
the time look at the time bro 20 seconds
you see what I'm saying like yeah yeah
this this dynick has definitely save
this I think you're right by the way
James that this H4 Pawn is going to be
lost and that's horrible news he goes
Knight C4 he wants 95 check that was a
mistake
Dania can take that and then take this
and that and we're in a pond race right
look at him calculating them so I'm
doing a quick okay Shake move okay
looking around take tank take
okay so this check wins another Pawn
he can grab that pump but it's not about
pot quantity it's about quality is very
fast maybe oh look at John you go he's
so smart he brings the king inside the
square yeah he's got the pawn
okay and it's Eagle it's equal the
magician
oh my goodness just don't let this POG
run oh he's okay he scared me his Rook
A8 to cover the promotion yeah his good
to go chat and it's good to go oh yeah
because I was check he came over okay
one or nothing wow six seconds for
Resident preo2 he's gotta move you gotta
get him he gets the move off but it's
scary territory
Indie Six I think should get it done
right yeah yeah King D6 you have to give
up the pawn annoying as it is and you
get yourself a fill the door position
and Donna spends his time check here
okay
okay here comes that's annoying wait
whoa I went the wrong way oh man you
went the wrong way he looked up oh my
goodness
and D5 oh that's bring the king up that
hurts he has a password I'm sorry crazy
that's crazy check
there's nothing yeah King E5 it's
unfortunate for Downing I mean look at
how well he fought in this game after he
completely lost for so many moves it's
completely lost
yeah it's unfortunate for him he's just
trying to keep the king cut off but this
Rook can also go to the D7 square at
some point you can play rookie six to
create shelter for your king
oh it's a draw now he he went way up
Tanya the trickster
oh four seconds three seconds
oh my goodness here you might have
himself
I feel the door man this is this is
tough check and we block oh my goodness
chess is oh man your heart rate
I can't believe this and Donya he
probably played Rook D7 now and just
grabbed this Pawn of course he can give
this check again he has somehow survived
and scored a very critical halfway you
see the smile on dining
oh my goodness
he can't believe it he better go study
some of those books behind him because
he gave all the dark squares and this is
tragic for rosvan priyotu because he was
doing all the right stuff and at this
moment here when his King went to E6 the
check happened he couldn't bring his
King up he didn't realize that he
thought he'd be winning he needs to
bring his King back around because after
this check the king slides back give
this check the king comes to C4 and then
after this check here the King goes to
D3 Now The Rook can't keep checking it
has to go somewhere like here but after
this now white is finally able to make
some progress maybe give this check
before he's thinking back you can also
bring your Rook to the D7 Square I think
that's the easiest way because now
everything is defending one another and
now it's time for the king to just walk
in what A Swindle boy man I was getting
crushed it was like plus 10 and then it
was not and it's a draw that is it chess
is hard boy I'm telling you man wow what
is that practical choices and it was
made time pressure and a crucial draw
there wow
that that result could not be any more
important because after all four games
have finished in the first round of this
match we have a 2-2 score the middle
board for cobras they drew against the
middle boards for the chess bras Magnus
Carlson beats Arena Crush one to the
Yankees Jenna for you that's a board one
beating board four but no Separation on
those middle boards James that was an
exciting first round that was very
exciting of course the chat loved it we
loved it we didn't know what was going
to happen in certain games back and
forth oh my goodness right dania's
losing weight he's not I don't wait huh
emotions everywhere you don't know what
to do right it's crazy but lots of Chess
to be played and that was an awesome way
to start out the first one
it certainly was done in nerdinski a
prophet a wizard a magician you name it
that's what he is but now round one is
in the books we'll take a short break
and when returned Magnus Carlson and the
candle chess for us continue their
chance at a first match Victory against
the Charlotte cobras led by Daniel
nerdiski you'll not want to miss it
we'll be right back
so I loved puzzles I loved solving any
puzzle you put in front of me so chess
was a natural for my brain it was the
unsolvable puzzle it wasn't one of those
things you just looked at here's the
puzzle what's the solution it it was a
puzzle inside of an enigma inside of a
mystery like what is this game and there
was so much to it the more you learn the
more there was to learn so that puzzle
solving uh gift that I had or desire
wish you know I would do crossword
puzzles back in the day as well as a
little as a high school kid fell in love
with New York Times crossword puzzles
had to do one of those every every day
that the puzzle came out in the paper so
I always was a puzzle solver and I think
that that made it easy for me to to
transfer over that skill set to chess
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and we are back here in round two of the
match between the Charlotte cobras and
the Camden chess bras the first round of
action was a 2-2 split Magnus Carlson
winning his game over Arena Crush I
wonder Liang winning his over Jennifer
you James that was exciting stuff Daniel
nerdinski barely surviving uh what do
you think what's gonna happen going
forward well of course that was a
warm-up match so whoever's the hottest
right now when you warmed up like of
course I'll think about it as
professional basketball or football
right or any professional athlete right
what they do is they warm up you see
they still do layup lines before they go
play they still shoot the ball in
practice before they actually go play
that game so of course you do will need
to warm up some hopefully some of the
players warmed up beforehand but this
right here definitely this first match
was a nice little warm-up for both sides
there to get it really in the groove
especially if you lost or you're the
first game so pretty good stuff
hopefully we keep it moving and then
some good some strong chests it's all
about the matchups now though I think so
whatever the matchups look like from
here
all right my headphones just went out
there so uh I was getting back in here
James uh exciting first round
there he is a Magnus Leading The Way
Forward one for the cobras but we'll see
if a Wonder Liang Daniel nerdinski and
the crew can hold them off I mean James
you're playing this match what would
your mindset be my mindset is that hey
you know what it happens right you know
first round it was a little shaky but
it's tied it's tied so because that is
because it's tied we still have time
we're just gonna reset you know I mean I
remember Niha sarin saying that in the
cgc when it was like you know it's
today's a new day and we're just going
to reset when they're asking how you
going to the semis you're about to face
these trunk or you're about to do this
there's a lot of money on the line 100
000 right you know what do you do I just
reset reset and we redo and get back to
it
I feel you I can only feel you there
James gotta reset you gotta you know
just kind of dig deep you know it stinks
to lose but when you're tied two to two
you've all left to play four so as we
see uh the next round of action I wonder
Leanne gets the white pieces as does and
on their disc key and I feel like for
Magnus Carlson he has white as his
ariantari you know you look at the
players with the white pieces you have
to like their chances absolutely I mean
of course especially against uh some of
the lower boards there but they just
because you have the white pieces does
not mean that you just go all out or you
mess up in this case you have to work
and you still got a lot of chests to be
played play your best your team is
behind you and watching and of course
first eight and a half wins that's in
the back of your mind gotta play your
best every Point counts play your best
chest and hopefully
for sure the second round of action is
about to start uh we will have these
players going at it new uh opponents for
them but same lineups a Wonder Liang
scored an important victory in the first
round against Jennifer you Jennifer was
in time trouble he now gets to play
against razvant priyotu and Rosman he's
probably the most disappointed of the
bunch uh he in in that matchup uh
against youngerdiskey he spoiled a
winning chance and well okay this game
it was Aryan against a Wonder so that
was a a little too soon they will play
in the next round here we go I wonder is
playing against there we go Knight F3
didn't he play E4 first like
oh okay all right I'm gonna play this
what the heck is it okay
well he's gonna choose does he play E4
now and get into a sicilian but I wonder
I mean
I mean kind of a player who avoids
Mainline theory he doesn't want to get
into a long preparation battle
no that's actually I was playing a lot
of that on my training account last
night I'm not even gonna lie so I'm
happy to see this I'm like Knight F3 E3
and V3 is next Bishop P2 these are very
quietly dangerous lines they're like
quietly dangerous because if you know
all the ideas I mean you're already
doing well here already got them
thinking here right 83 he's like what do
I do here like what is this you know
what I'm saying you don't know where
they're gonna go and if you're playing
white and you know the plans you feeling
great you like I already know what to do
I feel good here so very confident it's
also very flexible I can go C4 I could
go I could go D4 I could go anything but
B3 is the usual here right so
he plays B3 so it's likely we're gonna
get a transposition to D4 lines where
white plays in this manner uh but I
wonder he really avoids opening Theory
as best as he can and for preo2 you
don't want to get too low on the clock
we just saw what a Wonderland can do to
you even a relatively even position if
you don't have the time to calculate
your options so res event he's going to
be disappointed he needs to put that
behind him uh because this is a very
important game for the Canada just for
us he's a strong player he is I think
underrated he's below 2500 but he is
going to make his presence very much
felt yeah especially after winning that
uh you know just win the Charlotte open
here you got Bishop B2 Bishop G7 now and
C4 yeah this is all Theory here maybe
you see this is the ikaro places stuff a
lot in the very 60 win rate in fact um
with this system believe it or not with
the competition he plays that's pretty
nuts so pretty uh pretty solid I think
we'll have a fight and it's in the same
Center a little bit with B6 Bishop B7
you even have d5s in some cases you can
go e6d5 D6 E5 Knight CC like there's so
many ways to go and so many structures
um to be to pay attention to
yeah so all of this available to Black
well he thinks Let's uh look at our
second game that just started Daniel
naroditski he survived against resident
Pro 2 in the first one now he gets to
play against Jennifer uh you in the
second game so he has
not you know no matchups are easy in
this event so it's going to be tough no
matter where you look but in the early
going you just grab the pawn in the
center and it's trying to get away with
it
yeah that's uh that's some Nifty stuff
there let's see what this is okay got
the what was this opening you for
E5 Knight F3 Knight F6 what do you think
this how did they play this out E4
E5 probably Knight F3 oh this is a I
don't know what this is what is this
what was the move order for this to be
like this it's almost like a Roy but
like with the Knight the bishop on E2
oh this wasn't the game up maybe yeah so
we can just look at how we got here yeah
it looks very bizarre but it started off
in a petrol that's right that's wrong
Bishop B4 and then he takes on E5 So
Daniel just the laying that capture by a
move changing up the Dynamics and what
he's accomplished by playing Knight D3
I've actually played this from the white
side before is that black has you know
good activity a knight on e4 rook and E8
but white has the pair of Bishops so we
see this double pawns here it's kind of
like a Spanish with reverse colors
Blackness black one Bishop B4 and took
the Knight and then white took back so
it's like a spiral Lopez calls reversed
that is so cool bro I've never seen it
like this I've actually only seen this
Knight D3 option and you know when the
world went crazy when uh Magnus played
it against uh Fabi and like that that
Knight D3 and everybody's like oh my
goodness he went 93 because he's never
do that like in the pet shop really so
it's very cool to see this whole idea
and actually knowing it as a uh that's
pretty sweet sweet to know it has a
reverse Roy I never saw it that way
until today so that's pretty cool Chad
hopefully you learned something there
it's not the ideas that you can play in
the Roy you can actually play here too
Obviously good move Knight F4 you can
also play C4 attack the center and Etc
maybe bishop E3 as well I mean easy
moves to make for life
yeah and this Knight out of four is like
when black puts a knight of five in the
Berlin and things like that so uh this
is just a Spanish colors reverse Dania
seems to be happy with its opening with
the bishop pair but you look at him on
screen he's just like digging that emote
I got that if you got the naira diski
emo let's put it inside hold up I know
he got it still
yeah this one right here
calculating send it James send it yeah
it's not just yeah let's say it's not
just calculating it's calculating over
everything I don't know where that goes
exactly everything so
he gets his Bishop out he has the bishop
pair C4 even if a queen trade you have
the pair of Bishops should be better in
the end game and it's not an easy
position for black to figure out just
because there are no obvious plans uh
you see that white is going to play C4
that frustrates you if you play B5 bam
A4 hits you immediately that's bad news
for black so I really like Donna's
opening choice I think Jennifer will
keep thinking here but she has to avoid
the time travel she had in game one so
why don't we look at our four boards
just because Magnus Carlson's game
against Brandon Jacobson has also begun
and we are going to dive into that one
given it's Magnus Carlson we always want
to see Magnus Carlson play because he is
the number one rated player on the
planet he is an absolute beast but no
slouch either absolutely not of course
uh he played especially the online
formats and the fast time controls I
mean bran is competing with the besties
buddy Karo he's bite Nero he's played
everyone he's B's on the leaderboards
he's played man it doesn't matter who it
is he's played him and he's actually
beat them before so Brandon Jacobson Is
Not Afraid here but he does know that
he's up for a huge challenge here
against the number one
for sure
so that's in the bottom left this screen
and the bottom right we see orientarian
Arena crush on some really odd position
where black is missing a Jeep on but as
fianchetto and the position is getting a
bit spicier opening up so all four games
saying at this point but let's dive into
the Magnus game against Brandon Jacobson
just because it's very early stage and
Magnus a minute ahead on the clock it's
his turn black just played a Magnus
Carlsen type of move with H6 I'm already
looking at Queen B3 James I want to get
active here but Brandon he's not just
gonna dilly dally he'll probably bring
his night out to C6 and up to B4 this is
actually what was the move over here was
this his regular cattle and stuff it
looks like it was that but it might have
been yeah it was wow he just plays he
doesn't care like he loves his opening a
lot you see a lot of Catalan from uh
Magnus here I mean it's one of the
openings where you could really can just
push for in advance it's the whole game
um from having very quiet positions in
fact that don't do anything it's really
it's really nice it also can be very
poisonous specifically getting E4 in
this is why the knights 106 Bishop F5 E4
is deterred we're deferred a lot so sort
of like a reverse London system here
with H6 and he put the bishop on H7 you
control the E4 square and you try to
play E5 at some point way later in the
game but this is Magnus you're playing
here after it H6 magnets on the Move
thinking about what to do maybe trying
to make it interesting maybe taking
Queen B3 you have Bishop G2 maybe try to
play E4 Bishop G2 Knight D2 Castle's E4
there's lots of ideas
yeah and I feel like H6 isn't the most
useful move if it looks like a Catalan
uh but with the bishop on F5 or on C8
and playing H6 so Magnus he's trying to
figure out how to punish this he knows
that this is not a standard sequence
it's rare territory for both players but
Magnus he's not certain so I am very
curious if after this big thing I'll
just play the simple straightforward
Bishop G2 develop Castle get the king
out of there or if he'll just pick up
the gauntlet and say let's go for it
let's go for B7 that is a Target because
the bishop is not home anymore
absolutely Queen B3 is definitely
playable because usually you with me
Queen B3 Queen B6 but you can't do that
here so it is it is something to really
pay attention to Queen P3 how do you
respond to Queen B3 is the question
Queen C8 and the whole diagonal D5 Hank
so like Queen B3 is really strong here
actually
I think it's a thematic sacrifice Queen
B3 Knight C6 please go ahead take my B7
Pawn the Knight jumps out to B4 and get
to C2 but the eval bar is suggesting
that this is maybe slightly better for
black complicated and that's scary if
you're Magnus because Brandon likely
played H6 with the knowledge that this
is going to be a decent try for black
the queen over here there might just be
a repetition so we see the last three
moves Bishop G2
C6 and now Queen B3 please like Queen B6
I'm Magnus Carlson I'm the best end game
player of all time you sure you want to
go that route right right you sure you
want to do this big fella are you sure I
give you one last chance right to to not
do this I mean It's just tough right
facing any in-game I guess Magnus is
going to be one of the hardest things to
ever do in your life but it is also a
challenge and you can learn as well so
uh looks like we have that though C5
Queen takes B3 takes and you play B4 B5
you get to sell out from the Carroll
compositions
um in the exchange variation but Han is
on there's usually no C wait it's a
little different
it's an improved version for white right
right you just take and just boom boom
you can't even stop only five right
because if you put A6 the problem is
your Rook is hanging so you play Knight
D7 and B5 still happens because you
can't take with the a pawn your Rook is
loose and this kind of position is
exactly what white wants it's not a
winning Advantage you see it's only half
a pawn but the position is just so much
easier for white to play gaining space
and so that's why after C5 Brandon might
play Queen C7 after Bishop F4 drop the
queen to C8 it's very common uh
defensive mechanism because you're
losing some time but your position
remains very solid I would go for that
against Magnus he's probably also
looking at Queen A6 James just to keep
the B7 Pawn defended and maybe we're in
a more active square but I'm already
worried the bishop comes back and
suddenly there's a problem for the queen
oh that's crazy right that whole idea is
just very tempting and that's very scary
to even face yikes yeah this is tough I
mean that's why I'm not a fan of these
positions obviously with the black
pieces you have to be so accurate Queen
takes is unappealing because you know
the idea before B5 Queen C7 you know
he's going to play Bishop F4 and I think
that's usually what they do in the
London systems anyway this is a reverse
London so Queen C7 between four and um
Queen C8 and then we just have this kind
of slightly worse position Knight D7 and
just develop our pieces maybe play P6
try to hit the C5 Pawn at some point we
do have uh some ideas
look at Brandon he's spending a ton of
time here you don't want to be in time
trouble against Magnus uh well we wait
to see if he takes the queen or drops it
back let's go to our four board scene
just because uh every single game is of
equal importance in the Pro Chesley
you're playing for your team if you win
your game that counts as a point whether
or not you're Magnus Carlson and so
Brandon Jacobs in the bottom left he
does bring his Queen all the way back to
C8 after a long think Magnus will try to
punish it with rapid development let's
look at a game we haven't seen yet
that's in the bottom right the game
between orientari and Irina Crush
because Arena she lost the first game to
Magnus Carlson now with the black pieces
uh this is going to be a very very
interesting battle James look at this it
is this position what is this
oh bro whoa what was this how did we get
here how did we get here bro
I don't know how we got here but we know
there's no going back
you're throwing those pawns forward they
don't move backwards G3 is a bit tender
as well if this Knight James could be on
C3 we'd be loving White's position but
that night is very far away
oh man this is this is something here
what do you put the king at G3 is weak
so he's just developed whatever
developed a piece knight H4 maybe a
knight to G6 there's some squares there
maybe I Castle Queen inside but that is
indeed a maybe and maybe I just wait to
wait to see where you put your king here
but Knight H4 Knight G6 is very tempting
I mean at least I get a nice piece on G6
yeah and F5 actually may be a Target
Bishop H3 Rook F1 just go for it with
all our pieces I like that and what does
black do by the way because Queen D7
Castle's Queen side then what like I
can't a bunch of moves I think you might
have to consider the move D5 but five is
a bit loose and my stuff's gonna hang
around
yeah it's actually correct what does
black do as it is her move right now you
need to come up with some type of plan
you got to get pieces off the back rank
it's kind of hard maybe you need a
waiting move you know Knight H4 is
coming maybe bishop F6 no but I'm not
trying to give it that Bishop so E4 not
enough to take You're Gonna Play Knight
H4 anyway E4 is without weak
yikes yeah maybe that whole idea just
Queen D7 Castle Queen side get the king
safe quickly and then we'll figure out
what to do next at least we get our
pieces out development usually isn't bad
that's one thing I always like to like
remember when you're playing you you
have to get the pieces out we know this
get the pieces on the back ring get a
king safe good things happen in your
position
yeah so I I wonder what the downside of
Queen D7 is it just looks very natural
at this stage uh maybe there's an
argument oh no I'm hanging the pawners
let's say Bishop F6 just to make sure
your Knight's not getting to H4 so
freely I don't think I want to give up
this H6 point so she does after quite an
extensive think play through Queen D7
we're expecting Knight H4 sink the teeth
into the G6 Square the problem for black
is this H6 Pawn needs the rook and The
Bishop's defense those are the two
pieces and that means The Rook might
have to go up to H7 that's pretty ugly
that is pretty ugly that is pretty ugly
and that night is going to be chilling
there for a while and I mean Bishop F7
but it's a concession you give up the
light squares and my light Square Bishop
is an absolute Beast so Knight G6 is
definitely gonna be strong yeah Rook H7
because you're giving up H6 I can't just
give that up I can't just give up H6
like that okay hey concession you have
to make it it's done so maybe we try to
act on our faster development here maybe
play E4 at some point Knight G6 on the
board Rick H7 now we can play Play
Bishop F6 Queen G7 E4 Maybe
oh my gosh there's also something
available if this Rook goes up to H7
just to defend then there might be
Bishop takes Knight over here I'm just
gonna show that very quickly you can't
take with the queen because this Knight
jumps into the E7 check with a fork and
she she did play Rook H7 and if you have
to take with the pawn on C6 I'm already
looking at B4 Rook B1 Queen A5 let's go
against this King this is ugly yeah it's
pretty ugly but yeah that's right and
the nice little on G6 wow this from both
sides of the board I can also hide my
king on D2 or F2 even castling should be
fine King the H2 and run away Rook 287
on the board he could take Pawn takes
and also go with B4 or Rook B1 open up
the file there pieces seem uncoordinated
for black you also get off of the dark
Square oh castles
oh
what do you care about life you have to
stay far away from that man stay far
away from that man when he doesn't even
care about his own safety wow yeah
Castle's king size he's walking into
where these ponds are storming but maybe
he just believes in this Knight on G6
that you can't kick it out very easily
and if you bring your knight back in
comes before in comes Rook B1 let's just
go after the black king yeah he really
is like man I mean all-out initiative
all-out attack I am a big fan of that
kind of Chess from Ariane it's already
there castles B4 King B8
okay okay what do we do
where's that King hiding I mean it goes
to A8 it's still in line with this
bishop over here so I'm looking at Rook
a to B1 and I might even sacrifice an
exchange I was just thinking that yeah I
was just thinking B4 immediately or even
A3 B4 I mean A3 B4 is kind of nice
because I I get everything A3 I play
Rook B1 B4 is coming
wow okay well everyone is probably gonna
think here with B4 being on the agenda
let's go to our four board scene just to
see what's happening in the teammates of
these two players uh all games are still
in session here in the second round of
action we've seen the top right done in
there this key with the bishop pair and
he's facing an isolated Pawn advantage
narodiski in the top left I wonder Liang
I mean he is a force he is up a pawn
against resvan preo2 good news for the
cobras on those two boards and then the
bottom left Magnus okay let's go to
magnus's game I mean we should always go
to Max's game in the world is happening
what is it what happened there how's our
Pawn on D6 yep oh man you know what I
know exactly where I'm so he got E4 and
he went Knight F to D2 which is the
common idea you do that a lot obviously
you want to get your E4 you put it
anyway oh his Bishop under attack and he
goes bam you take mine I take yours your
king is going to be in the center for
longer term the bishop slides back and
Bishop D6 his whole point is he wants to
throw an E5 that would be a protected
pass pawn and so Brandon's like no no no
no I gotta get rid of that one but then
H4 G4 H5 please take me oh my goodness
what is he doing this you don't you
can't if you you don't know what he's
gonna do that's scary because you don't
know his next move you have no idea what
he's going to do he's just launching
stuff at you now wow beautiful stuff
that's strong boy that's strong he can
grab this Pawn here he can castles King
in either direction if he's been
studying chess with Aryan tari he's
probably going kingside uh just to walk
into where he's pushed his Pawns but
this Pawn on these such a thorn in Black
side and it's very difficult to get
because it looks two moves away but the
queen is stuck defending this B7 Pawn
it's a vulnerable Pawn here James I love
the way Magnus is handling this
absolutely of course especially when you
get e4n into Catalin and you have these
type of positions you are already doing
quite well when you get the E4 push in
this is what we're looking to do anyway
it's very nice it becomes a very sharp
position he takes what's a push it it's
besides Bishop takes E4 James this whole
game is against the rules of Chess we
typically shape with a knight but here's
a please take my Bishop I take back the
F6 square is vulnerable I protected my
healthy past Pawn on D6 even though it's
doubled and isolated Magnus Carlson is
just an absolute Beast no surprises
there but Brennan Jacobson is feeling
like the brunt of his force and he's
down a minute and a half and after
Bishop e494-94 the threat is D7 you have
a D7
97 96 if Queen D7 Knight F6 if King D7
Knight maybe C5 or queen A3 or something
it's a Sig
Fork there it's nasty the queen takes
four there and if which means the king
takes you have to take with the King
look at your King on D7 my guy you're
king of D7 Queen A3 Maybe
we'll just get into all the before
something's that looks great so look at
you you're doing your tactics and Brent
says no no no I'm gonna get my king out
of there but look at this
Magnus says you go kingside Iowa Queen
side and now B7 can be captured uh
perhaps if you're Magnus you could think
about the queen trade I may have seemed
like it's out of the question but you
could just bring a rook to E1 and go for
this Pawn that lands on the Square maybe
rookie won right away because if Queen
takes Knight takes Knight coming to C5
things like this I feel like white is
just way better coordinated as Pawn F5
is also quite weak I mean that's kind of
one of the the uh good the great things
about the Catalan is that you know it is
a very positional opening but it gets a
good position where lots of tactics and
good in games can come from it it's like
an all-around just wonderful opening to
play
um where you get everything from there
Bobby says uh tactics flow from a
superior position and a lot of times you
can find yourself in very comfortable in
sometimes Superior positions in the
Catalan here as uh we see magnets do all
the time time after time again loving
the Catalan and having a great question
he's gonna trade Queens he's gonna do
what he does best rookie one this is a
forest variation Queen takes Pawn Knight
C4 the queen is trapped on unless you go
back to B8 and then he can just trade
queens in a favorable end game for what
you don't have to trade Queens you can
bring it away but if you do trade Queens
into this end game after the swap I
think Knight D6 Scoops up F5 and H6 is
weak and the e-file is whites for the
taking this is really bad news for
Brandon Jacobson so everything hang in
pawns everywhere I mean it's just very
tough here very tough of course you are
playing Magnus so that's already tough
what's the time situation yeah about to
go under a minute as well it is
difficult it is difficult you are under
Fire here Queen B7 rookie one is played
does Brent have any other is Queen's
under attack if he brings his Knight in
you just take it you can't make those
moves slowly again it all happens and
it's there and it's on the board he's
gonna take and play Knight D6 and then
just gobble up the pawns I just have a
better position H6 is hanging
you know what it's like it's like when
you're a younger brother and your big
brother sits on you that's exactly
what's going to happen
yeah right like I can't do anything I'll
punch it I can't get out of this and
that's what's gonna happen with Knight
D6 and then rookie seven you can't bring
a rook to E8 you are just absolutely
Frozen oh that's hilarious only brings
it backwards instead of forwards and he
just eyes off the G4 Pawn so Magnus says
all right I'll just take the material
you take on H5 I take on G4 and
Brandon's doing a pretty decent job I
might say because he wants to protect
this pawn and go after this one later
but Magnus is now up on at least for the
time being absolutely he's up a pawn and
of course I mean you already hate going
to in-games with Magnus now you're down
a pawn in the in-game against Magnus
just very difficult it's very very
difficult situation here Magnus is
playing some great chess
and Brandon is under time now of course
you cannot give up here he's not going
to give up and it's not going to give up
but it is very difficult the time
situation playing magnets down upon
in an in-game that is just worse right
now
and that apparently was not the right
continuation he had to take on D5 now
that pawn can go up to the D6 Square you
push your past pawns and Magnus first
brings his Knight that push is not going
anywhere this Knight can jump into E5
and this Rook can slam down on E7 I feel
like it's all about this past Pawn on D5
and Brandon has no time to consider
anything
yeah this is an AC4 look at the nice air
very good positioning we're a 95 could
be played two everything's happening wow
sorry we have to go to our four board
scene because I just saw the chord in my
eye there is a Time scramble between a
Wonder Liang and Resident prior to and
that game is wild the king
Rick D4 get him off the board wait no no
that doesn't work no and no Black's
winning oh my goodness because the B2
Pawn you can't take it you get mated
so what did he miss over there Queen he
went Queen before Rick D4 King there I
have no idea I have no idea what that
could have been might even go up to G1
you know to help out because there's
only a single check and then the king
can I think he's gonna hide
oh so I took the pawn relax man hold on
great move great move oh he wants to
come over here why not
okay okay
just push the pawn you can't stop it The
Queen Is Gonna block all checks and the
H Pawn is going my goodness rosvin is
such a strong player bro F oh that
almost works
there's nothing you can do about it you
really can't stop it jeez
James I'm gonna go back because you're
not gonna believe when I saw this game
at the corner of my eye you're gonna
wait for it okay there was a pawn right
on uh on E7 evaluation bar is saying why
is completely winning check this out
two queens oh hey bro hey
man I'm knocking everything over in
front of me I wonder only at 7.8 seconds
it forced mate if he takes this bishop
and queen takes Queen into his Checkmate
unfortunately you start with queen h8
and that's how the king ran away and
then it was even winning for black at
this point because the King on H3 is
somehow safe and this is just ridiculous
like he could have you know he could
have grabbed this Rook but he did the
you know this winning thing where he
ended up using his pawns to his
advantage that was a ridiculous series
events that's where they yeah you have
to and that's a rattling game that's
rattling and you know even uh see Carl
says like you gotta have that short term
memory loss with losers with losses but
this one is where it gets hard because
like how to forget that you lost this
game for the team it hurts and like ah I
could have and then you're going to the
next game like okay he's still feeling
it you can tell I mean absolutely he's
like I lost his are you kidding me I was
completely winning we've all been there
like I was completely winning you know
I'm crushing how did I lose this game we
have to shake it off there it happens it
did happen it was a Wild game right
rosvin's a very strong player too as
well it happened we just bounced back
and keep moving
yeah so let's go back to our four board
scene because again also won with the
white piece you see the final move is a
check winning The Rook uh and he just up
material and then we see in the bottom
left Magnus Carlson up a rook against a
knight it's actually a rook and two
pawns ahead for white compared to just
one night with Brandon Jacobson in the
bottom Arena Crush in big trouble
against uh Aryan tari and Magus Carlsen
just won that game so you see all that
extra material for magnets in the bottom
left so let's go to the game that is
still remaining Irina Crush she has the
black pieces but unfortunately for her
she's down material she's down on the
clock it's really bad news very bad news
here yeah of course with them I mean
it's the best whoa whoa whoa whoa no I
saw the evil Barco crazy I was like what
happened okay so uh yeah this is just
lost that's tough GG
when you're playing strong players like
that's what it is it happens tough game
yeah I mean she had a black piece
against Aryan tari he cast some things
that her thing was open and there we see
a win for the chess bras that was a bad
round for the cobras a great round for
the chess bras and wonder Liang that
could swing the match into the chess
Bros favor because if had he won the
game it would have been a 2-2 tie for
the second round in a row but because of
priyotu Chess Bros win this round three
to one a huge huge game there huge swing
for rasmine prior to and the chessboard
absolutely I mean that swing there makes
it heal I mean that's that's that's that
hurts man it really does right because
like you take that you go back to the
locker room you know like after the half
and you go back to the locker room and
you talk yourself like what happened how
do I do this like bounce back man get
out of this you know what we started out
even we still have chess left two rounds
we can do this right we just got to stay
focused and there's a different matchup
coming up now
yeah you can't do it it is possible for
sure but they are going to need to get a
little bit of rest some relaxation some
preparation in because when they return
you're still facing Magnus Carlsen
orientari and the rest of the chess bras
Bunch uh but we are also going to head
towards a break but before we do just
want to give a quick shout out to an
event that is coming your way in just
under a week because chess played quick
it's a fun series of events and it
Returns on February 20th watch your
favorite streamers battle our AI Bots
claim bounties and buy their share of a
prize fund of 2 000 twitch subs don't
miss this month's just play quick AI
plays February 20th at 9am Pacific Time
use the command cpq in chat for more
info James and I will be right back this
is the pro chess League 2023 season it's
just day one the action continues just a
few chest bras and the cobras
[Music]
foreign
becoming a chess streamer like your
favorite creators such as Hikaru Gotham
chess and the bowtest sisters come on
look at this
look at this chess.com is excited to
announce the community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chess.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and return here at the pro chess League
2023 season it is the first day one
match is in the books it was the Indian
yogis against the Brazil capifaros are
currently watching the Canada chess bras
take on Charlotte cobras James it's been
an exciting first day of action the
Indian yogis look kind of Unstoppable in
that matchup and in progress we have the
cobras and the Canada chess Bros that
one seems a little closer absolutely of
course so the match earlier with the
yogis I mean they just absolutely
dominated they did their thing of course
we say this in the Indian water
everybody over there strongly was just
ready and of course dropped a few games
there copper Bears was just not able to
keep up at the end of the day yogis were
able to advance and then we have the
cobras versus the chess bras here very
intense match very close of course it
was even after the first one and then
after the second one chess bras was able
to pull away a little bit so cobras are
going to have to really bite with some
Venom in this next
oh some Venom I like uh the sound of
that and I think that Daniel neraditsky
and his crew they will need to Showcase
their best chess uh for Dania that's
shaky first game where he held the drug
against razuma pro 2.02 has kind of been
the unsung hero for the can the chess
bras he just scored one half out of two
points against Daniel narodiski and a
Wonder Liang and it could have been two
out of two if he finished that game off
against Daniel he was able to win that
but Dania he Slither his way out in that
end game so he's helping keep the
Charlotte cobras in this match very very
uh strong chess obviously I mean this is
so much to go on so much chess left guys
I mean even tomorrow we have a match
with uh the chess Wizards versus versus
my Garden State passer so that's going
to be fun so we're ready for that it's
time to play and be ready on the examine
we gotta go stand off in second and
Linderman and also a Trisha is playing
so it's gonna be very strong I'm ready
for that line up there but uh the lineup
right now that we have is actually where
the bras and the cobras here so in this
next round we got our yantari playing
White against a Wonderland there near
Disney playing Black against Magnus
Brandon Brando playing White against
Jenna for you and the arena Crush
[Music]
potato black against Magnus Carlson
that's the big one in round three all
right Atari also White against the one
Liang so the Norway gnomes if they score
three now points they can put away
Charlotte cobras that is not going to be
easy given how tough the cobras are this
one is just a couple moves away from
being a 4-4 locked match but the cam
chess bras in the lead and as you
mentioned James I mean you're playing
your team is playing tomorrow against
the levitov chess Wizards and of course
the Spanish Maniac shrimp they take on
the Norway gnome so the action does not
stop today it continues every day
throughout the week Wednesday we have a
double header Thursday the same Friday
at double header as well it's just
exciting times here at the protest
League yeah of course there's so much
chess to watch right it's just like the
pros going at it as you see everybody
brought Magnus out heavy hitter team
Indians all of these GMS are on the team
every one of them probably are playing
for some team or helping the team right
so they're all together there we like to
see that camaraderie we like to see the
camaraderie with you future being here
watching it and we bring this content to
you
hey well this uh next round is about to
begin our entire with the white pieces
against the Wonder Liang and I don't see
an Ari Atari you don't see it already on
there 20 seconds I don't think they get
a time back usually you know they'll be
all nice and stuff just kind of I'll
give you your time back this for the
team bro he's not here coach he's not
here right run the clock
run the clock yes you're here he was
given a time and he just went away and
has been out and about but if he doesn't
come back that is going to be a huge oh
the game has been aborted so they
started without him being there they did
him the favor of letting him come back
but Aryan where are you buddy you need
to play your game against the Wonder
Liang oh yeah delay of game you know
Super Bowl delay of game uh delay of
game five yards
ivr penalty uh at the 10. give me give
me my time
well while we wait for orientare to come
back to his chair I mean we know that
this matchup will be super important
later uh but later today we will see Dan
mereditski take on orientare in the
final round when board one plays board
one two versus two three verse three
four versus four I feel like it that
final round matchup actually is one that
Charlotte should be very happy about
because uh on the top two boards where
they are underrated or I should say a
lower rated compared to Magnus and
orientare they get the white pieces
there and Brando we know what he's
capable of the black pieces again those
two James like that is a toss-up to me
that's a toss-up yeah especially rasmine
if he's I mean he's in good form he's in
good form he's almost been there Dixie
there I mean winning another game draw
like he's playing great finger now of
course he was losing against a Wonder
there but he was not able to close and
if not ever close there I mean it just
matters in that game right there at that
time who's a better player right now
right so that's what it's really about
is who is better at this game right now
and can score on the board so we can
make it to the next match
well the chess Pros just not seem not to
be at the board and man they just stay
chilling they partying right now you
know their chest problem I'll be there
this weekend we'll see what's up they
over there nobody's there like Magnus
not into a deceit there yeah okay
well they might actually be partying I
mean the chess Pro is likely streaming
uh this coverage of Magnus Carlson our
antari and the rest of the crew and
that's the thing about the protesting it
really isn't just about magnets we are
going to watch his games he may win
every single game he plays uh but uh the
every single player is important and
perhaps no player has been more
important to the can of Chess bras in
this match thus far than preyotsu he
drew Dania from a winning position he
allowed Donna to escape and then he
beats Wonder Liang from a lost position
so he has one and a half out of two and
gets the top two boards for the cobras
that is what you need take down the team
as powerful as Charlotte yeah that's
tough that's tough I mean the cobras are
a very powerful team absolutely and they
get one and a half out of two out of the
top boards there I mean cool I mean the
rest is not easy by far I mean that's
not even the word right but it is like
okay the top two boards right I have
been able to do one and a half out of
two let me just try to keep playing good
chess and see what I do in these next
two games
and we see now Irina Crush she gets the
white pieces against uh not orientare
but Raz Von priyotu and D4 played by
crush he's always been a D4 player and
this is a big matchup for the cobras
because Irena has lost her first two
games but with the white pieces against
resven who's been performing well she
can take him down and she throws this
queen A4 check against the grunfels yeah
I'm a grunfield player myself I do like
growth Kings Indians this one a queen D7
one yeah the queen d71 is very uh nice
wow Bishop B5 I've never seen actually
that is an interesting move
yes one of these lines where you provoke
the move C6 because now the Knight
doesn't have a square to get out from so
look at Black's pieces Queen on D7
Knight on B8 both kind of stuck there
the bishop
yeah usually play C5 right that is
what's going to happen but Irina it
quickly played Knight F3
um she can also decide if she wants to
stop the move C5 at some point or bring
her Bishop around so I think it's now or
block you need to strike with C5
absolutely C5 just I mean you get a
delayed version of it the C5 would be a
great move here and if it should be five
now we can move the queen away and
actually going to G4 which is going to
be very very strong hitting G2 and E4
these are ideas you actually see from uh
all the Greenfield courses and all the
grid field books they actually do uh
cover this idea quite in detail here
very strange grundfill here but of
course lots of play for black and
activity which is what we as everything
you're looking for in a grinfeld for
white here and we have the strong Center
big stuff right maybe bishop B3 H3
castling all these moves are very
logical
I want to point out a funny tactic oh B5
was playing wow that is wow dangerous
move strategically runs the quickly show
the queen G4 Knight G5 whoa defense E4
and if you take G2 well thank you very
much for your Queen Bishop F3 your queen
has nowhere to go they see the
evaluation bar reacting between would
have been trapped on G2 No Escape
squares in the bishop does protect the
Knight white Bishop protects the Rook on
H1 but instead James B5 like that move
if you don't follow it up with like C5
Plus at some point yeah it's pretty
gross yeah you usually we'll see this in
like you know um the viennas or like a
semi-slave where you play A6 B5 Bishop
B7 but you paid a groonfield so that's a
little bit different I mean in fact it's
just different right so we have to you
know still play C5 maybe A6 Bishop B7
but maybe we don't have to play A6 right
now to play C5 because the the B5 Pawn
is defended so maybe we just go C5
anyway which you know we were trying to
play at some point
yeah we'll see if resident plays C5
other games are getting underway so
we're just gonna hop away from this one
for a moment as president plays A5 A5
all Queen side I mean but hey he
understands Greenfield is all about that
he's a queen size in the center that's
your trumps in the cornfield it is
indeed but while uh you know they figure
this out and I like White's position uh
Reno's looking like she's in good shape
here another game has begun it is the
board three for the cobras Brandon
Jacobson he has the white pieces against
Ward four for the chess bra that's
Jennifer you and early stages there well
we can Dive Right In because it's
another sort of unusual position with
pawns and A4 and A5 another Bishop B5
check here so I think Brandon's just
trying to catch her off guard yeah I
don't know what this man what maybe just
they just play on kind of stuff today
how did you get here what is this
where's the C pod
E3 move too you know another one
C4 okay D4 wow just E4 A4 like
wow I like the center from White hair
very strong Knight to c3h4h5 intentions
are coming from me I'm not just anytime
you see a bishop on G7 because of Lila
these days I'm just H4 H5 I don't even
think twice about it I love playing H4
in there get Knight g5s in and just you
know go for the mate here you can also
set the King on F1 and be pretty solid
but you know it's not necessary it's
definitely fun right I like what you're
saying whenever you see a fan cutter
structure you think h4h5 and you know
all these neural Nets are doing that so
it means that we should too of course
and the bishop came in D7 to block the
check are you afraid of Bishop takes B5
I'm not so sure because after Pawn takes
the Knight on B8 is dominated by the
pawn three squares away so I feel like
uh Brennan he's playing Knight C3 and if
it takes he may just take with the pawn
over here not with the Knight he's a
little bit ahead in the clock the
position I think is anyone's game James
because black may even throw forth an F5
type of move to crack in the center yeah
F5 is coming with an E5 as well uh E5
well H3 wow he doesn't want any Bishop
G4 business yeah because H4 Bishop G4
totally understand so H3
and F5 is definitely risky E5 will be
pushed I just pushed past you there and
Bishop E6 Knight C5 yeah I think you're
not in time you're right and you need to
be able to play like C5 but your knight
is on B6 so anytime you play C5 and
white takes your knight on B6 is just
hit so the knights in the wrong spot
yeah it's definitely a misplaced and
taking again I mean what do I do with my
pieces should I just develop
nice C6 B4 square is mine so maybe I
just put the Knight on B4 and just at
least at least again going back to
development you got to get your pieces
off the back ring and so you just do it
so you capture it and C6 very nice
attacking the B Pawn
yep and Jennifer wants to get her Knight
to C6 and put pressure on the center and
this bishop would love to go to E3 but
in Comes This Knight to C4 so I've been
hating on the night on B6 but it
actually has a plan so both sides with
their chances here let's zoom out for a
moment just because all four games are
underway uh we know that Magnus Carlson
uh he has the white pieces against Dan
neraditski and our antari also has white
against a Wonder laying in the top left
so the board is flipped for now but we
will get that switch for you uh but we
do see that Magnus versus Dunya let's go
right into that one because Magnus is
playing
oh yeah Meredith is like I'm gonna bring
the best he loves the king's Indian and
he played It Against the World Champ
himself
what do you think of that James it's
very risky because it is strategically
tough opening when it's done as bread
and butter that's right it is and I
think you know he's gonna go with his
best and I would do the same thing I
would go with my absolute best what I
like it's in fast time controls best
right because as time controls is
different you know in the classical game
like this might be tougher way tougher
to play this opening um with Supply
pieces but here I mean time is low
things can happen and as kings Indians
are very sharp you know how he plays
them he knows the ins and outs so I
think it's a good practical choice
yeah I'm with you and I think that for
Donya he really does not want to lose
this game both personally and for the
team Magnus Carlson on a bit of a
rampage right now if you can slow him
down that would be great for your team's
chances heading into this round the
chess bras were up five to three so
Donya can at least draw against Magnus
and the rest of the team can score some
points they'll be right back in this but
the problem with the king's Indian is
this is not a tactical King's Indian
where you have F5 in it's a positional
one and this bishop on G7 not the best
piece at least for the time being and
look at Don you go Queen A5 I'm already
looking can't I play Rook B1 and B4 A3
and B4 or should I take the time to
defend this Pawn on e4 because it is
under attack as the knights either is
pinned there's also B4 immediately in
weird cases B4 Queen takes Rook B1 Queen
A5 Rook B5 and then Queen back and
Bishop takes C5 or something takes C5
but maybe Queen to C7 so that doesn't
work well it's it's all kinds of things
here but the for for uh diet standpoint
I mean he has Knight takes E4 uh death
definitely coming so Knight to G3 okay
cool cool defends it understandable this
black send it here is it one of those
positions where you just toss your Pawn
up the board I don't like B5 because
all right you gotta take with the pawn
that's the pawn annoying part B5 looks
so nice though so King's indian-esque so
maybe go Bishop D7 to play B5
yeah Bishop B7 seems calmer I feel like
there's some shirt game maybe it's
Hikaru against grashook that was in this
type of position and I think white can
play Rook B1 now and B4 it might have
been from the Grand Prix the feeding
Grand Prix that hikar won to qualify for
the candidates wow
okay
you play [__] 57 too as well for 67
just trying to play this B5 move
you know James you won there it is
you're a coach right when you look at
this position white looks like they're
in terrible shape the kings in the
center they haven't finished their
development uh but then you see the eval
bar saying plus one for white so how do
you sort of
teach your students a position like this
when it looks bad but in fact it's good
well of course yeah you have to talk
about why what what are the Assets in
the position and what are the
liabilities so I mean there's a little
bit of both but the assets here okay
white is developed we have some space
maybe not fully developed but we do have
some space and I think space is a huge
Advantage we even see that from the
reassessor chess talking about just
space material things like that space
huge Advantage I have the Jeep you can't
push F5 you know I actually do control
the sort of the pawn break of F5 I can
play F4 I have an open file now open B
file
um and I have the Bishops I think my
pieces look better than blacks does the
bishop on G7 compare the pieces right
Bishop on G7 Bishop on E3 much better
piece my knight on G3 defending E4 I
could also maybe hop into F5 at some
point after defending the E4 Pawn with
F3 maybe trying to play Knight F5 or H5
H4 H5 is a is a move as well with the
pawn so the knight's a little bit better
I would say but it may be about equal
there I think the queen for black is
better placed than whites Queen but the
Rook is on B1 is better place than um
the the account parts right now King
placement Black's a little bit better so
white slightly slightly but I mean you
could argue that black actually could be
slightly better from a human standpoint
I like what you're saying and I think
for Magnus at some point he may consider
the move C4 because in the end game or
at least in the queenless position the
king can happily sit in the center the
bishop on G7 is the worst minor piece on
the board whereas the bishop 183 is
healthy and staring in both directions
so I do like this uh position for Magnus
I think his minor pieces are better he
has more space but it's a solid position
for black and the move G5 it does allow
Dania at the right moment to open up
some of his pieces but look at Magnus
confidently pressing forward here saying
go for F6 I'm not worried about that
move in the slightest I'll just play H4
and reinforce my Pawn Yeah the problem I
think with the king's Indian is that in
these day and time especially against
strong players is they you don't get the
king's Indian you want the one that so
oh who played the king's Indian to
attack where did he attack this entire
game right you know where where was that
you know it's very tough playing this
obviously very positional one but you
can't get very good in games from it if
you have obviously the right the right
plans and every everything has to work
out but this is tough it looks like a
grip in the center here again that
Bishop is extremely bad you take with
the pawn here look at the dark Square
Bishop we have an H file that's open I
think it's a clear plan for white trying
to double on the H file exactly
maybe bishop right
is it just it can move around like this
but it's not going anywhere this bishop
we're on C5 oh yeah cheat and do that
now we're talking white would be happy
right black would be happy rather but
that Bishop cannot get out your pawns
are all in the way so Dania you might
just be playing safe chess and say
you're not going to make any progress
there are no queens in the board there's
no checkpoint attack I can always slide
my Bishop back where is this Knight
going where is magnus's Knight aiming
for is it this square is it this square
and maybe F4 many questions to answer
that's actually Correy I'm trying to
figure out what is this plan F4 will
probably be it is it's just a huge
blunder why would you we can open up the
position King in the center the pawn on
e4 will be hanging The Bishop's nice now
so F4 will be a fatal blunder
um positionally but I mean the Knight
maybe it swings around yeah where does
the night go like maybe you go Rook H3 I
mean Rook B3
yeah swing The Rook over yeah also this
this Pawn not really a Target because
the bishop can just sit up on E3 so the
bishop seven clearly the worst piece
Magnus trying to prove his Knight Donya
trying to prove his as well and I don't
think Knight C5 is a good move here I
would snap that off immediately I
wouldn't even take a second to think you
play 95 I take it I take it
you take with the d-pod I have a past
Pawn is protected right he played Knight
C5 wow okay let's see if Magnus grabs
that because if you take with the B Pawn
an open B file should be good for the
Rook though the F2 Pawn maybe is a
little bit tender because Rook can
always slide up one square to defend I
really like mag's position but I also
feel like Dania yeah he's just solid
here he's definitely solid yeah there's
like there's no breakthrough this he's
definitely very solid and I like this
about diamonds position very great
choice extremely solid played his
favorite opening King's Indian and you
know we have a position like this this
is fine actually I mean the engine
thinks otherwise by like point something
they always think that even before you
start the game it's like oh engines
Point 43 or something I was looking I
was like how is it you didn't even move
yet right so
it's you know I think it's very equal
very nice from uh this bishop is so
strong I think I see why Magnus did not
take the Knight it's protecting G5 it's
protecting F2 so there's no threats
anywhere in the position because the
bishop holds everything down but Dania
is just saying you can't make any
progress is there going to be A4 A5
maybe you need to do something like that
Dania Is Not Afraid his Rook can slide
back and forth along the seventh rank I
love the way he's playing this why don't
we take a zoom out just for a second
because this game Magnus has the
advantage slight Advantage but still so
much life left let's look across the
four boards James what's catching your
eye let's see whoa there's a knight on
C6 Bishop on C3 what game is that that's
the arena Crush game with Rosman that
game look Wicked there's some stuff
going on there E6 what the heck is going
on there Rook on D5 she played E6 right
there
what is happening I I had to count the
material quickly and it's actually even
material but this Knight on C6 looks so
dominant and yet the evaluation Bar says
go away it's just right there's no
problems here I'm looking at this I'm
looking at this how in the world is
white not just better here
that's so crazy bro all right chess is
so hard right like obviously not just
better I got a clear plan I mean maybe
not clear but double the Rooks I have a
past D Pawn you tell me this is equal A5
hanging in many cases what is this like
double the Rooks and take on A5
yeah wow James is saying double The Rook
says Quinn if I would be a one mood
blunder Rook takes C6 The Rook on D3 is
hanging it's loose uh on the Square so
that's why either double the Rooks first
just defend the upward rook and then
take on a five step one complete oh whoa
you see the evil barge out yeah what is
that
is rookie it's like rookie it was Queen
of five I'm so confused by everything
that's happening here
yeah rookie two is a threat I guess
going after these
pots oh there's a cool tactic I'm gonna
show it very quickly say let's say we go
like this and King goes back to G1 Rook
takes D6 Works to take with the pawn to
lose your queen and if you take with the
queen queen takes F2 so that Queen of
the five is overloaded so I like the
look of this for resven all of a sudden
I thought that first glance arena is
much better but he's going for it James
he's going for this attack yeah that's a
sick that's a sick tactic rookie two
Rick takes C6 is GG wow yeah that's
pretty gross so gotta be careful uh what
do you actually do I'm kind of tied down
Queen B6 but you know I can't take the
Rook so that doesn't do anything wow
foreign
I mean it's possible but then rookie two
in the end and then I go Queen C5
I don't know stuff
if wika played D6 that's what I'm trying
to do the queen is loose here so is
there anywhere we can move this queen
not right without rookie two you got to
stay up exactly you got to stay around
so she play Rook E3 makes sense
all right and by the way look at the
clocks she's up a minute and 10 seconds
and irina's had some trouble on the
clock in the previous games it's great
to see her jumping out to a lead on time
and that's bad news for the chess Bros
yeah absolutely yes um lead on a clock
there wow look at that like nice
position past Pawn here black can easily
make a mistake 97 is actually on tap
right now so you got to be careful uh
you blunder the fork and the pawns
running through
two so this Rook moves you could take A2
but then the D6 Pawn right it goes up
because this Queenie eight check always
protecting this Knight this is scary
stuff so think about this though what if
you like uh oh yeah you're right yeah
yeah Queenie Queenie Rook takes C6 Queen
E8 yeah but uh I mean maybe he does take
on A2 and run the b b and a pawns
because that's scary too you get rid of
A2 you sack Rook takes Knight
um and we run the B Pawn but that's
that's probably too risky it's not it's
not a necessary effect
yeah you need to D6 Rook C6 Queen E8
King G7 Queen takes C6 B yeah yeah I'm
not fast enough the d-pawn is too fast
yeah now this is a a situation where
those pawns maybe Runners for black but
uh White's Pawn is very quick as well
King G7 come move step out the way
exactly but now I'm more enticed once
the queen leaves if I go King G2 I'm
thinking like can I sacrifice on the
see-through scribe don't think you're in
time though with all these pawns hanging
so for arena she needs to come up with a
move right now Queen takes A2 is
definitely on the docket we think day
two is definitely coming right there's
no check anymore and of course that
b-pawn is very fast now I like the rook
and the queen around the bishop here
because we can't really push the b-pawn
well actually you could you can go B2
and then that would be over so there's
some scary stuff with these past bonds
here who's as faster is the question
who's is faster
you're like black suddenly is like an
easier position to play yeah and when
while she is thinking Irina is two
minutes and 20 seconds let's zoom out
for a second just because all games are
equally important in the Pro chess
League we see on board three Brandon
Jacobson with a winning advantage
against Jennifer you her clock is
ticking down let's tune into that one
quickly because it may be the last time
we see it it feels like Brandon is
winning material and Jennifer in fact
has resigned on the spot the last couple
moves that were played you see here is
that blacks pieces are all loose this
Palm with the D5 there's trouble down
the D Lane the bishop hits the Knight
The Rook is trying to join the party and
it just is a loss of a piece absolutely
it's just too much pressure too much
pressure on the night before Pawn takes
an E5 piece is gone there peace is gone
very nice play from Brandon to put the
points up for the cobras there
important win for the cobras and we'll
go away from this game just because it
seemed pretty one-sided so that means
the cobras they need to get the job done
the other boards Daniel narzitski still
in his matchup against Magnus Carlson
that one is looking relatively stable
for black not an easy position to play
and Donya down to a minute in nine
seconds we know he's the bullet uh King
he's a maestro he doesn't need much time
but you're playing Magnus Carlson all
right we're playing Magnus crossing here
it's always tough like that's like the
Magnus effect right when like you think
everything's going well or you may be
even winning you just sometimes you just
don't see it now Magnus has played near
discus played magnets on stream many
times right Blitz Games bullet games and
they actually have done well I mean even
very respectable is what he said this is
a respectable score like it's like 10 to
like 18 or something like you beat him
10 games absolutely that's respectable
especially against Magnus so you know I
think the pressure may not be there not
as in like uh you know the fear that
usually most people may have playing
Magnus is not there with near ditsky
here but the position is saying that
what is this evolve bar talking about
you're wondering the same thing what is
this what is this evil bar talking about
here because if you take this knight
ever this G5 Pawn is in some trouble uh
so I'm wondering where the tactics are
you see the eval bar being this High
there must be some winning tactics if
this is let's analyze a little bit here
and if Bishop takes nice
okay so it is Bishop takes
it might be Knight takes D6 like
something like this right oh oh it is oh
my goodness this mates it's mate the two
Rooks it's me by themselves with this
Pawn get out of here it's gross
I guess King F6 only move and Rook f8 is
easy thank you very much bro
oh my gosh so the threat is you take
this Knight you then go and take this D6
Pawn
oh God man you lose the Rook I was
wondering like what if he takes with the
pawn then what if he takes with like the
B Pawn you still do Knight D6 what if he
takes with the c Pawn then
[Laughter]
what was DC was DC wrong too
I think DC you just go F4 and if it
takes E5 Jesus bro let's just yeah
that's a wrap oh my goodness yeah it's
not about the quantity it's about the
quality and we see how strong those
pawns would be in the center and whoa
Magnus players F4 yeah I'm gonna steal
yeah is he gonna put Knight 66 next or
Knight D4 Knight to E6 something like
that
yeah it's tough that's tough found this
broke through here break through here
wait but he oh he takes look at that
that's Carlson is so good that he could
have taken on D6 right away and he says
Ah let me throw an F4 just to free up my
next Pawn uh just in case I need it jeez
now he pushes the pawn through that is
gross man Knight to D6 is on the board
man he was holding like a beast bro I
mean I thought it was I thought he was
gonna get a draw I'm not even gonna lie
here I really thought this was going to
be a drop
in a very solid position
yeah two but the past pawns now are too
strong and Dania knows it uh the good
news for Donya even if he goes down in
this game is his Cobra teammates are
doing quite well I see a Wonder Liang is
taking down orientari that's huge news
for the Cobra fans because if if the
chess bro scored enough points in this
round the match would be over but
they're not going to get to that three
and a half that gives a fourth and final
game and we see him back as Carlson top
right his pawns reaching E6 the next
punk you go to D6 and the pawns are
gonna keep rolling up the board I think
that this one's just about done with uh
meanwhile I see Arena Crush she's about
to make a draw against Rosman Pro 2 so
that leaves a Wonder Liang to the task
of taking down orientare
yeah it's gonna be this is tough here
what is that I mean that's that's like I
don't even know what the match score is
it's like oh he's he no he's winning no
they're winning over here what is is
back and forth they're swinging on each
other and it's a draw there uh Rossman
got a draw nice we had a creeper yeah
nice okay did they split this round
I think actually the cobras are gonna
take it if uh because Brent Jacobson won
for the cobras and if Wonder Liang is
able to win his game and he does have a
huge advantage against our antari he's
up in exchange for no compensation that
one's over then the cobras will take
round three two and a half to one and a
half
okay all right Chad
there's a lot going on here yeah he's
down in peace now if you take this the
king G7 all right there's some hope with
the past pawns over here
yeah yeah no no play for you
no he's not even a check
the night covers the check over here
rotates B6 yeah and it's coming back
this way two seconds one second he moves
two seconds and if Rook F7 is Rook takes
H7 oh gross
Magnus Carlson
just a bully at this point poor Dania I
feel for him and after Rooks trade the
Knight is able to come back and stop on
The Rook goes up but now you're just
down a minor piece for no compensation
so uh this one is all Magnus Carlson and
I think dinos about to resign in a
couple turns
tough for Dania tough form at least we
get a big raid from James Marriott
thanks for the raid here wow huge raid
raid raid thanks for the rage
yeah
love that loved love to see the new uh
fans coming in watching this action
you're probably your favorite educator
Dana laritzki he is oh my gosh another
Fork Magnus just goes for every tactic
in the position Donya has to resign
he'll learn from the game but Magnus
Carlson is a monster he is not stopped
in the Pro chess League thus far
well what's the score right now is that
is it a total well okay they did take
this round though two and a half so
that's pretty good
yeah two and a half one and a half in
favor of the cobras and Ariana losing
with the white pieces to a Wonderland we
actually didn't uh give that game the
look it deserved just because Magnus and
Dania were duking out on this board here
but with it two and a half one half win
in round three a little May match win
that means the cobras are inching closer
it's six and a half to five and a half
James so
the cobras they have a real shot they do
they have this is it this is it right
here go like everything you need go to
the locker room right you know freshen
up get right you know what I'm saying
like put your pump music on for the next
few minutes here
you have to play you got to play this is
it it's all or nothing right now guys
wow three more points sorry two more so
three points for Charlotte and two for
for Canada whoever gets it that's it
that is it you are advancing the match
is over so eight and a half got some
shots left
yeah it's up in the air we'll see who is
able to take this Marquee matchup will
it be the candle chess Bros continuing
their lead or will the cobras strike
back and only find out in a few minutes
here the pro chess League day one of the
2023 season we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that's a familiar sight to many of you
in the chat they see the sports
memorabilia in the background some hats
jerseys some chess boards and things
just all around the room it is the chess
Bra House in Toronto Canada Magnus
Carlsen playing from that chair he is
the number one rated player in the world
he is also the top of the roster for the
chess Pros but James from top to bottom
this lineup is super strong absolute
super stack super stacked line up here I
mean you got a Magnus then you bring
anise Geary out okay right very strong
one of the world's best prepped and best
dressed players chess players here we
also have Jordan van for recently he's
very strong in the opening prep of
course a Novelties very strong
aggressive chest Yvonne Sark there works
with Magnus you know it's funny all
these guys have worked with Magnus at
some point or our own magnus's team so
it's kind of funny how like Canada and
chess bras come out here and just hire
Magnus in the whole team like I want you
second I want your uh yeah your third
your fifth yeah 11. I want all of them
right and that's how this team is right
now it's extremely stacked
yeah give me your second second and your
second second and now we're like getting
into mathematical tarotive that I'm not
familiar with but we do have one round
remaining and James every single match
in the protest League every individual
game is equally important so of course a
Wonder Liang gets to play against Magnus
Carlson uh but which of these four
matches sticks out to you the most
you know what okay so with this being
said let me see Magnus Ariane
Brandon and Junior for you I am going to
say the 106 out the most is the nearest
Ariana
closely very close match near ditski
after bouncing you know having that loss
wants to bounce back as the white pieces
against Ariana not as strong as Magnus
but also very very strong so
even near Disney having a position where
of course he was holding for a long time
but it just eventually fell through we
got the white pieces here he wants to
bounce back this is for the team this is
going to be huge right here so I think
the nerdinski max look at him right now
as he's studying right you know he's
thinking about everything he calculating
his next move you look at him he didn't
read look how deep he is in that book he
read all of that right now I look at
that that's fast and they saw how fast
he leads I'm gonna learn that when I go
to start crazy he actually just took in
the entire book and he did I wonder if
it was a book about openings maybe the
king's Indian or if it's just the latest
good read that he is has on his
bookshelf but either way Daniel
nerdinsky with the white pieces against
our antari huge matchup uh that you
called out is probably the biggest one
here and for me James I have to say
Arena crush with the black pieces
against Jennifer you that one rings a
bell to many of our viewers from the U.S
Women's Championship they tied they went
to tie breaks then they had to go to
Armageddon because nothing could
separate the two Jennifer you hangs a
bishop for free and still wins the
Armageddon to take her second U.S
women's championship title and now she's
the white pieces against Arena we talk
about this and it's just perfectly true
every single point counts every single
game is equally important so if I read a
crush for the cobras can take down
Jennifer you something she didn't
accomplish in the U.S women's this past
year that will help the cobras just have
a chance in this one it'll cut into the
deficit maybe erase the deficit
altogether so I read out she's
calculating she's pondering her opening
choices she will play a huge part in the
Cobra success and let's say that happens
she gets a win right I mean it's just
hypothetically if she gets a win right
then they get another win there and then
that'll be very close you'll be one away
from clinching right eight and a half in
any three in um chest bras need two so
very very very close I mean this is the
closest we've had today so it's although
it all comes down to this right here
this last match
it doesn't we are going to start with
the fourth board Jennifer and Irina
Irina she did draw that game against
razran prior to she had some chances
there but resmon uh held sturdy so she
has a half Point Jennifer has lost her
first three games that's the nature of
playing the top boards from the other
team they're super strong uh it's going
to be a tough event no matter what and
Jennifer now she gets the white pieces
against Irina Crush so she has this
fourth and final opportunity to score
some points and it could come at a
bigger time James even a draw will be
Monumental to the chess Bros and their
winning chances yeah that's true all I
need is points here and they need to try
to limit the points as hard as that is
to do Amanda say Carlson you know beats
Liang there and then the other three
yeah that could be it could go either
way like it really comes down to this
right here yeah this is this is close
this is a very close and clutch match
here
um because I think Carlson like we we
know that Carlson's a favorite obviously
but
the other three masses I mean that's
anybody's game
I wonder what the team strategy would be
your captain right so your team is down
by one point if you're the Charlotte
cobras do you tell a Wonder Liang to try
to force the draw and then have your
other three boards score two points out
of those three games like is that what
you do or do you say to wonder you're a
strong Grand Master you have white just
do your thing yeah that's exactly I
would tell them like yo just do your
thing you don't play full draw just play
your game right you know how to play
this game of course it is and Carlson is
on a rampage right now but still don't
think about that just think about these
64 squares here and what you got to do
on them so make the moves and the board
play the board and not the person it's
harder to do that if you play a Magnus
but right play the board and as much as
you can hopefully you can get something
out of it and I read a crush has to do
the same thing because she might be mad
and be looking for vengeance because uh
Jennifer you took her title from her in
this game she has the black pieces it's
a solid Triangle Pawn structure to start
this one right black says you're not
going to find a dent in my position and
Jennifer plays B3 if you ever take on C4
I'll take back with my Pawn I'll have a
strong sender a pawns a wall of Pawns
there and so it's kind of a it's gonna
be a long game this is I think this is
gonna be tough too because like Jennifer
Hughes is she just like she she was uh
lost to the um she just you know took
the ills today it's tough facing these
strong players and then you know you I
read a crush it's like you took the
title so this is just a lot of tension
for both of them Jennifer use angry I
want to win and the irina's crust is
like I need that Revenge so this one is
a very very uh you know personal match
right now
and Irina brings her Bishop out with the
pin that means that Jennifer will likely
slide her bishop and we might see some
trades here with a knight landing on e4
uh but liquidation is not something that
white is afraid of white does have more
space with her pawns you have two pawns
on the fourth rank black only has one
Pawn here in the center so a solid start
to this game uh both players trying to
figure the other out and now black has
Castle White will likely develop the
light Square bishop and Castle herself
so while these players exit the opening
stage let's take a look at the other
games that are in progress we'll zoom
out of this one for a moment because we
see that Brandon Jacobson he has the
black pieces he is performing well he is
taking on razvant priyotu whereas Daniel
laritzki made his first move in the top
right against our intari Aryan has yet
to move so why don't we actually see
what's going on there with Dania and
Aryan because it might be the second
time today and there it is
where is he he gonna afford the game
again in or are they just like no we had
enough for you Ariana you need to be
here on time I feel like they shouldn't
afford the game I mean you know we don't
make the rules I feel like you know the
one time he was given a free restart but
I think that you should be in your seat
when the games are beginning so I
believe this is on the player in this
case they know when the games are
starting so Dania just more mu played
him oh he's yeah are you kidding me what
you should be upset no I I I actually I
actually think you know if you don't
learn your lesson the first time around
it's clearly on you so uh Dania not
happy that his minute lead on the clock
is evaporated the game will restart but
let's go back to our uh four board scene
just because we do have games where the
players are actually seated and making
moves let's go to the game between
rasvin prior to with white Brandon
Jacobson with black because James these
two have been great performers for their
teams 302 has now two out of three we
saw that Brandon he yes he lost the
Magnus Carlson but he drew orientari he
defeated Jennifer you and now he is
black and this is a combative opening
this is oh this is uh what this was a
sicilian he's a rozer player so this
looks like the A6 Rosary played Bishop
G5 he took on F6 already and uh he's
very strong in these positions Brandon
Jacobson I actually played him in OTB
and was able to see you know in he
played E5 against me but I was I was
prepping his C5 like prepping this in
particular because he has a lot of games
here very strong
um as you can see B5 B4 will be coming
um a lot of times D5 is played but
should be seven capsules so this is good
this is a very good position I think for
black but also white has his trumps as
well we can play G4 H4 Rook G1 and try
to attack the king very quickly so this
is definitely going to be a battle and
it's going to be sharp in the next few
moves I think yeah sometimes black
wishes this Pawn were back on H7 because
as James is saying you're gonna play for
G5 and that pawn is going to be a hook
and you're going to be able to open up
the lines against the black king So a
resident is taking a big think here with
the white pieces he can just develop his
Bishop E2 if he wants to a patient move
he could also start throwing the pawns
for he is looking out for your move
James D5 because black can strike in the
center while white plays in the flanks
so you have to be very very careful
before you make G4 yeah absolutely yeah
be careful here G4 has to be at the
right moment and a lot of times it's
usually I would do it before casting
sometimes after castling uh usually
there's the darts for Bishop here so he
actually traded it which I'm we're used
to keeping the bishop move it back to E3
and Etc but because of this was gone the
attack usually isn't as strong after G4
wait James not a strong I know you got
your glasses the bishop's still here man
right yeah see right all right
it's hiding man it's just like a cobra
it's hard to see one wow and actually
how do we get here so you play Bishops
yeah we can quickly go through the moves
I mean just to get to the live position
so the bishop went out to G5 she's kind
of like a you know a Rouser yeah and
then later after the swap of knights in
the center and the Palm went to age six
the bishop went all the way back home so
you guys you know the scenario right
like it's never a thing this is a very
rare a rare idea so I I get why you
didn't see it but it is kind of lurking
right it's lurking in the wings waiting
for this Pawn push the bishop does
defend the square and this black king
hasn't determined where it's going it
could still Castle queenside don't count
out that possibility that actually is
quite annoying like when they Castle
Queen side here but a lot of times your
Bishop should be on E3 so you can go
Queen A7 Bishop B6 but it's not
available the bishop is not supposed to
be on C1 so it's just definitely a
strange one the division usually always
goes to E3 you can go back to F2 and G3
G4 right the bishop is definitely tucked
in there though in the corner G4 G5 is
good H4 g52 H4 H5 F4 G5 right push every
Pawn on that side of the board
and you have a nasty consequences oh B5
you're always waiting for that knew that
was coming
he's trying to trap that bishop or open
up the queen side with his pod pushes in
a team event where you're down a point
this is exactly the position you need
from Brandon Jacobson he has actually
taken no risk uh the evaluation says
that he is slightly better uh but he's
not taking any risk as far as like
natural moves and he has good chances to
try and play for a win and their
grassland goes with G4 and here for for
black do you play A5 and try to trap
this bishop uh there's many big
questions here while Brandon thinks
about his next move let's go back to our
bird's eye view because all four games
are under way and it's a big moment for
the cobras because if you look in the
bottom right Irina Crush equal material
but with a sizable Advantage according
to the evaluation part James just seems
like her pieces are controlling the
center yeah she has a nine on e4 there
it's very strong it looks like a queen's
gamma decline like a strike the the
early ones this was a sort of a strange
one with B3 and Bishop B4 played in the
bishop 56 still Queens together decline
but definitely there for a weird one but
here I mean yeah definitely black has a
huge Knight on e4 there looks good
reinforced by the other night Rook on EA
classical stuff uh you don't even have a
like a minority attack from White here
it's not even playable really like you
can't even do that so she played Bishop
C3 to maybe try to get it going or to
get rid of one of those Knights but
definitely a nice Advantage for black
here right yes controlling the space
let's go uh to the game between Magnus
Carlson and a Wonder Liang just because
uh that's a huge matchup but Wonder did
just take down our entire with the black
pieces now he gets the white pieces
against Magnus and it was a French
defense that might have come as a
surprise that's crazy but I wonder who
plays the French himself as black so we
saw a French we see just kind of a quiet
start to this game trades right nothing
too major C3 let's defend our Pawn let's
just be calm I feel like Yasser sarawan
is somewhere here just like Whispering
moves yes and this is perfect from a
wonder you were saying as a team captain
James this is the type of position you'd
want for your board one against Magnus
Carlson it's easy easy to play okay
black has no weaknesses but yeah I could
go Queenie two guys so Queen side I
could go cast so I'll probably go king
size I just don't want to but I mean I
would play my game like I like the gas
for Queen side these positions are sharp
the bishop is attacking I mean yeah I'm
definitely gonna just go Queen side
again play the game not the person so
Queenie two Castle Queen AI looks very
nice H4 also as well giving stuff to the
center and my bricks to the files and
see what black does obviously but
they're pretty solid you know this is
what exactly what you want from a Wonder
and I know we always want to look at
Magnus Carlson's game but I'm actually
going to take us away because big stuff
is happening as we go back to our four
board scene the game between Brandon
Jacobson and Raz van priyotu things are
getting Wild on that board and I'm
starting to worry for the candid chest
bras they entered this Final Round Up
six and a half five and a half but look
at the pawns go James there goes the a
pawn I know white has a B Pawn that can
be pushed at some point but there's only
one King on this flank yeah I think even
my opening Choice when I was trying to
when I had to prep against Brandon
Jacobson in the tournament I was like I
did not want to face his Sicilian I was
like man it was very good I mean I saw
he lost the game to a Wonder online it
was an online game but in this situation
but it was definitely he was very very
strong with this razor B3 right
automatic
automatic this were bullet chess you
know Brandon would play that you might
Castle first saying that it's not going
anywhere because you know white can't
really stop it but B3 let's open up all
of these lions against the white king
who's home hello right now this is very
double-edged because after the B3 I can
understand you know take take and then
Bishop takes and the question is what do
we actually do if we give black a few
moves it's gonna be Castle Rook C8 and
like Queen A5 and okay you're mating but
I mean you have to do that you actually
have to do that you have to get past G5
Rook G1 and in some cases maybe I could
even you know get away how do I get away
though Bishop something yeah there he
going for it hold on bro this might be
scary Rick CA how do you get out of this
yeah Bishop D2 and you're right yeah
right first
what do you go for this Pawn now right
you can go over B8
yeah
C Queen C yikes yeah like Bishop C4
maybe there's even D5 let's relax the
whole thing open right D5 take taken
Bishop I can like something this was a
rook A4 just going after this over here
B3 first but yeah yeah we're okay yeah
we're K4 here
there's so many moves for black
oh my gosh look at this B3 Rook takes B5
you're pinned here oh my goodness
hey man this is a family guy that's
gross Rooker B5
this pins everywhere no this is looking
terrible for Resident prior to and he's
had a good day of Chess and he should
have taken down Dan on their diski but
he scored two out of three in the first
three games and now Brandon Jacobson
with the black pieces what's G5 he's
going for I thought I thought G5 was
playable but it's scary it's very scary
I even thought about sacking a piece
here Rook C8 let you take the Knight and
go Queen A5 and just like me oh but you
know I don't think you won at all yeah I
didn't care about none of that you know
I didn't care about none of that but I
think it just doesn't work I don't know
how maybe like Bishop A4 or something or
like yeah one of these videos or
something like that yeah yeah close down
the a file and then you got to keep
capturing stuff so it looks like Brandon
he takes first and then plays Queen A5
so why give a piece when you can go for
it look at the eval bar bam it's saying
black is winning and suddenly the cobras
uh they're striking at the right moment
is a completely winning game for black
it's so simple you're gonna go deliver a
Checkmate yeah and the cobras of course
that Venom is starting to seep in and
they started they bite you and then an
hour later you're feeling a lot
different or you're not here no more and
see what happens wow it's starting to
kick in a little bit of Venom that snake
venom from the cobras is starting to
work
White's attack just too slow you need
this Rook already on G1 so you could
take on F6 and go after the black king
but Rook G1 is met by Rook C8 the queen
is about to land on A1 and The Rook
takes away the king's escape this looks
just disastrous for Resident prior to so
uh you know we of course want to pay
attention to this game about all four
results are important it's not just
about Magnus Carlson who's won his first
three games we've seen that Brandon
Jacobson he may lead the cobras not just
to tie up this match but maybe even take
it if the other results go the Cobra's
way right that's a that's very very
possible guys I mean this is at that one
point one point five and a half to six
and a half that's it two and a half for
one three for the other
and he plays Rook C1 so it's nothing oh
no mate just take I'm hitting both the
Bishops
oh God
F6 like taking off F6 Bishop F6 and then
this is tempo after Tempo could you
defend the bishop I go Rook B8 another
tempo right you move the bishop I mean
there's there's Rook B2 and the queen B2
everything B2 look at the arrows right
look at that right
and he just like slowed down and took a
pawn and his double attack as you point
not even see that I would have been
looking for checkmate with like a rook
CA Queen A1 all that fun stuff he just
says this is easily winning for black so
this looks like Brandon Jacobson you
might be the hero that the Charlotte
cobras need uh what a game from him in
the fourth and final one and preo two
down three minutes on the clock it's
minus three and change in the position
uh so we'll Zoom away from this one and
look at our other boards because it
looks like Irina crush is also doing
very well for the Charlotte cobras James
two wins for them let's go over to that
one it's a rematch of the US Women's
Championship uh the tiebreaker Was Won
by Jennifer you but today the last one
F3 played I get it you're going after
this bishop on F5 but maybe the white
king is a little bit too open yeah this
stuff yes that's true Viking is
definitely open here FC wait whose move
is it okay so is irina's move so F6 I
like it I like F6 the night goes just I
mean yeah you just move the night and I
take on G3 I don't understand
but yeah we just play F6 move the Knight
take on G3 yeah yeah like this takes you
smooth the bishop back and yeah once the
Knight moves G3 is loose and then we
have F5 Queen H4
which is uh quite scary
oh this looks no fun at all for white it
doesn't say the advantage of that huge
so that's probably why Arena has paused
as she sees that she can play this F6
move but maybe before playing F6 she'll
play Queen G5 and go after the pawns
this way just be a little bit more
active right
yeah this is a this is tough tough to
defend for whites possible what's up how
much time she got three oh man they both
running out of time she has a minute 50
to figure this out gotta move the night
but wait we could do pawn takes E4 again
the bishop E6 have pointed out with the
Knight on F3 oh that's ugly that's
ugly and Brandon Jacobson wins his game
I just saw the uh the Finish there
yeah Brandon Jacobson won a very nice
game
um oh my gosh even the end of the game
is nice like that whole game was perfect
from his perspective we'll take a look
at it in more detail a bit later but
right now F takes E4 White's Pawn
structure lots of double pawns here the
bishop is going to be kicked back if I
really doesn't move the bishop uh and
like takes this Knight this series of
Trades does not help she goes all the
way back because she wants contact with
E4 and G3
yes takes back okay Bishop C3 F6 Bishop
CA that's beautiful that's a beautiful
move there Knight F3 take on G3 yikes
everything seems wrong about this
position but uh eval Bar says uh that's
something like plus one minus one I mean
maybe Knight C4 Bishop takes G3 and like
Knight ah I don't want to bring my
knight backwards E5 you can't even play
that I mean that don't work either
sheesh I was trying to play E5 that
don't work
Irina might be getting some Revenge here
it does look like that
Jennifer down to our final minute she
needs to find a plan she plays Knight C4
that stops Queen takes Pawn but Bishop
takes and Rook F3 wow that's beautiful
oh she defends E4 by hitting this bishop
and she wants to kick it back before
playing your move James E5 you need to
get that Bishop out of there and James
this game could turn like if black is
not careful look at White's Army you
have the Knight the bishop The Rook if
you get E5 and bring another Rook over
maybe white suddenly has play against
the black king
yeah this is beautiful here E5 I like it
Rook F1 Queen B3 check maybe you also
have a knight coming into D6 in some
cases okay E5 E5 right E5 gotta go you
just gotta go with it right no no time
no time no time is that 16 seconds
[Laughter]
on takes
and oh my goodness I mean I just have to
call this out because uh we will focus
in probably on this game but if we zoom
out for a second and look at the top
left of our screens Magnus Carlson is in
trouble against a Wonder Liang the world
champion is in a dangerous precarious
situation against a youngster from the
USA let's go into that game uh I wonder
and Magnus will keep a close eye on all
of them one game is over Brad Jacobson
won but if Magnus Carlson loses the
match will be over the chess Bros will
go down
wow after having such a great start here
too and you can't count the cobras out
Chad you can't kind of look at the match
score down there look at what that says
at the bottom the match score is even
the match score is even a Wonder length
position is not so we're going to dive
right into that one the last couple
moves were fascinating we saw that
Magnus took upon an A2 magnets up one
Pawn B3 give me a second Pawn Rook B1
your Bishop is pinned and Magnus
probably hoping that A5 A4 happens
quickly enough but there's an issue that
when does Knight captures the enemy
Knight on F6 the queen can no longer
take back you have to take with your G
Pawn that means your king is not very
safe the queen will replace the Knight
after the Knight takes the enemy Knight
and there's going to be a vicious attack
against the black king a Wonder laying
by the way up nearly three minutes on
the clock oh yeah that's that's and
there it is he's going for A5 which is
probably the only way that he could do
things here these French middle games
are actually some of the most tactical
you will ever see for both sides because
white is trying to rip your head off
here and black is counter-attacking left
and right so of course as you see white
is just trying to go for May black on
the other hand I have a pass a pawn here
and I'm up so if I'm able to you know
get out of your stuff or your checks or
whatever you're trying to do I'm going
to be okay
wow actually good point because this
King might Dart to E7 it could be pretty
safe there you don't really want to take
this Pawn on H6 your king is in the line
of fire so after Queen E4 king f8 or
something like that maybe A4 first but
check King f8 I don't think you take
this Pawn you might just get checkmated
yeah check into right yeah we might get
checkmated geez that is crazy white
could be in trouble here this could
definitely turn they love white so we're
gonna check and then what's the
follow-up
it runs away
idea check oh check Bishop C4
oh James with the taxes let's show that
real quick A4 check Bishop C4 your
Bishop is pinned because your Queen's
behind it threatening Checkmate over
here maybe the queen has to go back you
can't bring the Rook up that's Checkmate
here yeah I mean probably has to go but
then you can even just take this and
take it yeah and maybe we're pushing for
more in it H6 is now hanging right so
there's some possibilities there
nice fine by you the bishop C4 is classy
and necessary and that's why Magnus deep
in the think tank he is now down to a
minute and 35 seconds whereas his
opponent is 449 bad news for Carlson uh
but uh Magnus he's gonna need this for
his team because his teammates are
really in some trouble he goes Rook see
it and that's a bad move apparently it's
a blender wow look at the bar go crazy
let's go right back into that game
actually between a wonder and Max I see
what it is I see the reason why this
problem check you just go put forcing
you can bring your queen take this Pawn
with check it looks like black is the
one for choice
a Wonder Liang is a beast at bug house
he sees tactics like this he plays it
okay find his check the queen is losing
magazine goodness he's busted he's
completely busted here
Magnus about to go down
magnets are about to go down here and
that makes it a one point game where it
looks like Arena crush is actually
winning her game as well
we know the Charlotte chess Center they
were saying don't count out the cobras
it looked like they were down and out
but suddenly Charlotte Rises to their
best in the final match of Wonder Liang
has Bishop B5 check Bring em all to the
party and he's gonna beat Magnus Carlson
in this game he's gonna be well you know
what there's still some tricks Bishop B5
Queen takes B5 maybe you've got Queen
Ace three check first because after Rook
takes Rook h8 maybe yeah because if you
take the Rook Queen h8 then Rook check
and then King back
but then I'm still up though The
Bishop's hanging yeah I'm up I'm up in
exchange at the end yeah A4 I mean I'm
still waiting no I should be winning
that you want Bishop
Magnus sort of was praying for counter
play there but he finds the check I just
might just throw in the towel right now
I saw the Charlotte chess Center uh
chatting everyone is about to lose their
Channel points and you see Magnus he has
resigned he's mentally out of it and he
just knows that this game is over I
wonder Liang a hero for the Cobras for
real I mean right as you said what would
you tell a Wonder bro just play your
game just go in there I got Magnus I
gotta play The One and Only just play
your game bro and he played his game and
I mean to open a choice for Magnus there
for instance hey you know wrenches are
like this but sometimes they're very
strong work takes the a-o my goodness
still fighting not giving up no you can
you can do is you could take this Rook
it's like Queen f8 check and queen takes
F7 check because the bishop will have to
take and your queen is Left unguarded
Behind it that's beautiful that's
beautiful you got to play on because
he's trying he has to try to you know
milk the clock as much as I can eight
and a half does it oh gets eight and a
half first it is tied up seven two seven
eight and a half is the score
no this is just really tragic for the
chest bras uh they put together such a
monster lineup and right now Rook takes
C8 looks pretty simple and the cobras
are taking them down because I read a
crush and Jennifer you drew their game
wow that's actually Drew not good for
the how did they draw that I don't know
what happened there wow wait wow that
was a
it must have been a Perpetual or
something
yeah maybe it was very virtual Jennifer
was defending that pretty well we see in
the bottom right wait how is that a draw
the eval Bar says that black is just
crushing no pun intended
oh look at the time price might offer
maybe yeah they they have repetition
okay I'll bring it up quickly and then
we'll go right back to uh the game if we
can but we see that um the game was
drawn by repetition uh which is going to
be unfortunate for arena the queen went
to E4 The Rook went up back and forth
that's what happens when you're playing
bullet chess yeah yeah who you don't
know your minus four you don't know what
the result should be
white can't really move and that's
playing down a bishop let's go to one
game I mean unless you know if some type
of crazy Swindle in magnus's game but
uh their discus game is the last is the
one if somebody comes out with a win
and that's it
yes and you know we can wait on wonder
Liang here and then we'll go right into
the narrow Disney game against orientare
because uh Aryan will need to win that
game is no choice but to beat Daniel
nerdinski that is something that the
world struggles with you and we see I
wonder he's doing it he calculated this
to the end that's what he was doing he
was a big shirt this is easy for white
yeah he didn't want to you know give
Magnus any type of chances like it's
Magnus Carlsen don't give him no chances
he takes on F7 finds the move take date
and that's done
so they went to even oh what's happening
oh man bro that's crazy chess is like
this is ridiculous how is this a draw
you gotta be kidding me
um
he's kicked out no way Madness could win
this game he could it's very possible
work B5 he has to go directing Rook beef
oh maybe not okay where's he going with
the Rook that's what I thought oh
you might just run this way back around
but the bishop will lock it in once you
get this Pawn here the bishop comes to
B1 and The Rook is locked on A1 oh it's
locked in there he misses it
okay wait he goes up
he decides to go up here which means The
Rook can stay behind the pawn forever
that's good news for you I wonder and we
can push the f and g is our goal and try
to walk those boys through get the king
active too as well uh Magnus shaking his
head here he doesn't know he's like ah I
probably had to draw right 11 seconds so
it's hard to do that in 11 seconds
but what if Magnus ends up pushing his
pawn and bring his King to B6 you will
kick this Rook away because if it goes
up you go back and if it goes up you go
back we might see a repetition of the
sort there
might be right there actually and then
my king is too far away you can actually
walk your king up to try to take the C3
Pawn while distracting the rook and by
uh pushing the a pawn to to keep that
under control so if we get to take the C
Pawn then the b-pawn gets rolling and
who's winning
and that's the great thing about Bishops
right it protects A4 also covers the
promotion Square so F4 plate Max has to
play B5 if G5 will see a swap and a king
going right to B6 trying to kick this
Rook away Magnus Carlsen might hold this
game I really think that it's uh kind of
the trajectory is more towards a
magnet's draw than a Wonder win he had
right exactly right which has like
Magnus effect the magnet straw what is
going on right Maxie how does he do it
you know chess is too hard Greg exactly
I don't know how Magnus does it it
looked completely lost it was completely
lost and now he was King B7 and if Rook
A5 King then we might see a draw by
repetition jeez
okay
he's going for now this is what oh but
his well this is a race right right this
is yeah
you were saying what if that King just
goes for C3 right and the bishop yeah
he's gonna go back but if these pawns
were connected this would probably be
ruining for white I think but here we
can walk the king up take the pawn sack
the bishop for that pawn you gotta walk
the king all the way up oh I can't cross
oh yeah that's a thing Kingston Rook A1
I can't cross no the king can't cross me
is he trying to go this way now
oh he could be going that way yeah he
could run up that way
um
oh because rookie went out king E4 he's
crossing a little bit slower but he's
making sure his King gets in over here
man in the water down to seven seconds
he might lose this game get out of here
oh hold on to your hash chat oh my oh my
gosh Here Comes The King
oh it's waiting for black how does
Magnus Carlson do this
take it he just takes this Pawn the
bishop the long range piece covers G8
protects A2 the black king sleds in and
Magnus Carlson is winning in this
position he's actually just gonna use
the second Pawn James Canty is nowhere
to be seen but a victory or Magnus a w
will appear and look at one oh man you
see it you see it I mean he probably
says adult language just now
a Wonder Liang could have had four out
of four today but look at Magnus shakes
his head yeah he's like I got away with
this I got away with it you know I mean
let me sip out the chest bra mug here
hmm yeah that was losing yeah oh yeah
you're not losing
look at oh I feel so badly for a Wonder
Liang right now because he just had the
upper hand all game was much better
winning position he went for the
simplification but it wasn't simple so
we do still have one game going and now
that Magnus Carlson has won Daniel
naroditski needs to take down orientare
so let's go to that last game with
orientare on screen he has the black
pieces against Daniel narzitski and
James it's a wild Affair here with
Bishop oh my gosh
they said G4 open up
open up and
what's the deal already done it 20
seconds
what is happening what is this Pawn
structure what is this Pawn structure
though and then the G outf okay there's
almost Quincy for it almost works it
should be six yeah right
barely sheesh
and what's the materials black up a pawn
somehow
what a weird position
wow
what's going on here does I don't even
know the score that's the big question
because oh yeah players they're so
focused on their game does he know that
a Wonder lost that one
I still can't believe you lost that one
I'm just I am still baffled by that one
that was uh that was a classic Magnus
effect I have never seen that before
and now we're down to a bullet scramble
so Bishop E6 only move Bishop takes E4
Queen takes E4 that would force the
Queens off and I think that Donya has to
play Queen C at the Rio let's keep those
Queens on the board James keep the
fighting chances alive keep it alive
definitely set up there it was like what
it should be can you do that so he takes
on e4 really tricky stuff here this is
crazy takes who's better why uh oh it
might be
I thought G7 is a bit loose hey oh
Diane's down in time travel too didn't
he have a Time Edge I thought he had a
time in it she had a huge time hits he
invested all of his time trying to
figure out this queen trade Dania wants
C6 and to cement this Pawn on a dark
square if you go A4 maybe this Rook can
capture it uh but the series of Trades
uh after that C5 would be looser what
about C6 now
Bishop can take this Pawn
oh my gosh arya's in big trouble he's
down to five seconds
take this Pawn no you take
take everybody take well we're about to
see as you said everybody's gonna take
all of us
I don't think Donya knows the match
score because he would not have made
this game a draw yeah
it's a draw now you take A4 66 and oh my
goodness Magnus Carlsen was about to
save the chess Bros draw by agreement
and that's it
that is it oh my gosh that's it the
chess bras we're leading this match
after the second round of action they
somehow win this match it didn't look
that way we thought that Jennifer you
was going to lose to Arena crush the
final position was actually winning for
Irena but they didn't have time Magus
Carlsen was dead lost against a Wonder
Liang he still wins that game so the
chess Bros win eight and a half seven
and a half and I think we're just
shocked
yeah we're shocked guys I mean that that
we didn't know what was going to happen
I thought the car was the Venom was
kicking in finally and the cobras
started biting everybody and then
finally the chest bras didn't put out in
the clutch clutch came here I mean that
was crazy like it literally Magnus
should have lost and he didn't it's very
tough as the pressure was on time
trouble and all but at the end of the
day the chest bras are the one that
moved on what what a score like one
point bro one point has
that would have gone the other way right
the right and the chess Bros win but
Magnus was lost Jennifer you was in
trouble but both of those players
survived when it had to happen and I
just have to you know or the cobras and
a Wonderland in particular he played an
excellent day of Chess he outplayed the
number one player on the planet he just
altered down the stretch and in fact
lost that game we could have had tie
breaks James everybody loves tie break
everybody like oh my Armageddon and tie
brace right you know we could have had
more chess here today but I know one
thing about that that Charlotte Cobra's
team is very strong because the Canadian
team is absolutely stacked so for them
to be able to go neck and neck one game
basically almost beating you by I mean
one game that was it it was like a one
game match here I mean they have a lot a
very bright future I think here in a
pretty UCL
yeah because in this league you need to
win three matches to make it to the
playoffs and you don't get eliminated
until you lose three matches I think
it's gonna be hard to take down the
cobras uh but we saw two results now in
the Pro chess League season uh earlier
today uh we had the Indian yogis leading
the Brazil capybara so that was a big
win for the yogis and then we just saw
the can of Chess Bros beat these
Charlotte cobras tomorrow James I think
you're gonna be a pretty busy man your
Garden State passers take on the levels
of Chess Wizards and then after that the
Spanish uh Maniac shrimps they take on
the Norway nose how excited are you to
see your team play tomorrow I'm excited
we got the big people going over here
we're gonna see Shaq uh Shaq from uh the
Wizards are going to play David paravian
you got Dennis lazovic and then on our
side we got Sam Sabian gossane off uh
Linderman and Trisha Kanye morala so uh
definitely hard to say that but she's a
definitely a strong player very strong
so it's gonna be a nice matchup tomorrow
our boys are and and girls are ready so
it's gonna be good um more chess
tomorrow so we're excited gotta get our
head in the game
and we just said nerdinski in the chat
saying that uh Casa Casa how do you
pronounce that the chess God I never
knew how to pronounce it
not on our site today that's okay we see
you swinging big fella come on that
Venom was out there that Cobra Venom is
real
it certainly is and uh well you know the
Cobra Venom is real but the chess bras
are a team that are not to be trifled
with that chest broth Squad is stacked
from top to bottom Magnus Carlson he led
the way today with a perfect four out of
four but it was imperfect play the score
Still Remains perfect for him and is a
perfect start for the chess Brothers all
they want is to win their matches they
don't care how wide the margin is right
I don't care how you win it or how it's
done whether it's sloppy whether it's
clean who's moving on at the end of the
day right the match and of course we
have some great chefs today and uh the
first match was with the shogi's there
or uh Indian uh Indian yogis Indian
Yogi's right there they did a good job
there was a dominating match but then
this one was so close a nail biter we
didn't know who was going to win even
then it looks like Canada being a big
favorite it was uh down to the wire one
game very exciting it it was down to the
wire it was a fun match and well we are
going to take a short break but when we
return we are going to have an interview
with a special guest none other than
Eric Hansen of Chess bra Fame you'll
want to hear his thoughts and very a
great start for his team it was a bit
shaky but they got it done so let's
see you in a few minutes we'll have Eric
Hansen joining us to talk about the
protesting
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
and we are joined by chess bra team
captain Eric Hansen Eric congratulations
to your team on what was a fascinating
first uh match win but I got to ask you
as the captain how nervous were you
during the fourth and final round of
games
yeah the the fourth and Final Round uh
reminded me of uh of uh when I hear
stories from captains uh at the chess
Olympia that their nerves just get
destroyed I mean
um
I did not like in my head it wasn't a
big possibility that in the final round
there was Magnus that was going to lose
this game and that that another player
would have to win to make up the deficit
I thought you know what uh Charlotte's
really tough it might go to overtime but
at some point it looked like we might
lose three one three and a half half and
I mean Aryan wasn't at his board uh
rather than lost right away it was like
everything that could go wrong was going
wrong for absolutely a solid 5-10
minutes there and I just like couldn't
watch the the screen
yeah I mean it must have been
nerve-wracking for you and some of the
players are in the house so I think a
question that's relevant here is like
how important is that to you and the
team for camaraderie purposes to have RN
and Magnus playing from your location
yeah I always uh always like to have uh
people in-house when possible because
yeah you absolutely can when it comes to
like team building uh also just making
sure everyone's on on a good setup and
ready to play in like a comfortable
environment being able to have more
control over that
um is good because a lot of players are
still fairly new to playing uh serious
events online where you know there's a
lot that's been invested in Fair Play
and all that all the equipment around it
that everyone's in a comfortable
environment but for us uh some people
might know we've done a lot of team
building the last last week so at least
uh I was feeling I was very excited for
for this moment where we could have two
people playing in-house Magnus for the
first time Aryan for the second time he
played a couple years ago from Canada as
well and
um you know it's nice to have some
coffee service Water Service snack
service while you're playing a game so I
hope the players appreciate it as well
well of course A lot has been said about
Magnus and Aryan but I got to ask you
the match as a whole I mean it was from
the start a very close match uh what
about resin prior to it seemed like he
was performing super well for your squad
what goes into your decision making
bring a player like him onto your roster
yeah so I was with rasmine at the
Olympiad and he was around 24 40 20 for
50 feet a which is lower than what I
thought he should be I was like what
what's happening there and I think he
had some bad luck playing tournaments
with uh oh hello and but it's but
recently he's gained 50 points since the
Olympiad he I think he tied for first or
did very well in the recent Charlotte
event and I just like I've been
following his games and and seen his
ability to like beat Strong Grand
Masters and he's on the upswing right
now and and he works hard on his game so
I I do think there's quite a few players
on a roster that are young ambitious
players that that uh have have uh room
to grow like that can provide like uh
more than you might expect from the
rating and then Raz band definitely
lately is being good
um and that definitely was uh a player I
wanted from the start he was one of the
first players I reached out to he's
played for us I think once actually he's
never played for us sorry but it was one
of my my first Targets in the off season
yeah so it's a bit chaotic here I felt
that in an intruder here for a second
we'll we'll forgive you I mean we know
how much fun is happening at the
chessboard house but I just want to
follow up on that point you made because
a lot of people pay attention to the
superstars who are assigned so you said
Resident was actually one of the first
signings that your team had what goes
into making the roster how did you put
it together
yeah well I wanted to make sure
um we were sticking with the name Canada
chest Pro so part of the Canadian
identity have some Canadian players uh
on the roster and rosvan
um stood out because he's had some good
results he seems ambitious when he plays
like when he's playing strong GM's like
he tries to beat them he has very sharp
style of play and I and I uh I need
players who are solid but also players
that are willing to push push against
anybody willing to take risks to score
points and just overall just like
ambitious because it's a super
competitive league I mean I knew as soon
as the rules were announced uh this 2550
rating cap uh means there's a lot of
strategy and so
um you know you want to be represented
well with like the high-end boards
because of the the rating caps uh the
women's side of things Junior side of
things and and just overall I wanted the
identity to be uh you know for me
younger ambitious underrated
enjoying enjoying playing uh rapid and
online games like most of our players
play fairly regularly online so
um but just I guess it's a mix of
analytics which is not a lot of
interests and just uh enjoying general
manager duties where it's like you know
what I've been playing a lot of fantasy
football I'm going to take that to chess
and see see where I can get some good
pickups but um razvan in terms of
Canadian chess is one of the Premier
players so uh for me it was uh
if we have young ambitious players in
Canada I want this to be a nice platform
for them to play against the best
players in the world
well you know you're talking about your
roster configuration free agents
signings Magnus Carlson the biggest
signing you could possibly get so the
question we got from bgh was how much
did the Magnus affect like we saw in the
game against a Wonder factor into your
recruiting strategy
uh it was definitely definitely a factor
because that was a heartbreaking loss
for Wonder I've been there a lot of
other
players have been there and it's just
hard to quantify right I mean outside of
Magnus maybe Hikaru has that effect to
an extent as well but playing the world
champion and even getting a winning
position playing a great game
you just second guess like it's just
crazy how you can even manage those
nerves for 20 30 moves like you're at
the finish line and then that that
feeling of uncertainty uncertainty still
Creeps in at the very end right at the
finish line and that that's like the
magnet is just like so frustrating no
matter how disciplined you are about
your mentality it it still can happen at
any moment in the game even when you
have the game wrapped up so
um I thought it'd be a big boost to our
team morale but also just our actual
team strength to have uh have Magnus on
board and uh today was a a good example
of it uh first three games look
professional final game that was like
just an insane insane comeback uh to
witness
yeah he actually you know allowed
himself to smile for a second he
couldn't believe it himself uh well we
know what Magnus is capable of doing on
the chessboard we do have a question
from lost in the woods saying what is
the Highlight so far of having Aryan and
Max at the house so obviously I'm sure
there's some things that people have
seen on social media but what's been the
highlight for you
I would say probably uh two highlights
one of them is Pub chess but a big one
was going to the hockey game uh taking
the boys to to a hockey game and on
Saturday night uh just had a big crowd
there
they got to see the ice up close and it
was a fun game it was really fun game so
I'd say invading a chess Pub and then
doing a good old-fashioned hockey game
probably probably the two best right now
but now with this moment that might be
I said if we won today we'd go the NBA
game the Raptors playing today and I was
already like making plans to not go
during the final round but we squeaked
out a win so uh gonna treat the boys out
to some basketball
Jennifer's not here she's also on the
team but I know she's at school and yeah
Ross van is also at school I think so
I'll take the locals locals out
well it makes it sound like you're the
dad of the house like you are
determining what's going on you'll buy
the tickets yeah so is that your role
yeah you know chess players you gotta
like Usher them I mean uh if we're in
our natural habitat we'll be on the
couch watching these streams hanging out
playing some Blitz on the phone just I
don't know Finding ways to pass time and
at least I want to have a little bit of
a touristy experience where they see
some of what Toronto has to offer
well you know some of the best Toronto
gotta pitch them on visiting again so
that we can keep having uh having this
the players play from the house
well I mean it sounds like you have a
bunch of chess players in your house in
your life but there was a chess player
who also is professional in another
sport I think you posted on Instagram a
photo with Joey Votto so what has your
relationship with him been like how into
chest is he what's the deal there
yeah yeah
um Joey I think Joey's now uh in spring
training or starting soon but um he got
into chess or at least I I met him
during covid virtually and uh uh you
know we worked on a bit of Chess
together and uh he played his first
tournament recently uh in Canada like a
one once a week Monday night thing and
yeah being hanging out with him a bit
because he does spend some time here
he's from Toronto but plays for the Reds
uh obviously so during the off season
get to hang out a little bit indulge in
some sports whether it's UFC basketball
or or some chess but he's gone a lot
better and he's been just working on
that on his own as well and and I think
part of that is like he's got teammates
to play with but at the end of the day
like chess has gone a lot more popular
in the last few years so I think Joey's
been really interested in and he's a bit
more of a cerebral player for baseball
standards both like how he analyzes the
game approaches everything so chess to
me seemed like a normal fit for him and
he really likes it but I wouldn't be
surprised to see some other players a
more continuous stream of professional
athletes uh playing chess in the off
season or playing tournaments or just
adding that to their uh to their hobby
list
yeah for sure Eric I mean it's awesome
to see more and more players get into
the game and it's the off season for you
now at least for a week the chess for us
uh you get they gotta take a little
break before your next protesting match
I know you'll be back streaming so uh
just want to thank you for giving us the
time here and best of luck in the
upcoming matches
oh absolutely no thank thanks for having
me on I my first impression so far is uh
like no offense to the air things
Masters last week but I love team
formats this was super exciting win or
lost like you know people watching the
audience they probably loved it because
it was totally unclear what was going to
happen and like when you get to see
you know Magnus play against players he
doesn't always play like the imbalances
from all the Ross pairings that's
exciting like I I thought it was a like
very entertaining and I'm looking
forward to the rest of the season
because I I don't think people should
consider there to be like a big gap
between teams there's a lot of parody Or
with the rules that have been introduced
again or reintroduced so so like
anything can happen and we were like one
moment away from clearly losing this
match and that would have just been a
huge shocker if you asked everybody when
they're up 5-3 I mean we're probably
heavy heavy favorites and Charlotte just
came back and uh yeah like
near-death experience so uh I'm looking
forward to the season both as a manager
player but also a spectator so
appreciate you having me on as well
I appreciate that Eric and you're making
me want to play so I might have to you
know just get on a roster here made a
chess Bros they don't think you guys
need me uh but maybe I'll find a squad
to get on and play a few if they if
we're allowed to have a practice squad I
can guarantee that to start a practice
squad but you know we just throw a
limited to having 10 people or maybe
somebody gets injured if somebody gets
injured I can put them uh
on the injury list then a spot opens up
then yeah elevated so so yeah you know
we can we can figure it out
I appreciate that Eric well uh always
good to hear from you congrats again to
the team and we look forward to seeing
so much more from you know you guys in
the protesting and always on your
channel so we'll tune to your stream
sometime soon
appreciate that thanks Robert
thanks Eric you heard it from Eric
Hansen Grand Master the chess bras team
captain uh his team went on to win eight
and a half seven and a half over the
Charlotte cobras as Eric himself said it
could have gone either way Magnus
Carlson scores a comeback Victory
against a Wonder Liang and that was the
Difference Maker between these two tough
teams so it's been a very fun first day
the Indian yogis made things look kind
of easy against the Brazil Capybaras but
as Eric gave a lot of thoughts in that
interview uh when is this team format
there are no clear favorites for the
most part even when you have Magnus
Carlson that does not mean your team is
just going to run away with things so
tomorrow's action will include the
levitov chest of wizards against the
Garden State passers James Canty captain
of the Garden State passers and the
laptop chest Wizards have the likes of
Shakira mamajaro and the chess Queen
Alexandra costenio and the Spanish Mania
next trip they won the qualifier they
earned their way here they take on the
Norway gnomes I believe Anna Rudolph is
the team captain of the Norway gnomes
they have an Olympic Hammer I believe
David Howell was just signed to their
roster as well so it's going to be an
interesting set of matches tomorrow but
that will have to wait another day for
those of you who spent your February
14th with us I know it's because you
love chess and there is so much more
chess this week Thursday and Friday we
see more double headers I personally
love many of the logos the bottom one on
the Thursday schedule that is the Gotham
chess Knights spearheaded by Hikaru
Nakamura they take on the Berlin bears
and then Friday's action the last
matchup will be the gobletor led the
Croatia
team is playing the California unicorns
which is led by the chest Dojo Squad
including David Pruis and coaster
kabutski if you see the St Louis
archbishops Shanghai tigers everywhere
you look MGD one Squad from India
they're all these powerful teams the pro
chess league is a unique format it is a
team event of four players each and
every match take part and they get to
play everyone on the opposing team
Magnus Carlson led the way with four
wins in his games but it was not easy
and it will never be easy here in the
protesting but today's action has come
to a close it is Valentine's Day so
celebrate with your special Someone by
watching more and more chess see you
tomorrow on the protesting it's been a
pleasure I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
tomorrow's action will be another
doubleheader so it wants to tune in for
that see you then everybody
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]